GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
EXACTLY AT NINE THIRTY WE'RE
GOING TO GET STARTED TO ONE
WELCOME EVERYONE.
AS WELL AS OUR CO CHAIRS SO FOR
THIS HEARING.
DR -- WORK
AS WELL AS A MISTER BLOOM.
AT THIS HEARING IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO OPEN --
THE CONVERSATION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON THE ISSUE OF SAFE.
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
HOW TO MANY PEOPLE IN THIS STATE
ALONG WITH PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT?
THE SALINAS VALLEY CENTRAL
VALLEY AND OF NNOUNCED A
CALIFORNIA DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
WHETHER WELLS HAVE BEEN
CONTAMINATED OR THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO CONSOLIDATE WITH
NEARBY WATER SYSTEMS THE NEED IS
DIRE FOR THOSE.
UNABLE TO DRINK CLEAN WATER.
IN SOME AREAS STATE HAS MONEY
READY TO GO TO BILL TREATMENT
PLANTS.
REPORTS WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
OPERATE AND MAINTAIN THOSE PLANS
THERE LOCALLY IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF THESE PROJECTS --
UNFORTUNATE CANNOT MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THIS HEARING WE HOPE TO
LEARN ABOUT THE ISSUE FURTHER --
INFORMATION AND DETAILS OF HOW
TO APPROACH THIS COMPLEX ISSUE.
AND HAVE THE DIALOGUE WITH MANY
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE HERE
TODAY AND MOVING FORWARD WE ARE
COMMITTED TO TO CONTINUE
DIALOGUE TO GET TO A PLACE OF
COMMON INTEREST --
I BELIEVE WE CAN ACHIEVE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
BUT FIRST WE HAVE TO KIND OF
BREAK DOWN SOME OF THESE.
ISSUES SILOS THAT EXIST AND TO
BRING UP ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER --
WE'RE HERE TO LISTEN.
AND HOPEFULLY COME UP WITH SOME
GOOD.
TANGIBLE A NEXT STEPS AND PUBLIC
POLICY SOLUTIONS IN ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE --
BEFORE I INTRODUCED A CENTER
MORNING I'D LIKE TO ASK A MISTER
BLOOM AND FOLLOWED BY MISTER
QUICK TO SAY A FEW OPENING
REMARKS.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THERE WE GO --
MORNING EVERYONE AND THANK YOU
CHAIR GARCIA --
THANK YOU FOR A TO OUR STAFF FOR
PUTTING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
TOGETHER --
IT IT SO ALMOST A CANARD AT THIS
POINT --
THAT ALMOST EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN THE STATE REPEATS --
AD NAUSEAM --
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS TO MEMBER IN
A TED TALK TO OTHER FOLKS --
AND AND IF I THINK EVERYBODY
ELSE'S SACRAMENTO DOES THE TWO
WERE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
AND THEREFORE WHY CAN'T WE WELL
IN THE BLACK AND ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT WOULD SEEM MOST
OBVIOUS IS OUR SEEMING INABILITY
TO PROVIDE.
A CLEAN DRINKING WATER TO EVERY
CALIFORNIA.
I'D ALMOST A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE THAT
ACCESS TODAY THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE THE THESE FOLKS ARE
SPREAD OUT IN OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND SO. TOO MANY OF
US THEY'RE NOT SEEN ON A DAILY
BASIS BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT --
PUTTING TOGETHER A GROUP OF A
MILLION PEOPLE.
STANDING SHOULDER TO SHOULDER.
YOU CAN VISUALIZE THE EXTENT OF
THIS ISSUE AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD FRANKLY BE
ASHAMED OF HI WE HAVE.
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS ACROSS
THE STATE --
AND WE NEED A SUSTAINABLE
FRAMEWORK TO PERMANENTLY SOLVE
THIS CRISIS NOT IN THE WAY THAT
WE'RE DOING IT NOW BY TRUCKING
IN WATER AND MAKING PEOPLE ARE
YOU KNOW BRING BOTTLED WATER
INTO THEIR HOMES.
OF WE ALL.
HAVE A RIGHT TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER IN FACT CALIFORNIA LAWS OF
AS OF A FEW YEARS AGO STATES
THAT.
IT'S A IT'S A A HUMAN RIGHTS AND
A VERY BASIC.
ONE UP FRANKLY I THINK UGH A
GIVEN THE YEOMAN'S EFFORT --
TO THAT SENATOR MINING HAS PUT
INTO THIS AND THE FACT THAT THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN IN FRONT OF US
NOW FOR MULTIPLE YEARS --
WE WISH WE SHOULD BEAR SOME
SHAME AND NOT HAVING ADDRESSED
THIS ISSUE ADEQUATELY AT AT AT
AT THIS POINT.
AND IT'S UP TO US TO GET IT DONE
THIS YEAR SO THAT'S WHY THIS
PANEL IS SO IMPORTANT AND
LOOKING FORWARD --
TO EACH AND EVERY PRESENTATION --
AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE [inaudible]
LOOK DOCTOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WHERE ONE STATE --
THE GOVERNOR SAD --
THAT WE HAVE.
TO UP PAY MORE ATTENTION TO THE
RURAL AREAS WE HAVE TO IT IS.
EVERY ONE OF US A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY LEGISLATORS AND THE
GOVERNOR IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
TO TAKE CARE OF THE LEAST AMONG
US.
I'M FORTUNATE TO COME FROM THE
DISTRICT THAT HAS GREAT WATER --
WE HAVE THE SF SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES LARRY AND A
COUPLE OF LOCAL WATERSHEDS.
WE HAVE EAST BAY MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT WHICH GETS
WATER FROM THEM.
MCCOLLUM THE RIVER --
AND OTHER PLACES WE ALSO HAVE --
IN THIS SOUTHERN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT'S THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT WE HAVE
THE MONEY TO TAKE BRACKISH WATER
AND TURN IT INTO CLEAN.
DRINKABLE WATER.
THERE ARE MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY DON'T HAVE THE
ORGANIZATION --
WE CAN ALL AGREE ON MANY WAYS TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM GAPS SMALL
DISTRICTS ABSORBED BY LARGER
ONES TO GIVE TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
BUT IN THE END THE DIFFICULT
PART IS COMING UP WITH THE MONEY.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE CENTER
MINING FOR BRINGING FORWARD LAST
YEAR IS SB SIX TO THREE WHICH WE
PASSED.
HOWEVER WHEN WE PASSED IT WE
LEFT OUT THE DIFFICULT PART
WHICH IS WHERE THE MONEY COMES
FROM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT
ANSWER TO THAT IS RIGHT NOW BUT
THAT'S CLEARLY THE BIGGEST
QUESTION IT'S THE ONLY QUESTION
THAT.
THAT REALLY IS UP THERE I DO
PLEDGE THAT IF WE CAN BRING
SOMETHING TO THE FLOOR.
I WILL SUPPORT IT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT IS AND SO I'M MAKING A
COMMITMENT BEFORE IT COMES TO
THE FLOOR.
BUT I THINK THAT GETTING THAT
MONEY IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING AND WHETHER IT'S FROM THE
GENERAL FUND WHETHER IT'S A
SPECIAL TAX WHATEVER IT IS
THAT'S THE TOUGH PART THAT'S THE
PART.
THAT SENATOR MINING IS GOING TO
HAVE TO WORK VERY HARD WITH
LEADERSHIP ON AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY AND IF WE
DON'T DO IT WE ARE SHIRKING OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY I SEE IT'S A
VERY LARGE HEARING --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
GETTING US TOGETHER --
AND FOR INCLUDING ME AND MY
COMMITTEE AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AS WELL.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
I THINK EVERYONE'S NOTED YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A BILL FOR A IS
COMPLEX PROBLEM.
GET --
THAT'LL HAVE YOU BEEN EITHER
LET'S OPEN UNITS CAN ALSO
COMBINE YEAH THEY ALMOST --
BUT DOES IT IS STYLE THE
CALIFORNIA CAN BE IN IN A WHAT
WHAT IS THE THEM UP AN IMPORTANT
THING WHICH IS NOT JUST BECAUSE
DEMóCRATAS LOCALS.
STUMBLED LEAST WE DISCUSS IT
WILL BE ANNOYING IS COMING IN A
MUCH OF THE BUSES PORTS --
BUT TO SEE BUT SOON I'M GOING TO
NOW GOING TO INTRODUCE ENOUGH.
SENATOR MINING.
AND HE WILL --
FRAME THE ISSUE FOR US IS MAYBE
NO SIR MONNING HAS LED THE
SENATE.
EFFORT TO ADDRESS A SAFE IN A
FOUR WHEEL DRINKING WATER FOR A
FEW YEARS NOW.
AND WE WELCOME HIM TO LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED TIME
BOTH TOGETHER AS WE GO UP AND
DOWN THE STATE CALIFORNIAN HERE
FOR MARCUS STATUETTES.
BUT THE ISSUE AND WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO HAVE HIM JOIN US ON THE
PANEL AFTER HE SPEAKS OF
CEREMONY FOR YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
CHAIRED GARCIA WE WHEN IS THE
ESTIMATE THAT* POOREST
OPPORTUNITY THAT.
I WANT TO THANK YOUR CO CHAIRS
BLOOM AND QUIRK ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO JOINED US TODAY --
I ALSO WANNA A PARTICULAR LINK
KNOWLEDGE THOSE LITTLE COMMON
THE FLIGHTS AFTER MY PRELIMINARY
TESTIMONY. FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP.
IN THESE EFFORTS AND FOR ALL
MENTAL SEARCH OF A SOLUTION FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
I THINK THIS WILL BE YOUR
PROVIDING A VERY VALUABLE FORM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR WHAT MAY
BE DIVERGENT VIEWPOINTS ON SOME
OF THE SOLUTIONS.
I THINK WE'LL HEAR A STRONG AND
RESONANT AGREEMENT ON THE
GRAVITY OF THE PROBLEM IN THE
CHALLENGE THAT NEEDS A SOLUTION --
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS.
EFFORTS IN THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTED BY FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN AND NOW THE
LEADERSHIP OF GOVERNOR NEW SOME.
HAS ALSO PUT THIS FRONT AND
CENTER -- IN
TERMS OF THE STATE'S BUDGET IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC AWARENESS --
AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
THE PROBLEM AND I'M GONNA RECITE
THIS WHAT IS TOO MANY NOW ALMOST
A MANTRA.
BUT BEARS REPEATING BECAUSE OF
THE GRAVITY OF THIS ISSUE.
IS THE CHAIR MENTIONED CLOSE TO
ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
MOST CALIFORNIANS CAN TELL YOU
FLINT MICHIGAN IS KNOWN FOR LEAD
CONTAMINATION AFFECTING CHILDREN.
THOSE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE CRISIS IN
FLINT MICHIGAN MANY DON'T KNOW.
THAT WE HAVE IN SOME WAYS MORE
GRAVE PROBLEM IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE AFFECTED.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WAS MENTIONED BY CHAIR BLOOM.
WERE THE FIFTH STRONGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD IF WE WERE
STANDALONE NATION.
AND THIS IS JUST AN UNACCEPTABLE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
WE HAVE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
HARD WORKING MEMBERS OF OUR
STATE AND OUR ECONOMY.
WHO CAN'T DRINK THE WATER THAT
COMES OUT?
THEY CAN'T BASE WITH IT AND THEY
CAN'T COOK WITH CONTAMINATED
WATER.
THE COMMON DENOMINATOR IS THESE
TEND TO BE PEOPLE LIVING IN
SMALL WATER DISTRICTS.
AND IN POOR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES SOME SAY IT'S JUST A
PROBLEM IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR
THE SALINAS VALLEY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP.
EACH ONE OF THOSE RED STARS
ILLUSTRATES.
A CONTAMINATED WATER SYSTEM.
IT IS NOT LIMITED. TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OF THE SALINAS
VALLEY THOSE ARE AREAS OF HIGH
CONCENTRATION BUT VIRTUALLY
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SUFFERS FROM A CONTAMINATED
WATER SYSTEM.
THE TOXINS INCLUDE NITRATES
ARSENIC LEAD CHROMIUM SIX
URANIUM TCP AND THE LIST GOES ON
AND WHAT'S NOT KNOWN TO MANY IS
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
TOXINS.
ARE NATURALLY OCCURRING.
THEY BECOME EVEN MORE PROMINENT
IN GROUND WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
STRESSED BY DROUGHT.
IN THERE FOR CREATES A NEXUS
ALSO WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
INCREASE DROUGHT MORE STRESS ON
WATER SYSTEMS MORE LEACHING OF
NATURAL CONTAMINANTS AND SOME
ARE CAUSED BY VARIOUS PRODUCERS
AND PRODUCTS.
THEY ARE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION IN PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
AS WAS MENTIONED BOND FUNDS CAN
BE USED FOR CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
FOR A WATER TREATMENT FACILITY.
BUT AS WE SEE IN ON THEIR WITH
BOND MONEY USED TO BUILD A
TREATMENT FACILITY [inaudible]
FOR ARSENIC.
THE SWITCH IS TURNED OFF BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
FOR THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE ONE OF THE FEATURES
OF OUR LEGISLATION AND OF THE
GOVERNOR'S.
NOW SUBMISSION TO THE BUDGET.
IS THE VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
OF RAISING A SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER FUND THAT CAN BE ACCESSED
NOT JUST FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS ARE LINKING WATER
SYSTEMS.
BUT FOR THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE A SMALL WATER
DISTRICT WITH A SMALL NUMBER OF
RESIDENTS TWO HUNDRED THREE
HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED YOU CAN'T
RAISE THE WATER RATE HIGH ENOUGH.
OR OF TO BE AFFORDABLE. TO
PROVIDE THE ONGOING OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE.
SO WHAT ARE THE SOLUTIONS
[inaudible]
THE SOLUTIONS.
R. TO CREATE A PREDICTABLE AND
RELIABLE FUNDING SOURCE. TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
IN THE SOLUTION IS WITHIN REACH.
IT'S THE SCIENCES THERE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE THE
SOLUTIONS EXIST.
THEY MAY BE CONNECTING.
A CONTAMINATED WATER SYSTEM ARE
SMALL DISTRICT TO A LARGER
SYSTEM WITHIN A REASONABLE SPACE.
THAT.
CAN TRANSPORT CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
YET MAYBE CONTRACTS CONSTRUCTION
OF A TREATMENT FACILITY.
AND FOR ALL IT WILL INVOLVE SOME
NEED FOR ONGOING OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE.
AND IN OUR A MERCHANT SEE
CIRCUMSTANCE AND WE ARE LIVING
IN AN EMERGENCY IF YOU'RE ONE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T DRINK.
THE WATER THAT MANY ARE PAYING
FOR BUT CAN'T DRINK.
BOTTLED WATER IS AN EMERGENCY.
SOLUTION WE DON'T WANT BOTTLED
WATER TO BE THE SOLUTION.
BUT AS WE TRANSITION THESE
SYSTEMS TO CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER BOTTLED WATER SHOULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE AS WELL BECAUSE
MANY FAMILIES ARE PAYING FORTY
TO FIFTY DOLLARS A WEEK. FOR
BOTTLED WATER ON TOP OF PAYING A
WATER BILL FOR WATER THAT THEY
CAN ONLY USE MAYBE TO IRRIGATE
THEIR YARD.
BUT NOT TO DRINK.
OR BAY TH OR COOK WITH.
SO WHAT'S THE PATH TO THIS
SOLUTION.
WE HAVE A WORKING GROUP OF OVER
SEVENTY ORGANIZATIONS.
INCLUDING AGRICULTURAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
WATER DISTRICTS POLITICAL BODIES
AND GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES.
THE AGRICULTURAL PARTICIPANTS IN
THIS EFFORT.
AGRICULTURE AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT MONOLITHIC IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE DAIRY
PRODUCERS WHO WANT TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION WE HAVE CONTAINS
CATTLE.
CATTLE MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO WANT TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
AND WE HAVE A VARIETY OF CROP
PRODUCERS SPECIALTY CROPS TO ROW
CROPS TO ORCHARDS.
ALL OF WHOM.
HAVE WEIGHED IN SAYING WE WANT
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
AND THEN THERE'S THE RATE PAYER
PIECE.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME I THINK IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TODAY.
SOME OF SAID WELL LET'S JUST
ESTABLISH A TRUST FUND IN USE
THE GENERAL FUND MY BILL.
LAST YEAR AND WE'VE INTRODUCED
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED THIS
YEAR.
CHAIR GARCIA IS A CO AUTHOR ON
THAT -- IT'S
YOU MIGHT CALL A SPOT BILL AT
THIS POINT WE WILL BE FILLING IT
OUT.
BUT WE BELIEVE THE RATE PAYER
PIECE IS THE CRITICAL COMPONENT.
TO CREATING A GUARANTEED AND
PREDICTABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING.
ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND IT'S
A PUBLIC HEALTH IMPERATIVE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PEREIRA INTRODUCED AB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE IT ESTABLISHED THE
RIGHT IN CALIFORNIA.
THE HUMAN RIGHTS OF ACCESS TO
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER.
SO WE'VE ESTABLISHED IN LAW A
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER.
BUT WE HAVEN'T MADE GOOD.
ON THAT LEGAL RIGHT THAT WE'VE
CREATED.
IN OUR PASSED LEGISLATION WE
PROPOSE PROPOSED A COMBINED FEE
ON CERTAIN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
IN A RATE PAYER DE MINIMUS
MONTHLY FEE WHILE EXEMPTING
THOSE LIVING UP 22100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE.
UNDERSTANDABLY MANY WATER
DISTRICTS DO NOT SUPPORT A
REPAIR CONTRIBUTION AS PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
BUT EVEN WHEN IT IS LESS THAN
ONE DOLLAR PER MONTH LESS THAN A
CUP OF COFFEE.
LESS THAN A CANDY BAR WE CALL IT
A DE MINIMUS FEE.
BECAUSE BY ALL JOINING HANDS BY
LOOKING AT THIS AS A SHARED
PROBLEM OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE ALL SHOULDER PART OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
WE HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
WE HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
RIGHTS.
AND IT REQUIRES ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO STEP UP. TO HOLD HANDS AND TO
SUPPORT A STATE WIDE SOLUTION.
AS THE AUTHOR LAST YEAR BEST BE
SIX TWENTY THREE THIS YEAR OF SP --
TWO HUNDRED AS I MENTION CO
AUTHORED BY CHAIR GARCIA.
I REMAIN OPEN TO TALKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
BUT I'M ALSO MINDFUL THAT THIS
IS A PRIORITY FOR GOVERNOR NEW
SOME.
THE SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM.
AND SPEAKER RENDON OWN.
ONLY BY WORKING TOGETHER CAN WE
ACHIEVE THE SOLUTION.
THAT FAR TOO MANY.
HAVE WAITED FOR FAR TOO LONG TO
REALIZE.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE CO CHAIRS FOR CREATING
THIS FORM IN THIS OPPORTUNITY
THIS MORNING.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE ON
GOING WORK.
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GARCIA BLOOM
AND QUIRK SPEAKER RENDON OWN
PRESIDENT PRO TEM ATKINS.
GOVERNOR NEW SOME FOR PULLING
TOGETHER. TO SOLVE THIS NOT IN
TWO YEARS NOT IN FIVE YEARS NOT
IN TEN YEARS.
WE CAN SOLVE IT THIS YEAR.
THE ONLY THING LACKING IS THE
POLITICAL WILL.
AND THE WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP.
SOME OF THESE VOTES ARE HARD BUT
I WOULD SUBMIT.
ANYONE WHO VOTES FOR THIS BILL.
WITH ANY YEAR YOU'LL BE IT A
RIBBON CUTTING IN YOUR DISTRICT
OF THIS MONEY BEING PUT TO WORK
BRINGING SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER.
I THINK ANYONE WHO'S CONCERNED
ABOUT POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES.
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THE PRIDE.
IN THE RESPONSIBILITY BY WHICH
YOU COULD DEFEND ANY VOTE TO
ESTABLISH A CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER FUND SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND CO CHAIRS GLAD TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT I KNOW
I'M FOLLOWED BY --
EXPERTISE IN THE NEXT TWO PANELS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MONICA AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALL THE WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THIS
ISSUE -- WE
ARE GOING TO PROCEED NOW TO OUR
FIRST PANEL THAT --
I'LL INTRODUCE AND THEN OUR
SECOND PANEL WILL --
WHICH IS A TEACHER [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
SENATOR WITH WITH YOUR PROPOSAL
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROJECTING YEARLY THAT THIS WILL
GENERATE TO GENERATE ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION A YEAR.
OKAY AGRICULTURE WOULD
CONTRIBUTE ABOUT. THIRTY TO
FORTY MILLION OF THAT.
IN THE REST WOULD BE FROM THE
RATE PAYER FEENEY THAT
APPORTIONMENT IS BASED ON THE
SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS.
OF THE DEGREE OF CONTAMINATION
BE TRACED TO AGRICULTURAL
POLLUTANTS ABOUT 30%.
AND ABOUT 70% OR THE NATURAL
OCCURRING POLLUTANTS THAT'S
WHERE WE PROPOSE TO USE A RATE
PAYER FEE.
AGAIN AT NINE TO GATHER SO SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION A YEAR
ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
ENOUGH TO RUN ALL THE WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS ARE GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO EVEN PUT A DENT IN
THIS.
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION --
WE BELIEVE IT WILL BE ENOUGH AND
IT'S BASED ON AN ASSESSMENT OF
WHERE THESE POLLUTED.
CONTAMINATED DISTRICTS ARE
PROXIMITY TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER --
PART OF THE MONEY IN THE FIRST
YEARS WOULD BE USED TO FURTHER
PRIORITIZE.
IT DOES PRIORITIZE FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BUT
THESE ARE COMMUNITIES MANY OF
WHOM.
ARE CONTRIBUTING TO OUR STATE
WIDE ECONOMY WORKING IN THE
FIELDS --
AND CONTRIBUTING TO THOSE IN
URBAN AREAS AS WELL MAY I ASK
THE QUESTION BECAUSE THE IF WE
LOOK AT WHAT THE WATER BOARD
ESTIMATED --
FROM --
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THEY DISPERSED
OVER THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION --
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
WATER SYSTEMS AND I MEAN WHAT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUR
PROPOSAL SIR IS --
NOT EVEN HALF OF THAT CLEAR FINE
SO I'M IN AND AND WITH THAT DO
WE HAVE A COST ON HOW MUCH IT.
FOR OPERATION COST ON HOW MUCH
IT COSTS TO RUN. ONE OF THE
SYSTEMS OF VIRTUE OF THIS SAFE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER FIND.
AND THE PERPETUAL SOURCE OF OF
FINDING IT CAN BE USED FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE WE
CAN COMPLEMENT THAT WITH
EXISTING BOND.
MONIES FOR CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS --
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BUT WE CAN'T USE BOND MONEY FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE SO
THIS.
FIND HELP SUPPLEMENT WHAT WE
ALREADY HAVE FROM FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS SO IT'S NOT THE
ONLY MONEY AVAILABLE FOR WATER
IMPROVEMENT.
BUT IT SPECIALLY AVAILABLE FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW THAT'S
ENOUGH MONEY FINANCIALLY WHICH
IS WHY I'M WORKING ON A CA.
THREE WHICH WOULD BE 2% OF THE
GENERAL FUND TOWARDS THIS AND
OTHER PROJECTS AND MAINTENANCE.
FOR MORE THAN JUST CLEAN
DRINKING WATER BUT FOR
EVERYTHING IN THE PROCESS AND
I'M FAMILIAR WITH YOUR
LEADERSHIP THERE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
ON YOUR EFFORTS GUESSES THEIR
COMPLIMENTARY MY QUESTION THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR SENATOR
MONNING.
GREAT THE NOT A THANK YOU
SENATOR WE WILL PROCEED NOW TO
OUR FIRST PANEL --
WHICH IS --
SEVEN ENTITLED FRAMING THE ISSUE.
OUR PANELISTS ARE JOAQUIN --
OF THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD SUSAN BIONDA.
THE CO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND WE'VE
GOT.
OF THE HONOR --
OF HAVING.
OUR NEWLY APPOINTED SECRETARY OF
NATURAL SOURCES AGENCY.
WAIT CROWFOOT.
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO BE HERE TODAY --
CHAIRMAN AYE GARCIA CHAIRMAN
BLOOM A CHARMING QUIRK AND AND
MEMBERS OF OF THESE VARIOUS
COMMITTEES --
MY NAME IS WAIT CRAWFORD AND I
SERVICE THE NEWLY APPOINTED
SECRETARY OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY --
AND IN THAT CAPACITY THIS IS MY
FIRST --
HEARING ON WHICH I'M TESTIFYING
FOR THE LEGISLATURE SO IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE BEFORE YOU TODAY
LOOK OUT.
FOR THE BEST IS YET TO COME --
SO AS YOU KNOW THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY HAS OVER
NINETEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND
A BUDGET OF OVER FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. ONE OF OUR LARGEST
DEPARTMENTS AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WHICH HELPS
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER TO OVER
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
ARE SO WATER IS VERY MUCH AT THE
CENTER.
I IN MY PRIOR ROLES --
BEFORE IT SERVING IN THIS IN
THIS ROLE --
I I HOPE TO SPARE HAD --
THE STATE'S DROUGHT RESPONSE.
I AND THEN MOST RECENTLY LED AN
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
INNOVATIVE WATER SOLUTIONS THAT
WORK FOR COMMUNITIES ECONOMY IN
THE ENVIRONMENT --
I KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU ON ON
THESE COMMITTEES --
HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY --
I'M LEGISLATION IN EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE WATER MANAGEMENT --
AND VERY THANKFUL ON BEHALF THE
NATURIST ARSES AGENCY FOR YOUR
WORK THERE --
WE'RE HERE OBVIOUSLY TODAY TO
DISCUSS A REAL AND PRESENT
CRISIS IN THE STATE --
AND THAT IS NOT TOXIC DRINKING
WATER IN OUR COMMUNITIES --
AS GERMAN BLOOM --
EXPO -- WHAT
I'LL DO IS IS FRAME THE ISSUE
FROM OUR ADMINISTRATION'S
PERSPECTIVE I SHARE WITH YOU
GOVERNOR NEW SUMS --
INITIAL PROPOSAL AND HIS JANUARY
I BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THEN WE
CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS --
OF COURSE.
AT THAT YOU HAVE ALSO NOTE THAT
WE HAVE --
AN EXPERT HERE FROM THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD --
WHO CAN --
ANSWER QUESTIONS IN A VERY
DETAIL WAY INCLUDING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS IS QUESTION ABOUT
THE COST ESTIMATE.
THANK YOU YEAH I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE --
FIRST OF ALL THAT MOST
CALIFORNIANS ENJOY ACCESS TO
CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER --
THINKS TOO MANY OF OUR WATER
UTILITIES ACROSS THE STATE --
WHEN DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS
ARISE IN IN COMMUNITIES?
WHERE MOST OF US LIVE?
WELL FUNDED --
HIGHLY TO KLAY RESOLVE --
I KNOW I'VE ONLY LIVED IN
COMMUNITIES --
WHERE I TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER --
BUT I'VE USED AS YOU'VE HEARD IN
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT A REALITY.
FOR MANY PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
I HAVE A FOUR YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
AND I COULDN'T IMAGINE LIVING IN
A HOME WHERE.
SHE HAD TO LEARN I ACTUALLY NOT
TO DRINK THE WATER.
ORDERED ACTUALLY IS IN SOME
CASES TOUCH OBEYED IN THE WATER --
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE TAPS
BUT THAT'S A REALITY FOR PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE.
YOU KNOW TONIGHT UPWARDS OF A
MILLION PEOPLE WILL LEAVE THEIR
JOBS -- PICK
UP THEIR KIDS AND GO HOME --
TO PLACES WHERE THEY LIVE ARE
WHERE THEY CAN'T DRINK THE WATER
THE WATER IS ACTUALLY GOING. TO
TO IT TO MAKE THEM SO --
AND THEIR FAMILIES SEC AND I
THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S WIDELY
ACKNOWLEDGED AND THAT'S BEYOND
DEBATE --
BUT IT IS WORTH NOTING JUST THE
SORT OF THE HUMAN DIMENSION OF
THE PROBLEM --
SO HERE ARE THE FACTS AS WE
UNDERSTAND THEM --
MOCHA --
MANY LOCAL WATER SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE PARTICULARLY THE THOSE IN
SMALL DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CONSISTENTLY FAILED TO PROVIDE
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER OUT TO
THE TO THEIR CUSTOMERS --
OVER HALF A MILLION PEOPLE IN
OVER THREE HUNDRED PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE REGULATED BY
THE STATE --
FAILED TO PROVIDE --
OR OR EXPERIENCE TOXIC WATER
COMING FROM --
THEIR WATER AGENCIES AND BELIEVE
IT OR NOT THESE FOLKS ACTUALLY
PAY THEIR WATER BILLS OFFER
WATER THAT THEY CAN'T DRINK --
THEN THERE ARE ANOTHER SET OF
FOLKS THAT GET THEIR WATER FROM
WHAT ARE CALLED STATE SMALLS OR
A STATE.
SMALL DRINKING WATER AGENCIES
WITH LESS THAN FIFTEEN
CONNECTIONS THAT ARE DIRECTLY
REGULATED BY THE STATE AND THEN
OF COURSE FOCUS ON DOMESTIC
WELLS.
AT TWO SO WHEN WE USE THIS
ESTIMATE OF UPWARDS OF A MILLION.
CALIFORNIANS SUFFER FROM TOXIC
WATER -- WE
HAVE A VERY PRECISE ESTIMATE.
OF THOSE PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES --
BOARD A LESS IS KNOWN ABOUT THE
STATE'S MALLS AND THE DOMESTIC
WELLS.
I IN A SENATOR MINING SAID --
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
FOLKS ARE DRINKING OR OR HAVE
WATER IN THEIR HOMES THAT ARE
CONTAMINATED BY A RANGE OF
SUBSTANCES NITRATES ARSENIC --
ACCIDENT ACTS AVAILING CHROMIUM
OR CHROME --
SIX WE PROBABLY ALL KNOW THESE
CONTAMINANTS --
CAN.
CONTAIN CARCINOGENS AND OTHER
SEVERELY DAMAGING COMPOUNDS THAT
BECAUSE BOTH CHRONIC HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND HAVE BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TO SHORTEN LIFE
SPANS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN CENTRAL
COAST REGIONS --
WHERE MORE THAN 90% OF
COMMUNITIES DEPEND ON GROUND
WATER IS AN AREA THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY HARD HIT BY THIS
CRISIS?
MORE THAN A QUARTER MILLION
PEOPLE -- IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ALONE LACK
ACCESS TO A CONSISTENT SOURCE OF
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE WATER.
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THIS IS NOT JUST A
RURAL PROBLEM --
IN THE URBAN COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE AND POCKETS OF OUR STATE
ALSO FACE DRINKING WATER THREATS --
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE READ RECENT
I PRESSED WATER AGENCIES IN LOS
ANGELES IN THE LOS ANGELES BASIN
AUDIT OF HOW DRINKING WATER
PROBLEMS --
THAT THEY'VE HAD DIFFICULTY
ADDRESSING BECAUSE OF THE SMALL
AYE IMPOVERISHED NATURE OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS FUND WOULD ADDRESS THAT.
SENATOR MINING MENTION THE
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN FLINT
IN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WE ALL
REMEMBER THAT WHERE FAIRLY
SUDDENLY AYE LAD LEACHED FROM
PIPES --
INTO FLINT RESIDENTS WATER --
AS A RESULT OF FLINT CHANGING
ITS WATER SUPPLY AND NOT ADDING
THE RIGHT ANTI CORROSION
CHEMICALS --
AND WHAT RESULTED WAS --
TOXIC LEVELS OF LEAD IN THE
WATER.
I THINK WHAT'S REMARKABLE IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS DISCUSSION IS
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA TEN TIMES
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE --
COMPARED TO FRIENDS POPULATION
ACTUALLY OP SUFFER FROM TOXIC
WATER AND AGAIN THAT'S REALLY
BEYOND DEBATE --
AT THIS POINT --
I THINK ALSO CENTER MINING --
DEMONSTRATED A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS AREN'T AWARE OF
THIS CRISIS --
I KNOW I I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
ACROSS THE STATE AND A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT --
YOU WOULD THINK ON'T WOULD
UNDERSTAND --
SITUATION LIKE THIS ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE AWARENESS --
OF JUST THE SCOPE OF THE CRISIS --
IN MY PRIOR FROM MY PRIOR ROLE
WATER FOUNDATION --
WHICH WORKED ON THIS ISSUE I
KNOW THAT PUBLIC NONPARTISAN
POLLING HAS SHOWN ON THAT MORE
IS KNOWN IN THE STATE.
TODAY ABOUT FLINT MICHIGAN THAN
ARE THEIR OWN CHALLENGES HERE --
SPALLING THAT WAS DONE IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN DEMONSTRATED THE
STATE RESIDENTS ARE READY TO
STEP UP AND HELP SOLVE THIS
CRISIS --
AND THAT PARTICULAR --
POLLING SUGGESTED --
UPWARDS OF TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIANS --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SUPPORTED A
SURCHARGE OF UP TO TWO DOLLARS
PER MONTH ON THEIR WATER BILLS I
TO ENSURE CLEAN AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
SO AS MENTIONED IN THE
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS ON
SOLUTIONS TO THIS CRISIS
INVOLVES SEVERAL IMPORTANT
ACTIONS --
ONE OF FUNDING INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES IN LOCAL WATER
DISTRICTS BOND FUNDING --
INCLUDING SOME BOND FUNDING I
TALK ABOUT IN A MOMENT IS
IMPORTANT TOWARDS PROVIDING
THOSE ONE TIME CAPITAL UPGRADES.
ALSO ANOTHER IMPORTANT ACTION IS
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF THESE
LOCAL WATER DISTRICTS A TREAT
POLLUTION AND PROVIDE CLEAN
WATER.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO THE SMALL COMMUNITIES.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT ACTION IS
CONSOLIDATING OR REGIONAL ISING
SMALL SYSTEMS --
WHERE THEY'RE SIMPLY NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE WATER?
AND YOUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS HAVE HAS
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF TOOLS --
THAT THE WATER BAT BOARD HAS TO
INCUR OUR NATION'S OF FAILING
SYSTEMS THAT'S CLEARLY PART OF
THE SOLUTION --
IN THE LEGISLATURE HAS AS LEAD
IN EACH OF THESE AREAS --
AS NOTED THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
REMAINING CHALLENGE IS THE LACK
OF A STABLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
LONG TERM OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE FOR DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS.
WHILE BOND FUNDS PROVIDE THAT
IMPORTANT ONE TIME CAPITAL --
UPGRADE --
WHAT WE SEEN ACROSS THE STATE AS
IF THERE'S NOT RESOURCES TO
ACTUALLY OPERATE THAT --
THAT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
TECHNOLOGY --
THEN THERE'S THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS CLEAN WATER IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND THERE ARE
CERTAIN CAUTIONARY TALES WHERE
THE STATE PROVIDED INITIAL ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES.
ON THAT ULTIMATELY GOT SHUDDERED
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF ON GOING
FUNDING.
BOB CLEARLY GOVERNOR KNEW SOME
HAS MADE AFFORDABLE SAFE
DRINKING WATER PRIORITY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION --
WE SHARE THE VIEW THAT IN THE
STATE AS AT AS RICH AND RESOURCE
WEALTHIEST CALIFORNIA --
THE FACT THAT UP LARGE PORTION
OF OUR RESIDENTS I CAN'T DEPEND
ON CLEAN AND SAFE WATER --
IS A SHAMEFUL REALITY THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS --
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE CAN
ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THE PROBLEM
THAT'S BEYOND DEBATE BUT NOW WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO COMMIT
OURSELVES TO A SOLUTION.
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
CONTAINS SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSALS --
ON THIS TOPIC NUMBER --
ONE IT APPROPRIATE IT'S OR
PROPOSES APPROPRIATE EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FROM PROPERTY
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT THE BOND
MEASURE THE PASSED IN JUNE --
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS AND LOANS TO PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS I IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS.
IT PROPOSES TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN EMERGENCY WATER SUPPLIES --
FOR FROM THE GENERAL FUND --
TO ADDRESS THESE EMERGENCIES ARE
WHERE.
THROUGH THE PROVISION OF BOTTLED
WATER WATER TANKS ETCETERA.
ALMOST LIKE EMERGENCY ROOM CARE --
THAT'S NOT SOLVING THE PROBLEM
BUT IT'S ADDRESSING THAT THE
ACUTE LACK OF A CLEAN AND SAFE
WATER.
UP ANOTHER TEN MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED IN THE GENERAL FUND --
FOR THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
IN MANY OF THESE SMALL
COMMUNITIES THEY SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD FULL TIME TECHNICAL
EXPERTS.
ON SO COMMUNITIES I VISITED --
THEY CAN ACTUALLY CONTRACT FOR A
TECHNICAL EXPERT TO COME IN AND
HELP THEM UNDERSTAND THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY THEY NEED TO CLEAN
THE WATER AND ACTUALLY --
THEN OPERATE THAT TECHNOLOGY
NOTE THAT BOTH I'M TEN MILLION
FOR EMERGENCY WATER SUPPLIES AND
TEN MILLION DOLLARS THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
WERE CONTAINED IN AB --
SEVENTY TWO THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ACTED UPON LAST WEEK --
SO THAT THOSE FUNDS HAT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR MURDERS HE
WATER SUPPLIES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
ARE RECOGNIZING THE EMERGENCY
NEED FOR THAT FUNDING --
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES ALMOST FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON A ONE TIME
BASIS TO BOTH THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE. TO TAKE INITIAL
STEPS TO SET UP THIS CLEAN AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER FUND --
AND SPECIFICALLY --
TO IMPLEMENT THAT FEE COLLECTION
SYSTEMS.
ADOPT AN ANNUAL IMPLEMENTATION --
PLAN AND DEVELOP A MAP OF HIGH
RISK AQUIFER'S --
THAT ARE USED TO DRINKING WATER
SOURCES --
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU GOVERNOR
NEWSOME HAS BOTH CALLED FOR AND
THEN SUBMITTED LANGUAGE ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND --
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR ON
GOING FUNDING --
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS --
THIS PROPOSAL AS IT'S WRITTEN
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE POLICY
FRAMEWORK OF SB --
SIX TWENTY THREE THAT SENATOR
MINING INTRODUCED --
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
AND I INVITE YOU IF YOU WANT TO
UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT HOW THE
FUND WORKS OUR TASK OF SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ARE I AS I UNDERSTAND
IT ACTUALLY THAT.
THE FUND --
IS FAIRLY FLEXIBLE IN THE SENSE
THAT IF THE FUNDS ARE NOT NEEDED
OVERTIME --
THE AMOUNT OF FEE COLLECTION
WOULD REDUCE AND THE FUND --
IT HAS PROTECTIONS AROUND
AMASSING TOO MUCH REVENUE --
THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY GET OUT TO
THE FIELD --
AND ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SO I
THINK SENATOR MINING --
AND OTHERS HAVE TAKEN GREAT CARE --
TO CREATE A FUND THAT
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEM BUT AVOIDS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
OTHER STATE FUNDS HAVE IN THE
PAST -- I
LOOK FORWARD WITH IT OUT TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE ADMINISTRATION I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS VERY
EXCITED --
TO ENGAGE ON REALLY DELIVERING A
SOLUTION --
THIS YEAR ON THIS CRISIS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND TO SINCE
HE TOUCHED ON THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL LET ME JUST TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT
WE WILL HAVE A FULL HEARING KA
KA IN BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE --
THREE TO ADDRESS SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND WE WANT TO OF COURSE FOCUS
OUR EFFORTS HERE ON THE ISSUE AT
LARGE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR GARCIA CHAIR
BLOOM AND CHAIR QUIRK AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES MY
NAME IS WALKING ASK ABOUT AND I
HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING AS A
MEMBER OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE A FEW THOUGHTS ON TODAY'S
PANEL.
AND THANK YOU TO CENTER MINING
AS WELL FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE.
AS YOU HEARD FROM SECRETARY
CROWFOOT WE HAVE AN IMMEDIATE
MORAL IMPERATIVE TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER.
AND THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP IN
PLACE TO SEE IT ADDRESSED.
I CAN SAY WITH CERTAINTY AND
WE'VE HEARD IT SEVERAL TIMES
TODAY ALREADY.
THAT.
THERE IS A CONSENSUS OUT THERE
AND THERE IS AN OVERWHELMING
SENSE OF AGREEMENT THAT WE CAN
NO LONGER ACCEPT THAT THE
WEALTHIEST STATE AND THE
WEALTHIEST NATION IN THE WORLD.
WE HAVE COMMUNITIES FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN THEY GO WITHOUT ACCESS
THE CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
AND YET DESPITE THAT SENSE OF
AGREEMENT CANDIDLY I HEAR
CRITICISM THE PURSUING A CLEAN
SAFE DRINKING WATER FUND IS TOO
PREMATURE.
THAT STATE AGENCIES NEED ONLY DO
MORE WITH THE RESOURCES WE HAVE
OR THAT WE NEED TO FURTHER STUDY
OR UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM BEFORE
PURSUING FUNDS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE GENERAL
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A STABLE
SOURCE OF FUNDING THAT CAN BE
SPENT ON THE OPERATIONS
MAINTENANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
OF FAILING OR SOON TO FAIL WATER
SYSTEMS.
IS IN A REQUEST OF FIRST RESORT.
NOR IS IT AWAY TO INDEFINITELY
PROP UP UNSUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS
INSTEAD THE FUND IS THE KEYSTONE
TO A COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THIS
STATE HAS STOP LEE PIECE
TOGETHER OVER THE LAST YEAR'S.
WHILE IT MAY NOT SEEM LIKE
THERE'S A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAMMATIC RESPONSE TO
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT ACCESS TO
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AT HAND.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT STATE
LEGISLATURES LEADERSHIP AND
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT ON THE
ISSUE OVER THE LAST YEARS.
HAVE CRAFTED A SAID OF
AUTHORITIES A COMPLIMENT INFORM
ONE ANOTHER AND TAKING
COLLECTIVELY PROVIDE AN INTERNET
PROGRAM AND A SET OF SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS ACCESS TO CLEAN AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER IN THE STATE.
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CONSOLIDATION AND
REGIONALIZATION AND CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS.
AS YOU KNOW.
THE DIVISION A DRINKING WATER IS
TRANSFERRED TRANSFERRED TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN NOW JUST FIVE YEARS AGO.
IN DOING SO THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED YOU TO BREAK DOWN THE
REGULATORY SILOS THE TEND TO
BUILD UP.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME GRANT AN
AGENCY WITH A WIDE COMPLEMENT TO
REGULATORY PROGRAMS FROM WHICH
TO ADDRESS ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO THAN
ESTABLISHED AN OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABLE SUSTAINABLE WATER
SOLUTIONS AT THE BOARD TO ENSURE
THAT EFFECTIVE COORDINATION OF
FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO TAKE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS
PROVIDED.
THE OFFICE IS NOW HELPED OVER
TWO HUNDRED SMALL DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SECURE FUNDING FOR
PROJECT PLANNING AND
CONSTRUCTION AND OVER FIVE
HUNDRED WATER SYSTEMS WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALSO GRANTED
THE BOARD MANDATORY
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITIES OVER
FAILING SYSTEMS GREATER ABILITY
TO DENY THE PERMITTING OF NEW
UNSUSTAINABLE WATER SYSTEMS.
ALONG WITH THE ABILITY TO
APPOINT ADMINISTRATORS TO
FAILING SYSTEMS.
IN FACT OVER THE LAST YEARS WE
HAVE BROUGHT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
SYSTEMS REGULATED BY THE STATE
WATER BOARD BACK INTO COMPLIANCE.
LEAVING STILL TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR TO BE ADDRESSED AND
HALF IS IS NOT A SUCCESS HALF IS
NOWHERE NEAR CLOSE TO SUCCESS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT OF THESE
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR SYSTEMS
NOT CURRENTLY MEETING DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS THERE ARE STILL
MORE SYSTEMS THAT ARE EITHER
CYCLING IN OUT OF COMPLIANCE OR
ONE HARDSHIP AWAY FROM MEETING
NEWS.
NEW STANDARDS OR MEETING CURRENT
STATE.
STANDARDS.
WHILE THE NUMBER OF SYSTEMS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE AS ONE INDICATOR
AND WORKING TO BRING THE NUMBER
ZERO IS IMPORTANT WE KNOW THAT
IT'S A NUMBER THAT DOESN'T
REFLECT THE THOUSANDS OF SYSTEMS
WE ESTIMATE TO EXIST THAT ARE
EITHER TOO SMALL TO BE REGULATED
BY THE STATE BOARD.
OR ARE HOUSEHOLDS DEPENDENT ON
DOMESTIC WELLS.
ON THAT ISSUE WE'RE GLAD WE'VE
TO RECEIVE FUNDING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST SESSION
TO COMPLETE A NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
ATTEMPTS TO QUANTIFY THOSE
UNKNOWNS.
BUT THE FACT REMAINS THERE IS A
GREAT DEAL.
ULTIMATELY IT'S TELLING AT THE
TELLING FACT THAT 90% OF
DRINKING WATER VIOLATIONS IN THE
STATE ARE FROM SYSTEMS UNDER
FIVE HUNDRED CONNECTIONS.
WILL FRAGMENTATION OF THE WATER
SECTOR MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A KEY
TO THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER WE
KNOW WHEN IT KNOWLEDGE THE
REGIONALIZATION CONSOLIDATION OF
SYSTEMS IS A CRITICAL TOOL IN
ADDRESSING THEIR ON
SUSTAINABILITY.
THERE CON ISN'T ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THAT NEED TO BE MET IN
ORDER TO HAVE THE RATE BASE TOOL
FOR THE PROVISION OF CLEAN AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER.
AND THESE FUNDS GO TO MEET THE
NEED OF BRIDGING THAT GAP AND
BRING SYSTEMS AND COMPLIANCE --
AS SENATOR MINING AND SECRETARY
CROWFOOT HAVE POINTED OUT.
IN A WHILE THE CHALLENGE OF
CLEAN DRINKING WATER MIGHT SEEM
TO BE A REAL ISSUE THE MAP ABOUT
A COMPLAINT SYSTEM SHOWS IT'S A
PROBLEM THAT IMPACTS COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS IS AN URBAN SUBURBAN AND
RURAL PROBLEMS AND THE SOLUTIONS
ARE UNIQUE TO EACH COMMUNITY
THIS FACING CHALLENGES.
THE SOLUTIONS FOR COMMUNITIES
WITH ARSENIC CONTAMINATED WELLS
IN THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY.
WILL BE DIFFERENT THAN THOSE
STEPS THAT ARE TAKEN TO ADDRESS
MALL SYSTEMS AND URBAN LOS
ANGELES WITH AGING AND
INADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE OR
COMMUNITIES IN LAKE COUNTY.
WHO ARE LOOKING TO BUILD
RESILIENCE AND --
FRAGMENTED SYSTEM SIR
CONSOLIDATION [inaudible]
ULTIMATELY.
WE HAVE THE TOOLS IN PLACE I
FEEL THAT THAT HELP US --
A GET CLOSER TO TO TALK TO OUR
GOAL HERE.
LASTLY I WANT TO BE SURE AND
MAKE CLEAR THAT WHILE I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE MANY OF THE
COMPONENTS NECESSARY FOR SUCCESS
WE CAN AND MUST CONTINUE TO FIND
WAYS TO IMPROVE OUR PROCESSES.
THIS INCLUDES HAVING TECHNICAL
PROVIDERS ECONOMIC A PROJECTS TO
COMPLETION FOR COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES TO DO SO.
MAKING SURE WE CONSIDER AND
ADDRESS BARRIERS TO ACCESS.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRS AGAIN
FOR PULLING TOGETHER THIS
DISCUSSION.
I LOOK FOR TO WORKING TOGETHER
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE IN ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU SIR AN ARC OF FINAL
PANELISTS SUSANNA DOWN GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE.
MY NAME IS A SON OF THE AND I AM
THE CO DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER
WITH COMMUNITY WATER CENTER.
WHOSE MISSION IS TO BE A
CATALYST FOR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING EDUCATION ADVOCACY IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE ISSUE
WATER FOR THE LAST DECADE FOR
OVER THIRTEEN YEARS.
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE AT THIS
HEARING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT I'VE
DEVOTED MY ENTIRE LIFE.
TO SOME OF US LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT NO
SWELLING THE WATER USED TO BRUSH
OUR TEETH.
SOME FAMILIES HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THEIR KIDS
TAKE BOTTLED WATER TO SCHOOL TO
AVOID HAVING TO DRINK THE WATER
FOUNTAIN BECAUSE AT THE SCHOOL
WE HAVE.
NIGHT NITRATES ARSENIC FROM SIX
SOME FAMILIES HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH WATER AT
HOME SO THAT WHEN THEY HAVE IN
WITH IT FAMILY COMING TO VISIT
THEM THEY HAVE ENOUGH WATER TO
AVOID DRINKING TAP WATER.
THIS IS A REALITY THAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S NOT OKAY.
WHEN WE SAY?
THAT OVER ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CALIFORNIANS HUMANS THIS
MAP TO MY RIGHT SHOWS A REALLY
GOOD INDICATION OF OVER THREE
HUNDRED SYSTEMS ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE HOWEVER AT THIS MAP
FAILS TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE ALSO
HAVE.
MILLIONS OF PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS
WITH CONTAMINATED WELLS AS WELL
SO THIS DOES NOT EVEN CAPTURE
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY.
NOW I WILL SAY.
THE MAJORITY THESE PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS ARE FOUND IN LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OF COLOR COMMUNITIES.
AND DESPITE THE MILLION OF
FEDERAL TAX DOLLARS THAT WE BILL
THAT WE PASSED A BILL VAST
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PASSING A
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE STILL CANNOT
GUARANTEE SEEM DRINKING WATER OP
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
LISTEN TO THAT.
WE CAN WE EVEN WE PASS ALONG WE
STILL CANNOT INSURE THAT ALL OF
US CAN WAKE UP AND DRINK TAP
WATER WITHOUT THE FEAR BECOMING
SICK.
THERE'S JUST NOT OKAY AND I'M
NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT SANTEE
TOWNS I'M TALKING ABOUT FAMILIES
COMMUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE OWN
THEIR HOME WHERE THEY PAY
PROPERTY TAXES PLACES LIKE EL
PART IS TO ROSY. TO LEGAL PLAIN
VIEW BLUFF AND JUST BLUFF AND
JENSEN COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL COAST.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT ALONE AND CITIES ARE NOT
EXEMPT AS WELL WE HAVE CITIES
LIKE URBAN THE DEAL WITH OUR
STICK CITIES I HAVE TRIED.
TRAILER METHANE SWITCHER BY
PRODUCT BY PRODUCT CHLORINATION
DIVIDE A BY PRODUCT BY PRODUCT
URINATION TREATMENT OF
SITUATIONS AGAIN I ALSO WANT TO
REMIND YOU.
THAT WHEN OVER 90% OF VALLEY
RESIDENTS CONTAMINANTS THAT NO
ONE NEEDS TO BE EXPOSED.
TO WE HAVE THINGS LIKE MY TREATS
LET ME REMIND YOU NATURE IS IN
THE QUEUE CONTAMINANT THAT HAS
BEEN LINKED TO THE BLUE BABY
SYNDROME AND CANCER AND KIDNEY
DISEASE.
SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN THIS
MEANS ARE HARD WORKING FAMILIES.
OR HAVING TO PAY SOME OF THE
HIGH WATER RATES FOR WATER THEY
CANNOT DRINK.
AND IN MANY SITUATIONS ON PAIN
SOME OF UP 210% OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME ALONE JUST HAVE
THE DRINKING WATER.
SO WE'RE HAVING HERE WE HAVE A
CRISIS WE HAVE CONTAMINATED
WATER GOING THROUGH OLD AND
DILAPIDATED INFRASTRUCTURE.
LEAD TO PEOPLE'S TAP.
I HAVE TO MAKE TOUGH TRADE OFFS
TO NOT DRINK THAT TAP WATER.
AND HAVE TO PAY WATER BILL THEY
CAN I USE FOR DRINKING AND STILL
HAVE TO BUY BOTTLED WATER.
THAT IS NOT OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE CHALLENGES
ARE MULTI FACETED.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS CRISIS HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR A WHILE IT'S SYSTEMIC AND
HAS SIMMERED FOR YEARS.
HOWEVER AS A PROSPEROUS STATUS
AS CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE THE
SOLUTION.
THE BIGGEST GAP TO SOLVING THE
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IS PASSING
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE WATER
FUND.
WE NEED TO CREATE.
A PERMANENT RELIABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING THE NATO. TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE SOLUTIONS WE NEED.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE'S
LIVES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SCHOOLS.
LAST YEAR IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OVER ONE
FORTY LABOR COMMUNITY AND HEALTH
AND BUSINESS ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTED A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD CREATE THE SAME FOR
THE FOUR OH DRINKING WATER FUND.
THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE THAT WE
WERE EVEN TALKING ABOUT HAVING
EXTENSIVELY BEEN DISCUSSED AND I
CAN TELL YOU FIRST HAND.
OUR COMMUNITIES BELIEVE THE
SAFER FOR DRINKING WATER POINT
WILL ULTIMATELY HELP THEM SOLVE
THIS ISSUE.
AND BE ABLE TO OPEN UP THE TAP
WATER WITHOUT THE PURE BECOMING
SICK.
WE LOOK TO YOU TO HELP PASS THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THIS YEAR.
WE HAVE NO TIME TO WAIT ANYMORE.
THE BIGGEST GAP TO THIS CRISIS
IS THE LACK OF SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE FOR COMMUNITIES.
WE CAN ON YOU TO HELP US PASS
THE SUPERBOWL DRINKING WATER FUN.
LISTEN NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE.
WHAT SCHOOL YOU GO TO OR YOU GO
VISIT FAMILY MEMBERS AND SOME OF
THESE SYSTEMS?
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DRINK TAP
WATER WITHOUT THE FEELING OF
SICK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR THE INTELLIGENCE THE
DEDICATION AND THE TRUE PASSION
THE TO BRING TO THIS ISSUE --
AT THIS POINT WE CAN PAUSE
SUFFER QUESTIONS OF FOR ARE
THERE ARE ANY FOR THIS PANEL.
MISTER QUIRK --
AGAIN WE WE ALL AGREE ON THE
PROBLEM.
ARE WE CAN AGREE ON HOW IT CAN
BE SOLVED --
BUT THE REAL QUESTION IS GRAY ON
HOW TO FIND THIS.
NOW.
IF IT COMES OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND WE CAN ALL VOTE FOR THAT
EIGHTY VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY
FORTY VOTES IN THE SENATE.
COME BY OUR I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE.
I CAN SAY THAT IN MY DISTRICT I
DON'T EXPECT ANY OF THE MONEY TO
COME TO ME THAT I HAVE ALREADY
SAID WHETHER IT'S FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OR A TAX OR FEE I'M
WILLING TO GO AHEAD --
AND AGAIN I'M NOT ASKING THAT
EVERYONE ELSE MAKE THAT PLEDGE
TODAY BUT I AM ASKING YOU TO
THINK ABOUT IT --
YESTERDAY --
TUESDAY WE HEARD ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR FUNDS TO REDUCE
FINES FOR THE VERY POOR PEOPLE
GO THROUGH OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
AND THAT'S ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR --
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT COME FROM
THE GENERAL FUND BUT I DON'T
THINK IT IS --
HOW WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THAT I COULD I CAN'T TELL YOU --
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IN MY
DISTRICT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND IN FACT ARE COUNTIES.
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND ALAMEDA
HAVE AGREED INCLUDING THE COUNTY
I SERVE TO FOREGO THOSE FIGHTS --
BUT IT'S IT'S A TOUGH CHOICE TO
BE MADE AND I WOULD JUST ASK
EVERYONE HERE.
I'M PRETTY SURE THAT IN THE BAY
AREA AND IN LA MOST OF WHOSE
DISTRICTS DO NOT INVOLVE SYSTEMS
WITH WATER PROBLEMS THAT THE
VOTES WILL BE THERE IF IT'S
NECESSARY FOR FEAR TAX.
AND I WOULD ASK THE PEOPLE FROM
THE RURAL AREAS AS WELL.
WHERE AND?
ADMITTEDLY THERE IS A
EDUCATIONAL --
URBAN AREA BUT MOSTLY IT'S CAN
BE IN THE RURAL AREAS I WOULD
ASK THOSE FOLKS AS WELL. TO
THINK CAREFULLY RIGHT NOW AND
HOPEFULLY COME TOGETHER.
AND IF NECESSARY TO PASS A FEAR
ATTACKS TO DO SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF THERE ARE
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS --
MR MATHIS.
SO I'LL TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE I'VE GOT SEVERAL
QUESTIONS REGARDING TO FUNDING --
IN THIS ARE PROBABLY BEST --
DIRECTED FOR ALL THE STRESS WALL --
AND AND MISTER CRAWFORD I'M SURE
YOU PROBABLY HAVE SOME THE
ANSWERS AND AND I DO APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT ALL OF YOU --
SUSAN IS FROM MY DISTRICT AND WE
TALK A LOT.
AND I LOVE YOUR FASHION I'M GLAD
THAT YOU'RE HERE.
PUSHING THIS FORWARD --
BUT AGAIN MY CONCERNS OR OR TO
COST IN IF IT'S ENOUGH --
YOU KNOW WE WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW THERE'S OVER TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR WATER SYSTEMS
THAT WERE TRACKING PLUS.
SEVERAL THOUSAND OTHER ONES SHOW
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST TO RUN ONE
OF THOSE SYSTEMS AND I KNOW IT
DEPENDS ON WHETHER IT'S OUR
SNICKER NITRATE TO CETERA.
OR EVEN ON THE COAST SALT WATER
INTRUSION SO I MEAN DO WE HAVE
AN AVERAGE COST.
PER SYSTEM.
THAT YOU CAN GIVE US OR OR JUST
A GUESSTIMATE TO GIVE US KIND OF
GO FROM POINT IT WOULD BE A GAS
AND SO I WOULDN'T WANT TO JUST
THROW SOME OF FIGURE OUT TO I I
CAN TALK TO OUR DIVISION THE
DRINKING WATER AND SEE IF WE
HAVE.
YOU KNOW THE THE DIFFICULTY AS
YOU POINTED OUT IS.
IT DEPENDS ON A NUMBER OF
CONNECTIONS IT DEPENDS WHAT YOUR
TREATMENT TRAIN IS IT DEPENDS
THE SIZE OF YOUR DISTRIBUTION
CENTER SO.
YOU KNOW TO PLUCK OUT WHAT A
SORT OF A NO A RANGE OF SOME
SORT WILL.
HALF A MILLION A YEAR A MILLION
A YEAR I MEAN KIDS BECAUSE AGAIN
WHAT WE WERE PROPOSING LOOKING
AT IS A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION A
YEAR.
AND WE SEE A NUMBER LIKE.
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR YOU'RE
TALKING CHANGING FILTERS YOU'RE
TALKING STAFFING YOU'RE TALKING
KEEPING THE SYSTEMS RUNNING THE
MAIN AND SIX CETERA I THINK.
IF I MAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK
THE IMPORTANT THING TO REMEMBER
ON THE DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR THAT
FUND IS THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO A
TO A FULL PAY FOR THE OPERATION
WHOLE OPERATION OF A SYSTEM.
RIGHT --
THAT YOU KNOW IT MAY BE A IT'S
GOING TO BE A COMBINATION SO.
SAVE YOU COME INTO A COMMUNITY.
THERE'S AN ISSUE YOU HAVE MAYBE
A NUMBER FAILING SYSTEMS MAYBE
THERE'S YOU KNOW TEN OR ELEVEN
SYSTEMS WITHIN A GIVEN AREA.
THE WORK THAT WOULD BE DONE IS
WHAT ARE THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
REGIONALIZATION FIRST AND
FOREMOST YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU SO
WHAT IS WHAT IS THE RATE PAYER
BASE WITHIN THAT.
WITHIN THAT THAT AREA SO YOU MAY
THEN PACKAGE TOGETHER --
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAN --
THEY MAY THEN --
ALSO THEN IDENTIFY CAPITAL AND
TO AND AND AND NOW IT IS DONE I
I I I FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT SORT
OF OPERATION MAINTENANCE OR
RIGHT I UNDERSTAND THAT I AND I
KNOW MISTER CROW FOOT AND I WERE.
TREMENDOUSLY WITH THE SIDE PART
OF BILL WITH ANNEXING PART OF
THE AREA IN --
WHAT YOU COULD PLACE WELL COST
PLUS TREATMENT PLUS EVERYTHING
ELSE?
BUT YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A LOOK AT
THE THE NUMBERS THAT I WANT TO
HEAR BACK ON TRACK OR HOW MUCH
IT COST --
SMALL COMMUNITY SYSTEMS VERSUS
LARGER SYSTEMS.
ON YOU MENTIONED THE END ON A
WHAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL IN THAT
NUMBER IS A DISTINGUISHING
BETWEEN THE THE COST PER PERSON
IN THE STATE EXACTLY SO I LARGER
LARGER SIDE OF LOVE TO SAY I I
THINK SPECIALLY WITH THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL COMING UP.
THOSE NUMBERS IN THOSE ANSWERS
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT --
YOU'D ALSO MENTIONED THE LA
INFRASTRUCTURE --
IS AGED SO A COST ON WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
PROPORTIONATE WITH THEIR SYSTEMS
ON FIXING THAT.
AS WELL AS IF THERE'S A NUMBER
OUT THERE ON THE COST TO CLEAN
UP THE BLOOM THAT IS IN --
I IT WAS ALL WATER INTRUSION
ALONG OUR COASTAL CITIES.
AND THE COST OF DEALING WITH
THAT AND IF ANY OF THIS FUNDING
WOULD GO TO THE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER ASPECT OF THAT FOR ANY OF
THOSE CITIES THAT ARE DOING
GROUND WATER.
THAT ARE DOING THE SALT WATER
INTRUSION AS WELL AS DEALING
WITH THE CROWN SIX FACTORS FOR
ANY.
AREAS THAT ARE DONE WITH
COLORADO RIVER WATER BECAUSE
IT'S NATIONAL ECOLOGY FROM THOSE
SYSTEMS --
ESPECIALLY.
AND THE COACHELLA VALLEY AREA
AND THOSE DEALS.
AND THEN MY OTHER QUESTION TO
YOU IS DO WE HAVE ANY
PROJECTIONS ON THE FERTILIZER
TAX -- WHAT
THAT MADE DO WITH A INFLATION ON
FOOD PRICING?
AS WELL AS WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
OUR SOCIAL SECURITY NET AND
PAYING FOR WHAT EVERYONE KNOWS
IS FOOD STAMPS AND WHAT THE
ADDITIONAL COST ON THE STATE
WOULD BE.
ON THAT SIDE DEALING WITH THAT
INFLATION PRICE.
AND THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
BASIC NUMBERS I'D LIKE TO SEE --
AS WE LOOK BECAUSE AGAIN MY MY
LARGEST CONCERN IS I THEY HAVE A
REALLY HARD TIME THINKING A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION.
IS GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO COVER
THE STATE STATEWIDE AND I REALLY
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
SOMETHING.
THAT'S GONNA PUT MORE INTO IT
AND THEN ALL WE ALL KNOW.
A HUGE PART OF THE GROUND WATER --
CLEAN UP IS DUE TO THE FACT OF
THE DROUGHT THE DEPLETED WATER
THAT'S DOWN THERE.
AND WE HAVE TO DO GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE WHICH WILL ADD TO THOSE
BAY SANDS WHICH WILL DIE LIEU
ANY TOXINS AND GET US TO WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS THAT WE KNOW
WE NEED.
CHAU WOULD ANY OF THIS FUNDING
ACTUALLY GO TOWARDS RECHARGE
PROJECTS WHICH WE KNOW WOULD
INCREASE --
THE QUALITY OF THE WATER THAT'S
IN THE GROUND.
IF I COULD ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
KNOW THAT'S A LOT YEAH NO IT'S
BUT IT'S THERE AND THEY'RE
HELPFUL QUESTIONS --
ON THE SECOND QUESTION REGARDING
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF OF OF OF
THE PROPOSED INCREASE IN IN
FERTILIZER FEE --
WE CAN GET BACK TO YOU AND WILL --
WORK WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT FOOD AGRICULTURE JUST
TO CHARACTERIZE ANY POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF OF THAT
INCREASE --
I WILL SAY TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION I WOULD JUST --
IDENTIFY FOR THE COMMITTEES --
THE FAIRLY A TECHNICAL ESTIMATE --
THAT -- WAS
GENERATED LAST YEAR TO INFORM
THE THE ESTIMATED COST OF
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT --
SAFE DRINKING WATER THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY CHALLENGING BECAUSE
THAT TOPIC IS NOT BEEN --
FULLY TACKLE BEFORE AND A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM AND SOLUTION
IS HIGHLY LOCALIZED BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THAT A FAIRLY DETAILED
METHODOLOGY --
WAS ESTABLISHED TO ESTIMATE THE
COST --
SPECIFICALLY DOES --
SYSTEMS THAT ARE IMPACTED BY NAY
TRADE ONLY POLLUTION --
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY NAY TRADE
POLLUTION AND OTHER CONTAMINANTS
OR OTHER CONTAMINANTS Là IN
THAT'S THAT'S WHY I ASKED THE
QUESTION WITH THE RECHARGE.
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW A LOT OF THE
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE THE HIGH
NITRATE CONTENT ARE ALSO
AFFECTED FROM THE DROUGHT IN.
THE AQUIFER'S OF DRUG
SIGNIFICANTLY THERE AND I KNOW
ONE OF THE VIABLE THINGS THAT'S
BEEN USED IS TO CONVEY WATER
DOWN TO THOSE AREAS A NEW
SURFACE WATER IN LIEU OF
GROUNDWATER.
BUT WITH THAT IF WE HAVE OUR OWN
CHALLENGES WITH CONVEYANCE
SYSTEMS AND MAINTENANCE OF THOSE
SYSTEMS.
ON IN IN KEEPING THEM UP TO DATE
UP TO STANDARD --
SO YOU KNOW IS THAT COST
FACTORED IN ON MAINTAINING THOSE
CONVEYANCE SYSTEMS AS WELL.
UNDERSTOOD I WOULD JUST MAKE
THREE FINAL POINTS ONE IS THE
LEGISLATURE WISELY APPROPRIATED
FUNDING FOR A MORE DETAILED
NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT THE WATER
BOARD IS IS CURRENTLY CONDUCTING --
WHICH WILL.
BE IMPORTANT --
AND THAT I'VE ACTUALLY JUST LET
ME LET ME TAKE A MOMENT AS THE
OTHER TWO POINTS WILL IN ON THAT
NEEDS ASSESSMENT WOULD WILL WE
DEFINITELY LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH YOUR OFFICE SO
THAT YOU CAN.
UNDERSTAND THE DATA SETS WE HAVE
YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE ABLE TO
CHARACTERIZE ISSUES IN THE
COMMUNITIES RIGHT NOW AND TRY TO
GET SOME YOUR ANSWERS TO THE
NUMBERS AND AND I WOULD JUST
MAKE TWO FINAL POINTS ONE IS AS
I THINK THE SENATOR NOTED.
ON THE CURRENT PROPOSAL --
THAT AT LEAST WAS INTRODUCED
LAST YEAR.
CAPS THE THAT CONSUMER SURCHARGE
THAT -- IF
IF THAT WERE ACTUALLY PASSED --
THAT THERE WOULD BE --
YOU KNOW THERE WOULD BE AN
ABILITY TO INCREASE THAT AFFECT
THE COST OUT WENT UP BUT I WILL
NOTE THAT YOU KNOW WHAT WE KNOW
TODAY IS THAT.
SEVERAL HUNDRED OF THESE SYSTEMS --
I HAVE MAJOR ISSUES THAT CANNOT
BE ADDRESSED WITHOUT A ON GOING
FUNDING SOURCE.
SO WE HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
YOU KNOW --
BEFORE AROUND TO IN TERMS OF
REALLY TRYING TO GET PRECISE AND
WHILE IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
PRECISE ON THE OVERALL ESTIMATE.
WE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE DON'T
WANT TO MAKE THE PERFECT THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD IN OTHER WORDS
WE KNOW WE HAVE TO GET TO WORK --
SOLVING THESE CHALLENGES AND
LASTLY I WOULD JUST SAY FOR TO
DETERMINE QUIRKS --
JUST RAISING THIS QUESTION OF
GENERAL FUND PART OF THE
CHALLENGING NATURE OF THE OF THE
NEED FOR I'M GOING OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE.
IS IT'S IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AND
AND I WOULD ARGUE PROBABLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND I'M GOING --
TO OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
CONTRACTS IN THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES WITH ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND --
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE OLOGY
BUT YOU ONLY ARE FUNDED OFFER A
YEAR OF OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO ESTABLISH A SERVICE CONTRACT
WITH THE TECHNICAL PROVIDER. TO
ACTUALLY OPERATE YOUR SYSTEM SO
THAT REALLY IS THE NEED FOR THE
ON GOING --
A FUNDING SOURCE MOLD AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHY I'M LOOKING AT A
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD BE ON GOING
GENERAL FUND --
TIED IN WITH THE STATE
CONSTITUTION GOING TO THE HUMAN
RIGHT A WATER --
A AND I MEAN AGAIN THE INK THE
BIGGER THING WITH WATER IT AS WE
ALL KNOW WATER IS A VERY
HOLISTIC SYSTEM ALL THE WAY FROM
HEADWATERS. TO CONVEYANCE TO
STORES TO RECHARGE TO CLEAN UP
IN THE WHOLE LINE SO WE'VE GOT
TO ENSURE THAT WHATEVER WE'RE
DOING WE TAKE IN ALL ASPECTS OF
THAT.
AND I UNDERSTAND WERE HYPER
FOCUSED ON THE CLEAN WATER PART
BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUFFERING THAT SHOULDN'T BE
SUFFERING.
AND THE AGAIN WITH THE SUSAN'S
PASSION --
AND WE'RE SHE HEADQUARTERED
RIGHT LIKE TWO BLOCKS FROM MY
OFFICE SO WE TALKED A LOT --
AND PROBABLY SHOULD TOOK ON A
LOT MORE BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING INTIMATELY INVOLVED WITH
THE PROCESS ON THIS.
AND I EXPECT TO BE --
BECAUSE I'M NOT FULLY CONVINCED
YET AND I'M SURE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE THERE AS WELL.
THAT I I DON'T THINK THIS IS
ENOUGH HELL OF A LOT BETTER.
AND I THINK WE DESERVE IS IS WE
TALKED WE MADE THIS A HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER. FOR OUR STATE
AND I THINK WE SHOULD DEFINITELY
PUT SOMETHING IN OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT THE FINES THAT
THAT GUARANTEES AND LOCKS THE
FUNDING IN THERE.
SO THAT WE HAVE AN ON GOING
FUNDING STREAM SO THERE ISN'T A
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT THIS
IS ENOUGH.
AND THEN WE CAN PRIORITIZE
PROJECTS BASED ON THAT AND
PRIORITIZE THE MAINTENANCE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE TO ENSURE.
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST DOING THIS
TO TO ATTACK COLD ONE ASPECT
OVER COVERING THE FULL WATER
SYSTEM OF CALIFORNIA FOREVER FOR
ALL FUTURE GENERATIONS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY.
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
I APPRECIATE --
THE INFORMATION I REALLY DON'T
HAVE A QUESTION I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT I DID A BILL COUPLE
YEARS AGO --
DURING THE DROUGHT WHEN WE WERE
WE WERE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
PORTERVILLE AND YOU KNOW THE
WELLS AND THOUGH SO I TRIED IT
THAT. TO ONE OF THE CRITICISMS I
HAVE IS THAT --
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT REGIONALIZATION WHICH
WE NEED WE NEED TO TAKE THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NEXT TO
EACH OTHER AND MAKE A SYSTEM
THAT IS EFFICIENT THAT WORKS
TOTALLY GET THAT.
BUT I DID A BILL THAT TIME.
ALLOWED TO DO AT THE SOURCE
FILTRATION SO THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY RIGHT THEN PUT.
IN THE LINE SOMETHING THAT
FILTERS HE WAS A LITTLE HOW TO
MADE AS WELL TRUST ME I WOULD
LEARN HOW TO MADE IT'S A FILTER
AT MY HOUSE IF IT MEANT MY KIDS
GOT TO DRINK THE WATER THAT CAME
OUT OF THE TAP SO.
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT ALL
ALL THESE --
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY DRIVE THE
COST DOWN --
AND SERVE MORE PEOPLE SO I JUST
WANT TO THROW THAT OUT THAT
SOMETHING THAT --
I ACTUALLY TRIED TO DO --
SEEMED LIKE A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO ME --
THAT WAY WE THE BILL DIED IN THE
SENATE AND IT DIDN'T DIDN'T
HAPPEN SO WOULD YOU TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION BECAUSE I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF FAMILIES
OUT THERE LEARN HOW.
TO MAKE THIS A FILTER IF THEIR
KIDS CAN DRINK GOOD WATER.
MAYBE IN ONE OF A MEMBER.
THE ONE WE CAN RESPOND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YES ABSOLUTELY THAT THAT
THAT WE NEED WE NEED TO CONSIDER --
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENTS TO DRIVE
DOWN THE COST PARTICULARLY
DECENTRALIZED FILTRATION I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT.
AS I'VE HEARD THE CONVERSATION
CHARACTERIZED ON THIS NOTION OF
SORT OF DECENTRALIZED FILTRATION
OR UNDER THE SINK FILTRATION.
WE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW FILTRATION --
TECHNOLOGY OR EQUIPMENT WAS
PROVIDED --
SO YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT WE'VE
COME TO EXPECT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IS YOU KNOW THE
RIPPED OUT THE WATER FLOWING OUT
OF YOUR TAP IS SAFE AND CLEAN.
AND WHAT WE WOULD WANT TO AVOID
IS THAT YOU KNOW TO HOUSEHOLDS
NEXT TO EACH OTHER --
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY --
HAVE DIFFERENT QUALITY WATER --
SIMPLY BY YOU KNOW THE BEHAVIOR
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE.
IF I MAY IF YOU HAVE A LOT OF
THESE.
FOLKS WRONG WELLS IN THERE AND
THAT SERVICING THAT HOUSE AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BRING A
SYSTEM IS CUT AND IT'S IT'S
SOMETIMES TENS OF THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO GET OUT TO SERVICE
THEM.
YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE COST AND GO
CAN WE STILL AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S DIFFERENT CONTAMINANTS
THAT SOME FILTERS DON'T WORK IN
SOME I GET ALL THAT I I I HEARD
IT ALL IN MY IN THE TESTIMONY
WHEN I RAN THE BILL.
BUT I KNOW I KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT THERE ARE SOME CONTENT IT'S
WE CAN TAKE OUT RIGHT AT THE AT
THE HOUSE AND THERE'S WE SHOULD
BE DOING THAT IT'S IT'S A MATTER
OF SOMEBODY NOT HAVING A DIRT
BIRTH DEFECT BY HAVING CLEAN
WATER THAT'S JUST COMMON SENSE.
TO ME AND IT DRIVES ACOSTA --
SO I I KNOW YOU'LL TAKE IT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND EITHER BE A
LOT EXPERTS OUT THERE SAYING YOU
KNOW WILL THE KIDS WHAT ACROSS
THE STREET.
AT IN THE DAY WE STILL NEED TO
GET THOSE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO TRY THAT COST DOWN
AND GET GET CLEAN WATER AT THE
SOURCE.
I THINK IT'S DEFINITELY
IMPORTANT TO ON THE TOOL SET AND
I WOULD JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I
THINK RECENTLY WE JUST CLARIFIED
OUR POINT OF VIEW SOME POINT OF
ENTRY --
TECHNOLOGY RAGS --
OR OR USE RAGS YOU THOUGHT IT
SNOW WE NEED WE NEED THE SORT OF
AN TRUMP --
TOOLS AND SOLUTIONS BECAUSE
REALLY IT'S ABOUT ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THAT TAPE I CAN CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MAY JUST ADD TO THAT I I AGREE
WITH THE CONVERSATION OF HAVING
SHORT TERM OPTIONS.
HOWEVER THE NEEDS TO BE TIED TO
A LONG TERM SOLUTION I WILL SAY
SOME AREAS --
HAVE SIX TIMES THE MCL FOR
NITRATES SO WE DON'T HAVE A
CERTIFIED FILTRATION DEVICE
STEVEN OFFER THESE FAMILIES.
AND YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE OF MAKING SURE YOU DO
PROPER MAINTENANCE SO I IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT SHORT
TERM SOLUTIONS BUT WE HAVE TO
TIE THAT TO LONG TERM STRATEGY.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD TO IT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THERE'S NOTHING AND
ANY OF THE LEGISLATION THAT I'VE
SEEN OR PROPOSALS THAT I'VE.
THAT I'VE SEEN THAT WOULD
PRECLUDE --
A SPENDING MONEY IN THAT WAY --
THERE'S NO ONE SIZE I THINK
EVERYBODY AGREES THERE'S NO ONE
SIZE FITS ALL --
SOLUTION FOR EVERY COMMUNITY AND
EVERY SYSTEM.
HERE -- NEXT
UP WE HAVE A DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU AND SHE DOESN'T NEED
NAME BUT IT'S WHOSE ON I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WASN'T SUSAN --
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE MY THE GUY
WAS ON THE PANEL AS WELL BUT
THERE'S A BIT OF PRIDE IN WHAT
OUR NAMES ARE AND WHERE WE COME
FROM -- I
DON'T WANT TO MISS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO CHANNEL AND
TALK ABOUT RECHARGE AS WE LOOK
AT 90% OF THE VALLEY WHICH IS
DEPENDENT ON GROUND WATER WE
HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH AS THE STATE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING
OUR MOST VITAL RESOURCE IN OUR
SAFEST BANK ACCOUNT BLOWER GRANT.
AND WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
STOP ARGUING ABOUT FISH AND TAKE
THE WATER THAT WE CAN AGREE
SHOULD BE RECHARGED.
AND START ME CHARGING SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. TO FIGURE OUT IF
THAT'S A LOW HANGING FRUIT THAT
WE CAN HELP WITH SOME OF THE TO
DILUTE SOME OF THE POLLUTION
THAT CURRENTLY IS OCCURRING THAT
NATURALLY.
OCCURRING WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM.
NOW IT'S NOT LOST ON ME THAT
THIS IS IN MY BACKYARD LATER
TODAY IM GOING TO MEET WITH.
MEMBERS FROM LAND AIR AND FROM
COME TO A CREEK AND FROM
TOMBSTONE TERRITORY PLACES THAT
ARE ON MY NECK OF THE WOODS
PLACES THAT YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE
HEARD.
BUT THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO I TOOK
CARE OF IN MY PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE.
WHO OFTENTIMES COULDN'T STAY
HEALTHY BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY
WERE OR WERE NOT PUTTING INTO
THEIR BODY?
AND WHEN WE DON'T HAVE SAVE
SOLUTIONS LIKE BEING PRESENTED
BEFORE US.
I WANT TO FIRST ASK ARE WE
DEALING WITH IT LARGELY AND OFF.
I WANT TO CONCURRENT THAT I WISH
SENATOR MONNING HAD HERE LAST
YEAR.
BECAUSE WE'D BE A LOT FURTHER
DOWNSTREAM AND DEALING WITH THE
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US.
BUT ARE WE ADDRESSING ENOUGH
RESOURCES TOWARDS THIS PROBLEM
IS A HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH.
OR DO WE NEED TO COUPLE THAT
WITH A LARGE ONE TIME INVESTMENT
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO DEAL WITH
THE SEVERITY OF THIS PROBLEM.
NOW I COME TO IT AS ONE OF THE
BUDGET CHAIRS AND I KNOW I'M
STEPPING OUT OF MY JURISDICTION.
BUT ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE
MULTITUDES OF PROPOSALS BEFORE
US THAT ARE EXPENSIVE BUT IF WE
CAN'T START WITH THE BASICS OF
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AS A HUMAN
RIGHT FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT'S AWFULLY HARD FOR ME TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN KEEP.
HEALTH FOR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES A PRIORITY AS WELL.
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHETHER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION GETS
US UP TO SPEED FAST ENOUGH OR
WOULD A ONE TIME INVESTMENT IF
THE LEGISLATURE WAS WILLING.
HELP TO ASSIST IN ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE WE
HAVE TODAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER I'LL TAKE A SHOT --
AND JUST FIRST OF ALL ON
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE I THINK
THAT'S ARE ONE OF THOSE RARE
ISSUES IN WATER POLICY WHERE
EVERYONE AGREES LET'S CAPTURE AS
MUCH OF THAT WINTER RAIN.
GET INTO GROUNDWATER BASINS
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE IMPACTS
OF IMPLEMENTING THIS IS DOUBLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT SO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THAT --
I'LL SAY REGARDING THE COST
ESTIMATE OF A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE DO BELIEVE
THAT IT CAN ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
WHAT'S REMARKABLE ABOUT THE
SOLUTION IS IT'S NOT THAT
EXPENSIVE.
THESE ARE OFF THE SHELF
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE TECH IN A
DEVELOPED AND REFINED OVER TIME
AND COST IS COME DOWN --
SO IT'S NOT LIKE --
YOU KNOW FINDING A TECH YOU KNOW
A TERRIBLY TECHNICALLY
TECHNICALLY DIFFICULT YOU KNOW
SOLUTION IN EVERY COMMUNITY IT'S
SIMPLY BRINGING THE TECHNOLOGY
IN AN OPERATING THE TECHNOLOGY.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE WITH A ONE
TIME FUNDING IS AGAIN THAT I'M
GOING OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE --
THE BONDS THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
ESTABLISHING ONE TIME FUNDING --
AS RECENTLY AS PROP SIXTY EIGHT
IN JUNE --
WHAT WE REALLY NEED IS AT A
LOOSE OF ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE?
IS THERE A POSSIBILITY FOR A
HYBRID OF THESE TWO SOLUTIONS AS
WE GO THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS AND
I'M JUST TRYING.
AT SOME POINTS TO GAIN THE
INFORMATION AND AND LOOK IT'S
IT'S IT'S HARD WHEN WE HAVE THE
SURPLUS THAT WE DO NOT TO WANT
TO SPEND IT ON THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SPENDING IT ON
IN THE PAST.
AND SOI THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH WE COULD DO WITHIN ONE TIME
WHILE ALSO LOOKING TOWARDS WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO HAVE THE SAFE
AND RELIABLE ON GOING SPENDING
THAT YOU'RE RECOMMENDING AND SO.
I JUST WOULD ASK THIS COMMITTEE
IN MEMBERSHIP DOES THINK ABOUT A
HYBRID MODEL THAT ALLOWS US. TO
CONSIDER ALL OPTIONS BEFORE US
SO THAT WE CAN GET A DEAL DONE
THIS YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
IS PRESSES NEXT.
I JUST WANT TO COMPLIMENT --
THE CHAIRS --
FOR BRINGING TO US EXPERTS THAT
INCLUDE THE COMMUNITY.
I THINK IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT --
WATER TALKING ABOUT CLEAN
DRINKING WATER BEING A HUMAN
RIGHT.
THAT WE INCLUDE THE COMMUNITY
KING THE WATER THAT IS NOT CLEAN
AND DRINKABLE.
SO -- SO SON
ON THEM THAT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
PART OF THIS PANEL AND THAT YOUR
VOICE IS HERE REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY AND I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THAT THE COMMUNITIES HERE
IN BENITO SUBTLE SYSTEM THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GARCIA.
MY QUESTION IS IN REGARDS.
TO HOW WE ANTICIPATE TO
PRIORITIZE --
THE REGION'S SEVERITY OF THE
PROBLEMS AND I KNOW THAT MAYBE
HORSE BUT IF IF WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY --
THAT WERE --
ATTEMPTING TO TO SECURE HERE --
WHETHER IT BE THROUGH MISTER
BONDING STAFFORD TORY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT --
HOW ARE WE LOOKING AT
PRIORITIZING --
THE PROBLEM [inaudible]
THE IF YOU I WELL I'LL TAKE A
FIRST CRACK YOU KNOW I THINK --
OBVIOUSLY THE SYSTEMS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE ARE KIND OF THE BLADE
FROM BIG BLINKING RED DOTS BUT I
THINK YOUR POINT.
YOU KNOW THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT I
THINK WILL HELP PROVIDE --
SORT OF A A SCAFFOLDING IF YOU
WILL OF ASSESSING NEAR WHERE THE
PRIORITY SHOULD BE AGAIN.
SYSTEMS OUT OF COMPLIANCE THAT'S
EASY ONE BUT IT'S REALLY THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE OR CLOSE TO IT
TO BEING OUT OF COMPLIANCE THAT
ARE YOU KNOW ONE ONE PROBLEM THE
WAY THAT WE WANT TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY.
BEGIN TO ADDRESS PRIOR TO THEY
GET THERE AND SO I THINK THE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT WILL CONTINUE
TO ON EARTH --
A LOT OF WHAT YOU KNOW THAT THAT
MAY LOW OVERLAY DATA AND REALLY
BEGIN TO ZERO IN ON ON WHERE
EXACTLY IT IS THAT YOU NEED --
TO TO FOCUS IN ON PERSON OFF AND
AGAIN THE OBVIOUS ARE ARE THE
BIG SYSTEMS OUT OF COMPLIANCE
BUT AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT --
GOVERNOR BROWN THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORTED THE MOVE THAT THE MOVE
OF THAT DIVISION OF DRINKING
WATER FROM THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH TO THE WATER BOARD --
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND THAT WAS A
HUGE STEP TO SORT OF BREAK DOWN
FRAGMENTATION ON THIS ISSUE.
I'M SO WE DO HAVE A DIVISION OF
DRINKING WATER AT THE WATER
BOARD AND DURING PAHLAVAS WHO
LEADS THAT IS ACTUALLY HERE
TODAY.
SO -- IF
HE'S AVAILABLE TO ACTUALLY
ANSWER THAT THAT QUESTION AND
AND PART OF HIS JOB IS
UNDERSTANDING SPECIFICALLY HOW
WE PUT TO WORK THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU PROVIDE.
WILL IF YOU HAVE A BEER BRING
THEM UP GREAT.
HIGH OTHERWISE HE CAME.
FOR THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
I'M DEBORAH AMOS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE DIVISION A DRINKING
WATER IT STATE WATER BOARD --
TO QUESTION PRIORITIZATION IS IS
ALWAYS A TRICKY --
ONE AS A FORMER RISK OF ALL SAID
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO START WHERE
WE KNOW THE WATER.
SYSTEMS ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE
AND AYE I THINK KIND OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART TO REALIZE IT WE
WANT TO DO IS WE WANT TO FIND
FISSIONS HIS FIRST.
THIS FUNDING THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DO IS NOT ALL ON IN
ADDITION OPERATION OF SYSTEMS
NOW SO.
A LOT OF THE EARLY WORK WE PLAN
TO DO WILL GO INTO
CONSOLIDATIONS.
ARGAN MINISTRY --
IS TO TRY TO OF HELP SYSTEMS
UNDERSTAND THEIR TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS AND REALLY GET A GRASP
OF WHERE THAT'S AT AND THEN WE
YOU KNOW PLANNED OVERTIME MORE
FAT INTO THEN THE EXISTING
PROBLEMS THAT STAND SO.
IT'LL BE A MOVING TARGET AND THE
BEAUTY OF THE OF THE DRINKING
WATER BEING AT THE WATER BOARD I
WAS IT DOES PRODUCE DISSIPATION
DISCUSSIONS GET TO COME BEFORE
THE BOARD IN A PUBLIC FORUM SO
THAT WE GET TO ADJUST.
ON THE FLY AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE ON IT AND I I REALIZE HOW
OF COMPLICATE THIS COULD BE
RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS ON THIS LIKE A COMPETITION
OF WHO'S GOT THE DIRTIEST WATER
WILL GO FIRST.
RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT IT
BOILS DOWN TO AND THEN WE BEGIN
TO INVEST IN THOSE AREAS.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY THOUGHT INTO
HOW AS WERE PRIORITIZING THESE
AREAS WITH THE RED DOTS.
HOW MONEY COMING FROM THOSE
AREAS CAN GO BACK TO THOSE AREAS?
GIVING BOTH RATE PAYERS --
WATER AGENCIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THE CERTAINTY RIGHT
THAT MONEY'S GOING BACK TO THOSE
REGIONS TO ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM I WILL.
I WILL SAY OR GIVE THE
COMPARISON.
I THINK ONE OF THE REASONS WHY.
THE TWELFTH AN INCREASE ON
GASOLINE FOR ROAD IMPROVEMENTS --
SURVIVED IT'S YOU KNOW TEST IN
NOVEMBER WAS BECAUSE THESE
REGIONS OF THE STATE ARE.
WE'RE BEGINNING TO SEE THE USE
OF THOSE DOLLARS IMMEDIATELY.
RIGHT AND SO IS THERE.
A THOUGHT BEHIND HOW WE
IMMEDIATELY THESE INVESTMENTS TO
THESE AREAS WHERE PEOPLE SEE THE
MONEY THAT THEY'RE SENDING TO
SACRAMENTO OR MAYBE NOT --
STAYING THERE LOCALLY TO ADDRESS --
THE CLEAN WATER ISSUES IN THEIR
OWN.
BACKYARD.
WELL I'LL JUST SAY FIRST OF ALL
OF THE SORT OF THE HIGHEST LEVEL
I THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS BEEN
VERY CLEAR THAT HE WELCOMES ALL
THE IDEAS ON HOW WE SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AS LONG AS WE FOCUS ON
SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
SO -- CHAIR --
GARCIA'S I THINK YOUR
IDENTIFYING IS THE POSSIBILITY
OF ESSENTIALLY KIND OF REGIONAL
LIES IN THE COLLECTION
APPLICATIONS OF OF OF OF THESE
FUNDS -- SO
THAT --
FUNDING COLLECTED THROUGH FEE
TAX IN ONE REGION'S OR TO STAYS
IN THE REGION TO WORK ON CLEAN
AND SAFE DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS --
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING WE'VE
DELVED INTO IN GREAT DETAIL BUT
IT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
CONSTRUCTIVE IDEAS THAT WE
SHOULD THINK THROW.
I I ASKED THE QUESTION BECAUSE
IN LAST YEAR'S DELIBERATIONS.
THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
CONCERN.
RIGHT THAT THERE WAS A BIG FOCUS
ON OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
CENTRAL AREA SALINAS VALLEY --
AND MAKING SURE THAT THERE WAS
THE WORD WAS BEING USED
EQUITABLE WAY OF DISTRIBUTING
THE RESOURCES TO THESE AREAS
WHERE WE SEE THE RED DOTS --
WAS ONE FACTOR I THINK THAT GAVE
PEOPLE SOME RESERVATIONS
PARTICULARLY WATER AGENCIES --
WHO WERE BEING GIVEN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF COLLECTING
THIS MONEY SENDING IT UP AND
MAYBE NEVER?
SEEN IT AGAIN.
I THINK THAT'S A FAIR POINT I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN FUNDED BY
STATEWIDE BONDS.
WHERE WE'RE ESSENTIALLY
INDICTING OURSELVES AND OUR KIDS --
TO FIND INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND SO IN TERMS OF THIS QUESTION
OF RATE SHAFT JUST REST ASSURED
THERE'S PLENTY OF FUNDING THAT'S
GONE FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR
COACHELLA. TWO URBAN WATER
DISTRICTS TO FIND IN THE
FACILITIES ARE STORM WATER
CAPTURE.
SO I ALWAYS I ALWAYS CAUTION
PEOPLE TO BE A LITTLE BIT
CAREFUL ON THIS QUESTION OF OF
RATE SHIPPED UNLESS YOU REALLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE FUNDING --
QUESTION MORE HOLISTICALLY WE
GET WE GET IT.
RIGHT -- WE
HARDLY UNDERSTAND THAT --
ON THE GROUND.
RIGHT IT'S WE WHO HAVE TO GO
BACK AND SAY WE SUPPORTED THIS
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA DO THAT.
AND NOT.
ULTIMATELY SEE THAT HAPPEN RIGHT
SO I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF PUT
THAT -- ON
THE TABLE AND THAT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING OF MUCH INTEREST TO ME
AND I DO ARE JUST OF KNOWLEDGE
AND RECOGNIZE THE NEED
COMMITMENT FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM PORTER AVAILABLE IS ALSO.
PUT FORWARD A CONCEPT.
RIGHT A CONCEPT THAT REALLY TIES
OUR HANDS TO THIS GUY.
COMMITMENT WE'VE MADE TO THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT IT WOULD
GET.
YOU KNOW IT'S DAY IN COURT AND
AND AND REALLY BAD OUT THAT THE
IDEA THAT IF WE'RE TRULY
COMMITTED.
THAT WE'RE MAKING A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT AS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE X. AMOUNT OF MONEY EVERY
SINGLE YEAR WHETHER IT'S THERE.
OR NOT IT THERE IS A COMMITMENT
THAT GOES TOWARDS FUNDING --
OUR PRIORITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
AND THIS SEEMS TO BE A PRIORITY
I MEAN GIVEN --
THE COMMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
THE COMMITMENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS MADE --
AND CLEARLY THE PARTICIPATION
TODAY AND SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
THERE IS SOME SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION. TO VETTING THAT
OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT SURE QUIRK I THINK OF A
FOLLOW UP YES --
SO MY CONCERN IF YOU LOOK AT
WHERE THESE STOCKS ARE.
THIS IS A TRANSFER OF MONEY FROM
THE URBAN AREAS TO THE RURAL
AREAS IF YOU MAKE IT REGIONAL.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET ANY MONEY
FOR THE RURAL AREAS TO SPEAK UP.
SO I THINK IT'S A TERRIBLE LIFE
T. --
BECAUSE MY DISTRICT HAS NOTHING
OUT OF COMPLIANCE NEITHER.
I WILL SAY THIS.
THERE IS A PROBLEM.
JUST NORTH OF MY DISTRICT IN
OAKLAND WITH LEAD PIPES WITH
PIPE LED COMING FROM PIPES NONE
OF THAT MONEY WOULD GO TO THAT.
AND YET I'M WILLING TO BET THAT
MR BONTA WHO REPRESENTS THAT
DISTRICT WOULD BE WILLING TO
TRANSFER THAT MONEY TO YOUR
DISTRICT WHICH DOES HAVE THIS
PROBLEM SO I JUST DON'T THINK
THE REGIONALIZATION.
WORKS AT ALL I CAN PRETTY MUCH
GUARANTEE THAT ANY MONEY COMING
OUT OF YOUR REGION WILL BE MORE
THAN MATCHED WITH MONEY COMING
OUT OF THE URBAN AREAS.
AND I THINK YOU COULD SELL IT TO
YOUR REGION'S FOR THAT PURPOSE
THAT THIS IS BY AND LARGE THE
URBAN RICHER AREAS SUBSIDIZING
THE POOR OLD POOR RURAL AREAS.
FOR ALL PRACTICAL PURPOSES AND I
THINK WE CAN GET THE VOTES OUT
OF THE URBAN AREAS.
WELL I WILL NOT ARGUE WITH THE
DOCTOR WELL.
OKAY WE'RE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TURN THIS INTO A DEBATE --
SINCE THIS IS NOT A POLICY
DISCUSSION TODAY.
SOME THOUGHTS AND IDEAS THERE
ARE GETTING LAID OUT ON THE ON
THE TABLE HERE --
MISTER CRAWFORD DID YOU WANT TO
ADD SOMETHING IN THE LAW WILL
NOT.
COME A QUESTION FROM I WON'T I
WON'T DOT I WON'T ENTER THAT
DEBATE BUT I WILL I JUST OBSERVE
THAT.
AS WE HONORAS I UNDERSTAND IT --
THIS FUND ACTUALLY WOULD BE ABLE
TO BE USED FOR OUR DRINKING
WATER QUALITY PROBLEMS IN URBAN
AREAS INCLUDING LAD.
I'M SO IT'S JUST REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND --
AND WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION JUST THE CHARACTER
OF THESE PROBLEMS IN URBAN AREAS
AND THE FACT THAT THIS --
THIS FIND ACTUALLY COULD HELP
ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
AND WILL CLOSE OUT THE QUESTIONS
FOR THIS PANEL --
WITH ONE FROM SENATOR MORE MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANEL
MEMBERS.
FOR YOUR ADDED EXPERTISE IN
COMMITMENT --
I THINK MISTER CROW FOOT
ANSWERED THE QUESTION THAT I HAD
BUT JUST PUT IT BACK ON THE
TABLE FOR MAYBE CLARIFICATION
FROM.
MISS DAN THIS WELL --
QUESTION OF RELYING ON THE
GENERAL FUND --
AS EITHER AN ALTERNATIVE TO
LOOKING TO RATE PAYERS OR AG
FEES OR IN ADDITION --
TO MR CROWFOOT DID DESCRIBE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PREDICTABILITY IN
REVENUE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONTRACTING FOR LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS AND I JUST WANT TO BE
EXPLICIT.
THAT.
WE ARE WE HAVE A HELP THE
GENERAL FUND IN A SURPLUS NOW.
BUT I'LL REMIND YOU WERE NINE
YEARS OUT IN OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FROM THE RECESSION IF
YOU LOOK RETROSPECTIVELY.
NO ECONOMIC GROWTH CARRIED HIS
EVER EXCEEDED SEVEN YEARS FOR
THE AVERAGE IS ABOUT SEVEN YEARS
SO WE'RE TWO YEARS BEYOND THAT.
AHEAD OF US WE DON'T KNOW WHEN.
BUT WE CAN SAY WITH CERTAINTY
THERE WILL BE A DIP.
OR A DROP.
IN THE GENERAL FUND WILL BE
STRAPPED TO MAINTAIN ONGOING
OBLIGATIONS TO EDUCATION TO
HEALTHCARE.
IT CETERA IN IF WE RELY UPON A
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION EACH
YEAR TO MEET.
THE OBJECTIVES OF THIS IT'S IT'S
TOO MUCH OF A CRAPSHOOT THAT'S
WHY WE LOOK TO A GUARANTEED
PREDICTABLE REVENUE SOURCE THAT
REGARDLESS.
OF ECONOMIC.
EXIGENCIES IN OUR BUDGET WE
STILL HAVE A PREDICTABLE SOURCE
AND ALSO TO ADD ON TO WHAT MR
CROWFOOT SAID --
WE USE BONTA MONEY FOR FOR
CERTAIN CAPITAL PROJECTS AND WE
PASS THE INTEREST PAYMENTS WE
ALL PAY THE INTEREST ON THAT.
THIS IS A DIRECT FUNDING SOURCE
THAT.
THE MONEY COMES IN GETS
ALLOCATED AND SPENT IN WERE NOT
INCURRING DEBT.
IN THIS CURRENT STRUCTURE SO --
I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT
AGAIN --
DOCTOR RUMBLE RAISE THE QUESTION
MAY BE LOOKING AT SOME CAPITAL
INFUSION.
UP FRONT FROM THE GENERAL FUND
IN ALL CREATIVE IDEAS BUT I I
WILL CONTINUE TO ARGUE FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF A PREDICTABLE LONG
TERM REVENUE SOURCE THAT'S NOT
LINKED TO OUR GENERAL FUND AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO ADD TO
THAT IF I BELIEVE THE GOVERNOR.
ECHOES THAT --
PRIORITIZATION AS WELL IN EITHER
MISTER CRAWFORD --
MISS DOWN AND IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT YEAH I'LL JUST SAY AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
WELL COLLECTIVELY FOCUSED ON
SOLVING THE PROBLEM AND AS WE GO --
AS WE'VE GONE OUT THERE AND TRY
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE FOR THE
FUNDING THAT'S NEEDED --
WHAT WE'VE UNDERSTOOD IS TO
OPERATE AND MAKE AND MAINTAIN
THIS TECHNOLOGY YOU YOU NEED I'M
GOING FUNDING SOURCE AND IT
WOULDN'T WORK TO HAVE A CHUNK
HERE A CHUNK THERE SKIP A YEAR
ANOTHER CHUNK THERE --
IF SOMEBODY CAN PROVE OTHERWISE --
THEY SHOULD THEY SHOULD BECAUSE
AND IF IT CAN WORK --
THAT WOULD BE OF COURSE
EXCELLENT BUT ALL OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
NOBODY'S BEEN ABLE TO TO TO
REALLY MAKE THAT CASE
EFFECTIVELY.
THANK YOU MISTY UNDID INTO THEM
I WOULD ECHO THAT AS WELL I
THINK THAT THE GENERAL FUND IS
UNRELIABLE AND UNPREDICTABLE.
AND TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE WE NEED
A SUSTAINABLE SOURCES PERMANENT.
TO ENSURE THAT WE SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM SO WE REALLY DO WE CAN
RELY ON A PERMANENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO ALLOW US TO HAVE THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE NEED.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES TO HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
MISTER KALRA.
I LIKE WHAT I DON'T WANT TO DO
NOW IS GO THROUGH ANOTHER ROUND
OF QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE --
OF NOT THAT MUCH TIME LEFT TO
HEAR THE THE NEXT THE NEXT PANEL --
FEEL QUESTIONS ON THAT PANEL AND
THEN WE WANT TO GIVE THE PUBLIC
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK SO I
APOLOGIZE I'M NOT TRYING TO CUT
YOU OFF IN A JUST A THIRTY
SECOND COMMENT --
ONE I I APPRECIATE YOUR GARCIA'S
COMMENTS REGARDING --
GETTING RESULTS SOON --
IT'S MUCH MORE DIFFICULT WITH
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE THEM WITH
PAVING ROADS AND BUILDING
BRIDGES YOU CAN SEE THAT MUCH
MORE QUICKLY YOU DON'T ALWAYS
SEE THE WHAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT DEALS WITH CLEAN WATER BUT
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO SHOW
RESULTS VERY QUICKLY.
IF WE'RE GOING TO HOWEVER WE
FIND IT AND THEN TO THE THE
POINT IS A LOWER COURT OKAY EVEN
IN SAN JOSE --
JUST LIKE OTHER IN AREAS LIKE
OAKLAND AND EVEN LA IN SOME
PARTS --
THERE HAVE BEEN ISSUES WITH --
TOXICITY LEAD IN OUR WATER SO
THE STAFF.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO EACH OF OUR
PANELISTS AND FOR ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS AND
I WILL NOW PASSED THE GAVEL OVER
TO CHAIR QUIRK FOR THE NEXT
BATTLE.
SO FOR THE NEXT PANEL I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE CHAIR BLOOMS COMMENT --
IT'S ELEVEN NOW AND I WOULDN'T
WANT TO START PUBLIC COMMENT ANY
LATER THAN NOON.
SO AND A LOT OF THE MEMBERS OF
BE LEAVING.
PROBABLY BY NOON --
SHORTLY AFTER SO WE SHOULD BE
CAREFUL ABOUT OUR QUESTIONS AND
WE'LL GO FROM THERE.
SO THE NEXT PANEL IS ABOUT
MANAGING AN IMPLEMENTING SAFE
DRINKING WATER --
WE FIRST WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM COST TO LOW ESTRADA --
BOARD VICE PRESIDENT --
CULTURALLY WITHOUT COACHELLA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT --
CHAIR.
GARCIA YOUR AREA --
CINDY PAULSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA URBAN WATER DISTRICT
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHO YOU
REPRESENT.
AND THEN PAUL JONES GENERAL
MANAGER EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND IF YOU COULD TELL
US WHERE THAT IS WHEN YOU --
I INTRODUCE YOURSELVES.
SO WE'RE GONNA FIRST HERE FROM
OUR CASTILLO ESTRADA
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
SO I JUST THE I WANT TO THANK A
HALL OF YOU.
FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
YOU.
HOW THIS ISSUE IS IS --
IMPACTING OUR REGION.
AND HOW WE'VE BEEN OUT TRYING TO
ADDRESS IT. FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME IS --
CAST LOW [inaudible]
STYLER.
I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
I WORK AS A CIVIL ENGINEER.
FOR THE KITCHEN WATER AUTHORITY.
A PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
THAT PROVIDES WATER TO THE CITY
OF COACHELLA.
A CITY OF ABOUT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
WHAT I'M GONNA TRY TO DO HERE IS --
PAINT A PICTURE FOR YOU.
OF THIS ISSUE IN OUR REGION I
THINK WHEN WE ALL HERE ABOUT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY.
SOME OTHER THINGS THAT WE KIND
OF PUT IN OUR MIND IS.
THE MUSIC FESTIVAL.
THE AMOUNT OF GOLF COURSES THAT
WE HAVE TO RESORT LIFE.
AND AND THAT'S A VERY REAL BUT
WE ALSO HAVE A REAL VERY REAL --
WATER.
ISSUE IN OUR REGION THAT I THINK
A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T KNOW ABOUT
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA
TRY TO PAY FOR YOU.
TODAY.
OF THE COACHELLA VALLEY IS MADE
UP OF FIVE PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES.
THE COACHELLA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT.
<c.red>S BY FAR THE LARGEST.</c>
OF THESE AGENCIES.
COVERING MOST OF THE VALLEY
FLOOR [inaudible]
WITHOUT.
THE SERVICE AREA OF OVER A
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES.
WE HAVE OVER JUST THE COACHELLA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT HAS OVER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND SERVICE
CONNECTIONS.
HALF OF THE HALF OF THE
COACHELLA VALLEY [inaudible]
IS RURAL.
HALF OF THE COACHELLA VALLEY'S
ARE NOT ON A CORPORATION.
FULL OF AGRICULTURAL LANDS.
THAT ARE TENDED.
MAINLY BY FOLKS THAT LIVE WITHIN
THESE THESE AGRICULTURAL FIELDS
[inaudible]
AND THIS IS REALLY THE AREA
WHERE WE HAVE THE ISSUE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO FOCUS ON
TO UNDERSTAND THE COACHELLA
VALLEY YOU GOT TO KNOW THAT A
100% OF OUR WATER SUPPLY FOR
DRINKING PURPOSES [inaudible]
IS GROUNDWATER.
OUR WATER QUALITY VARIES ACROSS
THE AQUIFER FLOOR.
AND PRIMARILY WHERE WE HAVE A
RACE USED ARE IN THE RURAL AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE NATURALLY
OCCURRING ARSENIC.
NATURALLY OCCURRING FLUORIDE
NATURALLY OCCURRING NITRATES.
AND EVEN THOUGH THE CHROMIUM SIX
ISSUE KIND OF HAS GONE AWAY FOR
AWHILE NOW.
BUT IF IT COMES BACK IT'LL BE
ONE MORE ISSUE THAT WILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH --
TO GIVE YOU SOME REFERENCE OF
HOW THAT'S GOING TO IMPACT OUR
REGION.
AND PROBABLY THROW MORE
COMPLEXITY INTO THIS DISCUSSION
OF AFFORDABILITY OF WATER.
OUR AGENCY THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT WAS THE LARGEST
AGENCY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS GOING TO BE
IMPACTED FINANCIALLY BY THIS NEW
MCL.
THE COULD HAVE ANY WATER
DISTRICT HAS ABOUT A HUNDRED
WELLS.
AND A THIRD OF THOSE LAWS ABOUT.
THIRTY THREE AT HIGHER LEVELS
THAN WHAT THE NEW MC OUT WAS
PROPOSING SO THAT WAS YOU KNOW
WE WERE PRETTY CLEAR PROJECTING
THAT WE WE HAD TO IMPLEMENT --
SOME SORT OF PROJECT THAT WAS
GONNA BE IN THE TUNE OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THAT'S JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
OF HOW.
THE AFFORDABILITY QUESTION.
WHAT WHAT WHAT CREATE ANOTHER
ISSUE FOR OUR REGION BEING THAT?
THAT THAT THAT THAT OUR REGION
IS IS IS THE LARGEST AGENCY
IMPACTED BY THIS NEWMAN SIAPA
COMES BACK.
BUT I THINK WE SAW A MAP HERE
WITH -- WITH
THE WATER SYSTEMS THAT WERE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE THOSE THOSE WERE
THE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS --
AGAIN THE COACHELLA VALLEY IS
MADE UP OF FIVE PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS BUT WE HAVE HUNDREDS.
OF STATE SMALL SYSTEMS.
THE FIVE PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
ARE IN COMPLIANCE THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
SAFE AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
OUR ISSUES WITH THE STATE.
SMALL WATER SYSTMS IF IF IF WE
IF I HAD ANOTHER BOARD HERE.
AND I COULD PUT IT.
UP THERE IN ANYWAY JUST IT WOULD
JUST FOCUS ON EASTER COACHELLA
VALLEY YOU WOULD HAVE THE EXACT
SAME NUMBER DOCTOR MORE.
SPREAD OVER THAT AREA.
OF ALL THE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY --
FACING THIS ISSUE.
SO THAT'S SOME SORT OF VISUAL
THERE -- IN
IN OUR REGION WE'VE BEEN WORKING
OVER A DECADE NOW TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE.
WE FORMED IN OUR REGION --
IS PART OF THE IRWIN PROGRAM.
A GOVERNING STRUCTURE THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD KIND OF ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES UNDER UNDER SOME SORT OF
REGIONAL ASPECT --
ME IT'S BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL
TOOL FOR US WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING SOME OF
THAT GRANT FUNDING.
ODD THROUGH THE IRWIN PROGRAM
FIRST AND PROP FIFTY DENTAL
PROPERTY FOR NOW TO PROP.
ONE UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO
MORE MONEY.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO THE IRWIN
PROGRAM.
UP THE BOND I THINK THAT PASSED
IN JUNE.
HAS NO MORE MONEY ALLOCATED TO
THAT PROGRAM AND THE BOND IT
FAILED --
LAST TIME.
EVEN IF IT PASSED OUT WITH THE
CAT ANY MONEY ALLOCATED TO THAT
PROGRAMS WHILE AND I JUST WANT
TO MENTION THAT THAT'S BEEN A
VERY SUSPECT SUCCESSFUL TO IN
OUR REGION.
BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT
[inaudible]
THAT DOT.
THAT IS WORTH THINKING ABOUT
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE SEEN
THAT I'VE EXPERIENCED.
AND AND IN OUR EFFORT TO TRY TO
GET THESE THESE FUNDING SOURCES
TO TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT PROP?
ONE OR ALL THE OTHER PROPS THAT
THAT PUTS MONEY INTO THESE
DIFFERENT BUCKETS THERE'S A
BUNCH OF COMPETING PRIORITIES.
RIGHT AND SO.
I THINK THAT EVEN WHEN YOU LOOK
AT PROP.
ONE THE MINIMUM AMOUNT.
OF OF OF OF WHAT PROP ONE SAYS
NEEDS TO GO TO DAX IS 10%.
AND SO.
THAT YOU KNOW IT.
THERE ARE ALL THESE POTS OF
MONEY BY.
HOW THAT TRANSLATES INTO THE
MONEY THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING DOWN
TO TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IS
VERY MINIMAL --
BECAUSE OF THE PRIORITY THAT I
THINK IS GIVEN TO A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS LIKE CONSERVATION.
SO I THINK THAT'S A VERY IT'S A
VERY GOOD CONCEPT THAT WAS
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH WITH
A COLLEAGUE AND WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE EFFORTS OF OF STORAGE
RIGHT I THINK THERE WAS ABOUT
SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN PROP ONE FOR STORAGE.
AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF MONEY --
PUT ASIDE FOR CONSERVATION.
AND OUR REGION I WOULD SAY THAT
THAT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
COMPETITORS IN OUR REGION BEING
THAT WE HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
GOLF COURSES WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY GOLF COURSES.
I WOULD SAY THAT A LOT OF THE
MONEY THAT CAME OUT OF THOSE
PROPOSITIONS PROP FIFTY PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT PROP FIFTY EIGHTY
FOUR AND PROP. ONE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST COMPETITORS FOR THAT IS
IS CONSERVATION THAT COMES IN
THE FORM OF OF TURF CONVERSION.
A LOT OF THAT GOES TO THE GOLF
COURSES.
SO YOU KNOW THOSE I THINK WE
GOTTA RETHINK THE ALREADY HERE
SO -- I
THINK THAT THE THAT THE OTHER
ISSUE.
IS ALSO THAT --
YOU KNOW I THINK WE HEAR THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
WELL THERE'S A READY THIS POT OF
MONEY THAT I THINK THERE WAS AN
ANALYSIS THAT SAID.
THAT THERE'S THE STATE REVOLVING
FUND LOAN THAT.
THE STATE MATCHES IT COMES FROM
THE EPA --
WE HAVE ALL THESE OTHER BONDS
THAT THAT SEEMS TO PUT MONEY
INTO VARIOUS BUCKETS TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE.
ARE BUT I THINK THAT THAT THAT
IT'S REAL.
OUR THAT IT'S NECESSARY TO
CREATE A FUN.
THAT GENERATES THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT'S NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AND I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE WHY
SAY THAT.
ARM.
IN IN OUR REGION WE FORM WHAT'S
CALLED THE THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES INFRASTRUCTURE TASK
FORCE.
AND TOP WHAT WE'VE DONE IS IS
WE'VE BROUGHT EVERYBODY TOGETHER
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS OFFICE THE
CONGRESSMAN'S OFFICE.
THE SUPERVISOR'S OFFICE VARIOUS
NONPROFITS LIKE BLUE NEEDLE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL --
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES --
THE TREND LOCAL TRIBES THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
THIS LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE EASTERN CHINA VALLEY AND
EVERYBODY'S TRYING.
TO WORK IN SILOS TO GET THEIR
PORTION OF NICK WORK TOGETHER TO
TRY TO MAXIMIZE THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE BECAUSE WE ON THE ACCESS TO
WATER WITH THE YOU NEED FOR THE
SCHOOL WHETHER YOU NEED BECAUSE
YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD.
ANOTHER ANOTHER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMPLEX OR WHATEVER THE
CASE IS.
THERE'S A LACK OF PIPE AND SO I
THINK WE WE FORMED THIS TASK
FORCE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
WE DID IN THIS TASK FORCES WHICH
WE DIDN'T A NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
AND WE WORK WITH THE COUNTY TO
HELP US MAP ALL THE STATE SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS IN EASTERN CHINA
VALLEY AND THAT'S HOW WE HAVE
THE NUMBER OF YOU KNOW OVER A
HUNDRED OF THEM THAT ARE
SCATTERED.
AND THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE.
REGULATED BY THE COUNTY THERE'S
STILL MORE THAT ARE NOT
REGULATED BY THE COUNTY.
THAT THIS PROBABLY DOUBLED IN
THAT.
SO WE'RE NOT CAPTURING ALL OF A
BUT HAVING SAID THAT UP THAT THE
NUMBER THAT WE DID CAPTURE AND
AND YOU HAVE TO HAND OUT THERE
FRONT OF YOU --
WE MAPPED OUT ABOUT MAYBE EIGHTY
TO A HUNDRED DIFFERENT SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS.
AND WE LUMP THEM INTO INTO INTO
ABOUT FORTY PROJECTS.
AND THESE FORTY PROJECTS ARE
CONSOLIDATING ANYWHERE FROM. TWO
TO NINE OUR SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
WITH ONE PIPELINE AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE DID WE SAID OKAY
WE'RE GONNA IT WE BUILD THIS
PIPELINE HOW MANY OF THE SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS CAN WE CAN WE
COMBINE CAN WE CONSOLIDATE AND
THAT'S REALLY BEEN OUR EFFORT.
AT THE COACHELLA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IS IS TO CONSOLIDATE.
ALL THE SMALL WATER SYSTEM
THAT'S BEEN THAT'S BEEN OUR
APPROACH --
I DON'T THINK WE WE WE REALLY
HAVE.
A LOT OF ISSUES MAYBE WITH YOUR
AND IF WE WERE TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THAT SITUATION SYSTEMS THAT
ARE PROBABLY JUST TOO FAR AWAY
TO THE CENTRALIZED.
WHERE WE WOULD HAVE TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF --
LONGER TO IN THIS CASE YOU KNOW
THAT UNDER THE SINK TYPE OF
TREATMENT AND THOSE TYPE OF BOB
MAYBE WHILE HIS TREATMENT SUCH.
BUT DOT --
BUT OUT OF I JUST I I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE IS OUT OF THE OUT OF
THOSE PROJECTS THAT WE TRADED
THE THIRTY NINE PROJECTS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE CALCULATING THAT
THAT THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
ABOUT YOU KNOW SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. TO EXECUTE THE
THIRTY NINE PROJECTS.
AND AND THINKING ABOUT
[inaudible]
OUR HOW AGGRESSIVE WE'VE BEEN
PURSUING GRANT FUNDING. FOR THE
PAST DECADE.
AND THE SUCCESS THAT WE'VE HAD
IN IN IN SECURING THAT
GRANDFATHER.
I WOULD SAY THAT AT THE PACE
THEY WERE GOING.
IT TAKE US YOU KNOW ANOTHER FEW
DECADES BEFORE WE WERE ABLE TO
EXECUTE ON ALL THOSE PROJECTS SO
THAT JUST SHOWS ME.
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF FUNDING.
ATTRIBUTED. TO ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE -- AND
AND I WOULD JUST AND I WOULD
CALL THAT THE FIRST SPACE
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL PROBABLY
SECOND PHASE BUT IT TAKE US
FIFTY YEARS PROBABLY JUST AS THE
FIRST SPACE.
AND I THINK ARE.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE DO
FIND SOME SORT OF REVENUE
STRUCTURE THAT THEY CREATES MORE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES --
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S QUITE
ENOUGH.
OFFER THE NEED THAT THAT THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
ARM AND SO THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
MY CAR I WANTED.
TO PAINT THAT PICTURE --
I THINK THAT.
IN IN OUR REGION I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS THE CASE IN OTHER
REGIONS ARE ISSUES WITH THE
STATE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
ARE IN OUR REGION I WOULD SAY
THAT.
ARE.
IF THE MCL FOR THE CHROMIUM SIX
IN INCOME BACK.
OUR PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
WOULDN'T HAVE ANY ISSUES.
BUT WE STILL HAVE THE ISSUE WITH
THE STATE'S SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
AGAIN OVER A HUNDRED OF THEM
SCATTERED ACROSS THE VALLEY
FLOOR --
RURAL AREAS --
FOLKS THAT LIVE WITHIN THE THE
FARM FIELDS --
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THEY WORK
IN A LOT OF TIMES THESE ARE THE
FOLKS.
WHEN YOU LOOK WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE COACHELLA VALLEY AND I
SAID YOU KNOW YOU HAVE ONE SIDE
OF THE VALLEY THAT'S RURAL AND
AGRICULTURE AND IN THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE VALLEY IS GOLF
COURSES IN?
AND LANDSCAPE AND AND AND THE
RESORT LIFE WHAT'S A LOT YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S THOSE FOLKS.
THEY GOAL WORK THERE.
AND THEN THEY GO BACK TO WHERE
THEY LIVE.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THESE TYPE
OF AMENITIES RIGHT IN SO IT'S
IT'S A BIG PROBLEM IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR FOR FOR INVITING
ME HERE FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR STORY.
AND AND I THINK THAT --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
STATEWIDE ISSUE INTO IN THE
SOLUTION NEEDS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
EVERYBODY'S INCLUDED IN THE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MAKING
THIS PROBLEM REAL TO US --
MISS PAULSON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY MY NAME IS CINDY
PAULSON I SERVICE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
WATER AGENCIES.
MY BACKGROUND IS I HAVE A PHD IN
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING HAVE
BEEN PRACTICING IN THE WATER
TECHNOLOGY IN POLICY AREAS FOR
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS --
A IS A NON ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
COMPRISED OF ELEVEN OF THE URBAN
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES RANGING FROM
THE SAN DIEGO LA.
BAY AREA AND FRESNO AREAS.
THE PURPOSE OF THAT ORGANIZATION
IS TO INFORM AND HELP SHAPE
WATER POLICY.
WE'VE BEEN IN PLACE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS --
HAS BEEN WORKING THE
ACCESSIBILITY AND AFFORDABLE
ISSUES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND VERY MUCH COMMITTED TO
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
REALLY WANT TO HELP BRING SOME
LEADERSHIP TO THE TABLE TO MAKE
AN IMPACT WE THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE URBAN AGENCIES
TO BE ENGAGED.
IN THE SOLUTION.
I'VE UP PROVIDED COPIES OF A
BRIEF IN ISSUE BRIEF THERE ARE
MORE DETAILS AVAILABLE ON THE
COOL WEBSITE AT C0 DOT ORG
IT'LL HIT SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
THEIR AS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED.
THIS IS VERY MUCH A MULTIFACETED
ISSUE -- IS
FOCUS AND OUR STRENGTH REALLY IS
TO DIG IN TO THE TECHNICAL
CHALLENGES AND POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS.
SO WE HAVE LEVERAGE THE STATE'S
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER DATABASE
AND OTHER STATE DATABASES TO
LOOK AT SYSTEMS SMALL COMMUNITY
SYSTEMS WITH WATER QUALITY
VIOLATIONS OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM SO THAT
WE CAN INFORM SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL BE LASTING AND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE.
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD ARSENIC IS A
CONTINUED PROBLEM TCP IS A NEW
ONE ON THE HORIZON CHROME SIX IS
PENDING --
ALONG WITH NITRATE AND SOME THE
OTHER CONSTITUENTS WHICH ARE
LESS PREVALENT IN THE SMALL
COMMUNITY SYSTEMS THAN SAY IN
THE DOMESTIC WELLS AREA SO IT
REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT TYPE OF A
SYSTEM YOU'RE LOOKING AT TURNS
OF THE CONSTITUENTS.
SO AGAIN WE'RE FOCUSED ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES SYSTEMS.
BY LOOKING AT THAT SUBSET OR
INTENT IS TO TRY TO ADVANCE SOME
EARLY PROGRESS AND ON THE GROUND
IMPROVEMENTS.
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO ACT AS A
CONVENER OF PARTNERS AND A
CATALYST TO GET SOMETHING
STARTED.
ULTIMATELY OUR AIM IS TO GET OUT
THE TECHNICAL ROOT CAUSES.
OF THE CHALLENGES FOR THE
PERSISTENTLY FAILING SYSTEMS
BOTH THOSE THAT ARE EXISTING AND
THOSE THAT WILL.
CONTINUE TO FACE NEW CHALLENGES
TAKE ACTIONS THAT WILL HELP TO
BREAK THAT CYCLE.
SO WE'VE LAID OUT THREE STEPS.
TO HELP RESOLVE THE PROBLEM FOR
THE FUTURE LONG TERM.
THE FIRST IS TO IDENTIFY WHICH
SYSTEMS WHERE TO BEGIN.
AND I MENTIONED THAT WE LOOKED
AT THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
DATABASE OUR ANALYSIS ACTUALLY
INDICATES OVER THAT FIVE YEARS.
THERE ARE OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE ONE OR MORE
WATER QUALITY VIOLATIONS DURING
THAT TIME FRAME SERVING A TOTAL
OF NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
AGAIN THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE FROM
SIX THE LOWER LEVELS UNTIL WE
GET TO THAT.
ABOUT 14% OF THOSE SYSTEMS OR A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE ON A WHAT WE TURNED
PERSISTENT BASIS.
THE WAY WE LOOKED AT THAT WAS
TWELVE VIOLATIONS OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD COULD DRAW THAT
THRESHOLD IN ANY PARTICULAR
LOCATION.
BUT WE FELT IT WAS HELPFUL TO
REALLY LOOK AT THE PERSISTENCE
TO HELP PRIORITIZE THE FOCUS.
OF THOSE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SMALL COMMUNITY SYSTEMS NEARLY
80% OF THAT SEVERELY IMPACTED
POPULATION IS FOUND WITHIN ONLY
THIRTY THREE SYSTEMS.
THOSE OF THE SYSTEMS THAT HAVE
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
CONNECTIONS.
OUR THOUGHT IS THAT THAT.
IS A TANGIBLE PLACE TO START TO
DO A LITTLE MORE OF THIS
TECHNICAL WORK TO TRY TO CREATE
SOME EARLY ACTIONS EARLY WINS
SHOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
LEARN AS WE GO.
TEST AND REFINE SOME WORKABLE
MODELS AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON IN
PARALLEL TO THE OTHER EFFORTS.
WE'VE DEVELOPED A STRATEGY TO
ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE FOR
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS FOR THE
FUTURE.
THAT IS THREE PRONGED TREATMENT
TECHNOLOGIES OPERATIONAL
STRATEGIES AN INSTITUTIONAL
MODELS.
WITH REGARD TO THE INSTITUTIONAL
MODELS IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO LOOK AT SUSTAINABLY SIZED
SYSTEMS THIS IS A NATIONAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS TO BE SUSTAINABLE. FOR THE
LONG TERM AND PARTICULARLY WITH
NEW CHALLENGES OF EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE THINK THERE ARE HUGE
ADVANTAGES WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AND IN FACT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO DO THIS
IN A MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVE
WAY IN A WAY THAT IS FUTURE
LOOKING.
THAT WILL ADDRESS THE
COMBINATIONS OF CONSTITUENTS AND
NOT JUST THE TRADITIONAL ONES
THAT WE SEE IN PLACE NOW.
THE ABILITY TO MONITOR WATER
QUALITY REAL TIME.
REMOTELY OPERATE THE SYSTEMS
INTRODUCES WHOLE NEW OPERATIONAL
MODELS THAT I THINK CAN HELP TO
REALLY STREAMLINED OR SPREAD THE
OWNER MONEY TO TO PROVIDE THE
GREATEST BENEFIT.
MOST COST EFFECTIVE AND MOST
RELIABLE SOURCES OF SUPPLIES.
FINALLY ENGAGED PARTNERSHIPS
THERE IS SO MUCH INTEREST FROM
MANY CORNERS.
SO MANY ARE MOTIVATED TO HELP
FIX THIS PROBLEM AND WE'VE BEEN
STARTING TO INITIATE SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THESE FOLKS
SO THE TECHNOLOGY PROVIDERS.
WHO ARE STARTING TO LOOK AT WILL
WHAT ARE THE TREATMENT TRAINS
THAT WE COULD PROVIDE WITHIN
PACKAGE SYSTEMS?
THAT COULD BE BROUGHT TO BEAR
VERY QUICKLY. TO CREATE SOME OF
THESE VERY NEAR TERM WINS AND
THAT CAN BE READY TO DEAL WITH
THE NEXT THINGS THAT COME ALONG
INCLUDING CLOCK FROM.
SIX UTILITIES YOU KNOW THEY'RE
SET UP TO RUN REGIONAL SYSTEMS
AND I THINK AGAIN.
GETTING TO SUSTAINABLY SIZE
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE THE THE
TECHNICAL WHERE WITH ALL TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE.
IN A SAFE AND RELIABLE MANNER.
SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
THEY'RE VERY INTERESTED IN
HELPING [inaudible]
UNIVERSITIES.
ARE VERY PRODUCTIVE HERE A WE'VE
BEEN PARTNERING IN PARTICULAR
WITH MISTER THOMAS GUERRA A
FRESNO STATE WHOSE --
SITTING IN THE ROOM --
AND HAS SOME GREAT IDEAS ABOUT
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE.
AND FINALLY FOUNDATIONS HAVE
TREMENDOUS INTEREST IN HELPING
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
RECOGNIZING THAT.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN THERE'S A
BROADER NEEDS NATIONALLY AND WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD AS A
STATE.
IN SERVING IN A DEVELOPING A
MODEL THAT CAN BE REPLICATED
ELSEWHERE.
THE THIRD STEP IN THE PROCESS
REALLY IS TO PREVENT NEW
UNSUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS FROM
FORMING.
STOP THE BLEEDING LEGISLATION
DEFINITELY HELPS TO ADDRESS THAT
THERE ARE SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAILS THAT WE WILL --
YOU KNOW THE DOUBLES KIND OF IN
THE DETAILS IN TERMS OF THE
ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT ON
THE GROUNDS TO BE SURE THAT
THOSE SYSTEMS WE DON'T.
HAVE NEW SYSTEMS ENTERING THAT
ARE WILL.
SO COOPER I MENTION CONTINUES
OUR WORK --
WE ARE --
WORKING A FAST TRACK PROJECT
RIGHT NOW WITH THE WATER
RESEARCH FOUNDATION THIS IS A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION.
VERY INTERESTED IN THIS TOPIC IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE PACIFIC
INSTITUTE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TO
START TO DEVELOP SOME ANSWERS BY --
MID YEAR.
THAT WORK INCLUDES SEVERAL
ASPECTS ONE OF WHICH IS
CONVENING A WORKSHOP OF
POTENTIAL PARTNERS TO BRAINSTORM
SOME OF THESE TECHNICAL
APPROACHES AND SOLUTIONS.
REALLY WHAT COULD BE WHAT COULD
WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
REALLY PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER TO
CREATE SUSTAINABLE SOLUTIONS.
SITE VISITS TO GET OUT TO SOME
OF THE AREAS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY HAVING SOME
CHALLENGES AND AND THERE'S GREAT
INTEREST IN BRINGING SOME OF
THESE SKID MOUNTED SYSTEMS TO
ACTUALLY TEST.
THE ABILITY OF THEM TO TREAT THE
SOURCES OF WATER.
AND REALLY TO LOOK UP DIG IN A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN TERMSOF THE
THE THIRTY THREE THAT ARE LARGER.
THAN TWO HUNDRED CONNECTIONS BUT
ALSO LOOKING AT SOME OF THE CASE
STUDIES OF THE SMALLER SYSTEMS
TO TRY TO DEVELOP MODELS.
THAT CAN BE LEVERAGED AND
EXTENDED TO OTHER AREAS THAT
REALLY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
IT WOULD ALSO BE SUPER HELPFUL
TO HAVE AN ASSESSMENT OF
EXISTING FUNDS AND PERHAPS SOME
MEANS. TO GET A MORE CREATIVE TO
PEEL OUT SOME OF THAT FUNDING.
TO ACTUALLY MOVE FORWARD SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WERE IDENTIFYING
THIS IS NOT TO SAY THAT THAT
FUNDING IS SUFFICIENT TO WANT TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED. FOR LONGER
TERM FUNDING SOURCES BUT WE
KRISTIN FOR INFORMED THAT
CONVERSATION OVER THE VERY NEAR
TERM AND WE THINK IT'S TIME TO
ACT.
WE ALSO SEE CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT
WITH STATE PARTNERS AND WITH
NGOS WHO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH CLOSELY OVER THE YEARS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING.
SO JUST IN CLOSING.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY WE THINK
IT'S IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
START.
OWNED BY REALLY UNDERSTANDING
THE PROBLEMS. FOR THE LONG TERM.
SO THAT WE CAN CREATE SYSTEMS
FOR THE FUTURE.
THAT ARE ADAPTABLE TO THE
EMERGING WATER QUALITY
CHALLENGES THAT CAN BE OPERATED
MUCH MORE SUSTAINABLY AND COST
EFFECTIVELY AND RELIABLY. FOR A
LASTING SOLUTION THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO BE
COMING BACK AND TALKING ABOUT IN
ANOTHER TEN YEARS FROM NOW
REALLY WANT TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
FOR THE LONG TERM.
WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD HERE IN
FORGING NEW SOLUTIONS. FOR SAFE
RELIABLE WATER FOR THE FUTURE.
WE HAVE THE NATIONAL ATTENTION
VERY MUCH ON THIS ISSUE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SET THE MODEL FOR THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY. TWO WOULD WEAR MUCH
LIKE TO JOIN FORCES WITH YOU ALL
AND PARTNERS TO HELP MAKE THAT
HAPPEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISS PAULSON FOR WHERE YOUR
TECHNICAL INSIGHT.
AND YOUR SUGGESTION --
THAT WE COULD GET 280% OF THE
PROP UP THE PEOPLE SUFFERING
THESE PROBLEMS BY LOOKING AT A
RELATIVELY SMALL NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS SO I I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT INSIGHT --
MISTER JONES.
THANK YOU CHAIRS GARCIA QUIRK IN
BLOOM COMMITTEE AND SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
TODAY TOM PAUL JONES GENERAL
MANAGER OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT AN AGENCY THAT
PROVIDES WATER.
WASTEWATER AND RECYCLE WATER
SYSTEMS TO MOURN EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN WESTERN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND ARE
SERVICER IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
INCLUDE SEVEN CITIES A RURAL
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY AN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS WITH OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND OF OUR RESIDENTS ARE
38% OF THE DISTRICT.
LIVING AND DISADVANTAGED OR
SEVERELY AS AN ORGANIZATION
EASTERN MUNICIPAL HAS
SUCCESSFULLY FOCUSED ON PROJECTS
AND PROGRAMS TO ENSURE ALL
COMMUNITIES OUR SERVICE AREA
RECEIVED SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE WATER AND SEWER
SERVICE.
AND WE HAVE DIRECT EXPERIENCE
WITH CONSOLIDATING AND REPAIRING
SYSTEMS WITH FAILING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SEVERE
CONTAMINATION ISSUES.
CALIFORNIA NATIVE ON THE WATER
PROFESSIONAL WITH NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS EXPERIENCE IN WATER AND
ENGINEERING INDUSTRIES AND LIKE
MANY OF MY WATER PROFESSIONAL
COLLEAGUES I AM ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED. TO WORKING WITH THE
STATE TO ADVANCE PRACTICAL
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE FAILING
WATER SYSTEMS WITH PERSISTENT
DRINKING WATER QUALITY
VIOLATIONS INTO PROVIDE SAFE
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE WATER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
BUT TO DO THIS I BELIEVE REALLY
NEED TO ANALYZE AND UNDERSTAND
THE ROOT CAUSE OF THIS DIFFICULT
PROBLEM.
AND THEN TAKE A DUAL APPROACH
THAT FOCUSES BOTH ON REFORMING
THE GOVERNANCE AND FLOOD SERVICE
DELIVERY MODEL OF SMALL FAILING
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS SIX
SERVING CONTAMINATED WATER.
AND ON TO DEVELOPING A RIGHT
SIZE COMPLEMENTARY FUNDING
PACKAGE WITH STABLE REVENUE
SOURCES TO ASSIST WITH
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
CONSOLIDATION COSTS AN INTERN
WATER SUPPLIES.
DISPOSITIONAL IS ALL TALK ABOUT
FURTHER WE'RE PROPOSING A
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH WAS
STATUTORILY ESTABLISHED
PROCESSES GOALS AND TIMELINES
FOR ASSESSING EACH OF THESE
FAILING SYSTEMS.
DETERMINING THE BEST PATH TO
MEET THOSE COMMUNITIES WATER
QUALITY NEEDS AND ULTIMATELY
REACHING THE END GOAL OF
ESTABLISHING VIABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS WITH
OPERATIONS AND REVENUE
CAPABILITIES.
IN DEVELOPING --
ANY EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO A
COMPLEX PROBLEM IT'S REALLY
VITALLY IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THE
ROOT CAUSE SO I'D LIKE TO START
OUT WITH AN EXPERIENCE WE'VE HAD
WITH A FEELING WATER SYSTEM.
AND DISCUSS THE COMMON ROOT
CAUSE ISSUES SHARED BY THAT
SYSTEM IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
SYSTEMS IDENTIFIED WITH
PERSISTENT DRINKING WATER
VIOLATIONS.
IN THE STATE BOARDS HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER DATABASE.
THE COUNTY WATER COMPANY OF
RIVERSIDE --
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS SERVING A
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY ADJACENT OUR
SERVICE AREA SYSTEM HAD A
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO CUSTOMERS
A SINGLE WELL SERVING NITRATE
CONTAMINATED WATER.
INFRASTRUCTURE SO DEGRADED THAT
THERE WAS NO FIRE PROTECTION FOR
THE COMMUNITY AND THE WATER IS
ONLY AVAILABLE DURING CERTAIN
TIMES OF DAY OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM OWNERS IN CUSTOMERS
LACK THE FINANCIAL RATE BASE AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE AND THE COMPANY WENT
INTO FINANCIAL RECEIVERSHIP.
ULTIMATELY THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT ASK YOU
SIR MUNICIPAL IN OUR NEIGHBORING
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM TO PURSUE A
SOLUTION INVOLVING ACQUIRING
GRANT FUNDING PROVIDING
TEMPORARY ABOVE GROUND PIPELINE
TO REPLACE THE CONTAMINATED WELL
SUPPLY.
REBUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
CONNECTING TO OUR SYSTEMS AND
THEN FINALLY DISSOLVING IN
CONSOLIDATING INTO OUR DISTRICTS.
DISHES WE EXPERIENCE WITH COUNTY
WATER COMPANY ARE UNFORTUNATELY
REPEATED OVER AND OVER IN OTHER
NON COMPLIANT SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT LITTLE MORE
DETAIL COUPLE THOSE ISSUE AREAS
FOR YOU.
FIRST OF THE CURRENT TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOUR SYSTEMS
IDENTIFIED AS NON COMPLIANT IN
THE STATE'S DATABASE. 81% OF
THOSE SYSTEMS SERVE LESS THAN
FOUR HUNDRED SERVICE CONNECTIONS
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA BASE AND STANISLAUS COUNTY
FIFTEEN OF THE SEVENTEEN SYSTEMS
OUT OF COMPLIANCE SERVE LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED SERVICE
CONNECTIONS.
IN MONTEREY COUNTY ALL TWENTY
TWO OF THE NON COMPLIANT SYSTEMS
HAVE LESS THAN A HUNDRED AND SIR
SERVICE CONNECTIONS WITH SO MUCH
WITH SUCH SMALL RATE BASES.
MANY OF THE SYSTEM STRUGGLE TO
SUPPORT NORMAL OPERATIONS TO
COVER BASS AND A COVER BASIC
OVERHEAD EXPENSES SUCH AS
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNTING LEGAL
FINANCIAL REPORTING WATER
QUALITY TESTING INSURANCE.
OFFICE SPACE ALL THE SIMILAR
EXPENSES THAT ARE COMMON TO ALL
OUR UTILITIES REGARDLESS OF THE
SIZE IN ONE WATER QUALITY ISSUES
OCCUR A WELL FAILS
INFRASTRUCTURE FAILS.
TRYING TO SPREAD THOSE
EXTRAORDINARY COSTS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SERVICE CONNECTIONS ARE
LESS JUST BECOMES UNTENABLE.
BUT THIS WAS CERTAINLY THE CASE
WITH THE LINEAR CAM.
WE'RE SPREADING THE EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED DOLLAR A MONTH
ADDITIONAL COST OPERATE IN
ARSENIC REMOVAL SYSTEM OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE SERVICE
CONNECTIONS BECAUSE FINANCIAL
INSOLVENCY OR THE MONTEREY PARK
TRACK COMMUNITY SAID.
SERVICE DISTRICT WERE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR AND REPLACEMENT
WATER COSTS PURCHASE FROM THE
CITY A SERIES ARE BEING SPREAD
OVER FIFTY ONE SERVICE
CONNECTIONS WITH HUGE IMPACTS ON
RATES.
IN SHORT FOR THESE VERY SMALL
SYSTEMS IN MANY OTHER FEELING
WATER SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE UTILITY BUSINESS
ECONOMICS JUST REALLY DON'T WORK.
SECOND IN EVALUATING THE
FINANCIAL RECORDS FROM FORTY
SYSTEMS RANGING IN SIZE FROM
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE TO OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND WE ALSO FOUND
THAT MANY OF THE SMALLER SYSTEMS
HAVE SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF
THEIR RATES.
THEY'RE BEING PAID BY THEIR
CUSTOMERS GOING TO
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD THOSE
CATEGORIES THAT I PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED. FOR THE LARGE SYSTEMS
WE SHOULD WE USUALLY SEE COST
ABOUT 30% OR LESS OF OUR
OPERATING BUDGET GOING TO
OVERHEAD FOR THOSE SMALLER
SYSTEMS WE OBSERVE OVERHEAD
COSTS IN SOME CASES HIGH 60% OF
BUDGET.
ARE THAT SIXTY CENTS OUT OF
EVERY CUSTOMER DOLLAR GOING TO
BASIC OVERHEAD RATHER THAN CORE
OPERATIONS AND WATER QUALITY
NEEDS.
THAT THIS IS REALLY ONE OF THE
REASONS SOME OF THESE VERY SMALL
SYSTEMS CAN EXPERIENCE HIGH
RATES.
NOW I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THERE ARE SMALL MANY SMALL
SYSTEMS THAT ARE WELL RUN IN
VIABLE BUT OUR CONCLUSION OF
THIS IS TO BE MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
MODERNIZING THE SERVICE DELIVERY
MODEL IN BY ELIMINATING
NONVIABLE SYSTEMS WITH
GOVERNANCE REFORMS INCLUDING
CONSOLIDATION AND
REGIONALIZATION IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL.
THE NINETEENTH CENTURY MODEL OF
HAVING HUNDREDS OF INDEPENDENT
AND NOW STRUGGLING WATER SYSTEMS
REALLY NEEDS TO BE CHALLENGED.
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN THE CALFORNIA MENISCAL
UTILITIES AGENTS ASSOCIATION ARE
PARTNERING TO INTRODUCE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD DO THIS
THAT.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE THE
STATE BOARD ADDITIONAL STATUTORY
TOOLS TO ADDRESS GOVERNANCE
ISSUES AND REQUIRED A VALUATION
AND DISPOSITION PROCESS.
TO FIRST BRING NONCOMPLIANT
SYSTEMS THAT CAN BE
OPERATIONALLY IN FINANCIALLY
VIABLE INTO COMPLIANCE THROUGH
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE WAR
CONSOLIDATE THE NONVIABLE
SYSTEMS WITH LARGER PUBLIC OR PC
REGULATED HOST AGENCIES USING
THE STATE BOARDS EXISTING
STATUTORY AUTHORITIES.
OR COMPLETELY DISSOLVE THE SINCE
AND CREATE NEW REGIONAL ENTITIES
WHAT WOULD BE CALLED STATE SMALL
SYSTEM WATER AUTHORITIES AT A
COUNTY OR A SUB COUNTY LEVEL AND
PROVIDE ENHANCED TECHNICAL
FINANCIAL MANAGERIAL
COMPETENCIES.
AND THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL THE STATE BOARD
WERE IN POWER BE IMPAIRED TO
UNDERTAKE A SERIES OF SEQUENTIAL
ACTIONS A POINT SYSTEM
ADMINISTRATORS AND COORDINATE
WITH COUNTY LAUGHED GOES TO
DEVELOP PLANS FOR SERVICE. TO
FIGHT IT NEED NEEDED CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS AND SUPPORT THE
FORMATION OF THE LARGER MORE
CONFIDENT SYSTEMS --
THIS WOULD ELIMINATE REDUNDANT
OVERHEAD WHILE ALLOWING MORE
EXISTING RATE PAYER REVENUE TO
BE DEDICATED TO COURSE SYSTEM
OPERATIONS.
CHECKS AND BALANCES ARE ALSO
BUILD TO THE PROPOSAL TO ENSURE
THE NEW SYSTEMS ARE ACHIEVING
THEIR WATER QUALITY
INFRASTRUCTURE MILESTONES.
AND REPORTS BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD ALSO BE
REQUIRED.
THE SECOND PART OF THE DEAL
APPROACH IS A PROPOSED FUNDING
MEASURE THAT WOULD INCLUDE A
STABLE AND RELIABLE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE STATE BOARDS
HOUSTON ADDRESSING COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS.
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO STATE
DRINKING WATER IS STILL SEE
ASIAN OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ARE SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION
THEIR REPRESENTATIVES ARE HERE
TODAY AND I KNOW THEY'RE GOING
TO WANT TO SPEAK TO YOU IN
PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN MORE DETAIL ABOUT THIS --
BUT THIS FUNDING LEGISLATION
WOULD ESTABLISH AND STATE LAW A
DRINKING WATER TRUST THE TRUST
WOULD BE FUNDED WITH AN INITIAL
INFUSION FROM THE STATE --
GENERAL FUND DURING A BUDGET
SURPLUS YEARS SUCH AS THIS AND
WOULD ESTABLISH A BENEFIT
CHARITABLE TRUSTS IT'S OVERSEEN
BY A SAFE DRINKING WATER TRUST
COMMISSION.
THE TRUST PRINCIPLE WOULD BE
INVESTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
UNIFOR FOR A PRUDENT INVESTOR
ACT IN NET REVENUES FROM THOSE
INTEREST EARNINGS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT
FOR TRANSFER TO THE STATE
DRINKING WATER FUN AT THE STATE.
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THE TRUST EARNINGS ALONG WITH
OTHER DESIGNATED RATHER REVENUE
SOURCES WOULD YOU SIZE STATE
BOARD OF FROM THE OPERATION
MAINTENANCE COSTS CONSOLIDATION
COSTS IN REPLACEMENT OF WATER
COST.
OF FOR THESE SYSTEMS AND ADDRESS
THIS CONTAMINATION AND SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
WITH A FOURTEEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FISCAL YEAR WE BELIEVE THERE'S
REALLY AN EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY
THIS YEAR TO ESTABLISH AND FUND
THE TRUST.
AND BY DOING SO GENERATE THOSE
INTEREST EARNINGS THAT WOULD
CREATE A PREDICTABLE AND
RELIABLE REVENUE SOURCE THE
COULD BE DEDICATED TO THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH PRIORITY.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE BENEFIT
OF A TRUST FUND BY GENERAL FUND
VERSUS A PER METER WATER CHARGE
IS THAT IT USES A PROGRESSIVE
REVENUE SOURCE WERE HIGH INCOME.
EARNERS HAVE CONTRIBUTED MUCH
MORE AND LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS
ARE CONTRIBUTING MUST LESS THIS
AVOIDS A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON WHAT WE CALL OUR INCOME
CHALLENGE RESIDENTS AND THOSE
ARE THE ONES WHO WERE JUST ABOVE
THAT 2100%.
THRESHOLD OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL UNDER A WATER FEE PROPOSAL
THOSE RESIDENTS SHOULD NOT ONLY
BE PAYING THE SAME AMOUNT IS
SOME OF OUR MOST AFFLUENT
CUSTOMERS AND RESIDENTS WOULD
ALSO BE ABSORBING SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
THAT ALL THE WATER AGENCIES ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO OCCUR --
INKER TO IMPLEMENT COLLECTION OF
THE PROPOSED FEE.
IN SUMMARY WE BELIEVE THAT
THOROUGH IMPLEMENTATION AND OF A
TWO PART PACKAGE DESIGNED TO
SYSTEMATICALLY ADDRESS
UNDERLYING GOVERNANCE ISSUES OF
THE FAILING WATER SYSTEM.
COUPLED WITH A STABLE AND
RELIABLE FUNDING SOURCE IS
CRITICAL TO RESOLVING THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND FOR
YOUR OPENNESS IN CONSIDERATION
OF ALL IDEAS. TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
AND RELIABLE DRINKING WATER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THANK YOU MISTER JONES JUST ADD
A LITTLE DETAIL TO HIS PROPOSAL --
WHAT I SAW FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES DISTRICT WAS --
AMOUNT OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THE
INTEREST OF WHICH WOULD BE
SOMETHING LIKE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR I WOULD GAS.
DEPENDING UPON.
WHAT'S YOUR BONDS --
YOU MIGHT INVEST IN IS THAT
CORRECT IS THAT YOUR PROPOSAL
THAT'S A OF CONCEPTUAL AMOUNT
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT IN THE
PROPOSAL BUT AGAIN IT'S REALLY.
DEPENDENT ON HOW MUCH REVENUE IS
THE GOAL TO BE GENERATED SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF --
YOU PUT TWICE THAT AMOUNT IN
DOLLARS AND YOU LOOKED AT THOSE
INTEREST EARNING SAY BE AROUND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AGAIN BEAR IN MIND THE WAY IT
TRUST WOULD WORK IN THAT REGARD
IT WOULD BE AN INFUSION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND INTO THE TRUST.
THE TRUST WOULD BE --
IN THOSE ROOMS REVENUES WOULD BE
INVESTED THEY DEVELOP INTEREST
EARNINGS IN YOU'D HAVE A REVENUE
TARGET.
IN GOOD FISCAL TIMES YOU'D BE
JET GENERATING INTEREST EARNINGS
IN EXCESS OF THAT REVENUE
TARGETS --
IN THAT MONEY WOULD REMAIN
PORTION OF THE MANY WOULD REMAIN
IN THE TRUST.
DURING DIFFICULT TIMES IN LOWER --
IN FINANCIAL DOWNTURNS YOU MAY
NOT BE GENERATING INTEREST
EARNINGS BUT YOU WOULD HAVE
PREVIOUSLY GENERATING THOSE
INTEREST EARNINGS AND THEREBY
CREATING A STABLE REVENUE SOURCE
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S THE
PROPOSAL.
OKAY I I THINK YOU'D HAVE TO PUT
A LOT MORE AND AND A HUNDRED AND
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN ORDER
TO GET.
SOMETHING LIKE THE HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED RIGHT NOW BUT WE WILL
LEAVE IT AT THAT --
SO I'M NOW LOOKING FOR QUESTIONS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
YES MISS GARCIA [inaudible]
A THANK YOU.
I WAS LIKE THE NUNS THE SINUS
PASSION EARLIER --
AND I THINK THAT IT'S NOT
PASSION IT'S TIME TO GO HOME ON
A REGULAR BASIS TELLING PEOPLE
ANY TO WAIT A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
AND THAT'S REALLY HARD TO DO AND
TELLING THESE COMMUNITIES I
THINK WE AS A LEGISLATURE ANY
DETAILS COMMITTEES THAT THE THE
SURF CLEAN WATER NOW.
THESE OTHER ANY LONGER BUT I
HOPE AS WE'RE DOING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE TWO FOLD AND
MISTER JONES IS TALKING ABOUT A
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE TAKING
ACTION IMMEDIATELY SO THESE
FOLKS HAVE THE WATER THE THE SO
THE SERVER. FOR US LOOKING AT
GOVERNANCE ISSUE SO WE DON'T END
UP IN THIS PROBLEM WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT EMERGING IN TEN
MINUTES WHAT IS KARIM SIX THAT
WE KNOW IS COMING.
WE HAVE THAT P. F. AWAIS THE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IS
GOING TO BE ENOUGH OR DO WE NEED
TO ALLOW ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY IN
THERE FOR THINGS THAT WERE NOT
THINKING ABOUT BUT WILL BE
EMERGING.
DOWN THE ROAD BUT I DO HOPE THAT
THAT WE COULD TAKE ACTION --
I LIVE IN A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY.
THAT HAS A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WHEN WE HAVE ALLOCATED FUNDS IN
WE HAVE MISSED OUT ON THE STANDS
FOR LOTS OF DIFFERENT RECENT
SUCCESSES SET UP THOSE PLANS.
HOPE WE'RE TALKING TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
BOND DOLLARS FOR WHATEVER REASON
EVEN THOUGH WE THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING TO BE ABLE.
TO START WITH UNDER THE SAME
MISTAKES AGAIN.
ANA INSIST MORE OF A COMMENT
THAN A QUESTION THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT --
LOT OF QUESTIONS TO HAVE ONE NOW.
BUT YOU KNOW I I LIKE THE TRUST
IDEA THINK IT'S DEFINITELY
VIABLE AND YOU KNOW A THING.
THE CONCERNS ARE ALWAYS THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY HOW HOW WE PUT
INTO IT BUT TRUSTS WORK THEY'RE
KNOWN TO WORK AND QUITE FRANKLY
I THINK ANYTHING'S BETTER THAN A
TAX.
ALL RIGHT AND I'LL JUST SAY MY
MY OF MY WRITTEN TAKEN MY HEAD
SCISSORS THREE BILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE TRUST BUT WE'LL SEE --
ANYONE ELSE WITH THE QUESTION.
WELL I WANT TO THANK I'M VERY
GLAD MISTER JONES YOU BROUGHT UP
THAT PROPOSAL WHICH I I'VE HEARD
BEFORE BUT MANY IN THE AUDIENCE
OF NOT --
AND I WANT TO THANK THE MISS
PAULSON FOR HER TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE AND I HOPE YOU WILL
GET TO US --
AS MUCH OF A THAT REPORT TO OUR
COMMITTEES --
FOR WERE WRAPPED WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE --
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND FOR
BUDGET SUB --
THREE AS MUCH OF THOSE REPORTS
AS YOU CAN SO OUR STAFF CAN LOOK
AT THEM.
AND AGAIN MISTER STRADA --
GIVING US IN ON THE GROUND LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENS IN THESE
COMMITTEE COMMUNITIES AND WHY
THEY'RE SO DIFFICULT TO SOLVE --
I SEE A LARGE LINE.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS AS CLOSE TO A MINUTE AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE MORE THAN THIRTY
PEOPLE UP HERE AND IT WOULD BE
GREAT. TO HAVE SOME MEMBERS
STILL HERE WHILE YOU'RE TALKING
BESIDES ME --
SO PLEASE TRY TO KEEP TO ONE
MINUTE --
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND TRY TO KEEP YOUR
AND WE HAVE TRANSLATORS FOR
THOSE SPEAKING SPANISH.
I DID PLEASE TURN ON THE
MICROPHONE [inaudible]
GOING.
THANK YOU THERE OKAY.
CINDY TECH WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIAWATER AGENCIES WE
APPRECIATE THE HEARING THERE
WERE SO MANY COMMENTS ON THAT
SENATOR MOANING CAVE THAT WE
AGREE WITH THERE'S A LOT OF
AGREEMENT WE WANT TO GET THERE
THIS YEAR.
AS EVERYBODY HAS SAID THE ISSUE
IS THE FUNDING SOURCE.
SO AQUA INSEAM YOU A ARE
SPONSORING THE LEGISLATION THAT
MISTER JONES REFERRED TO IT
WOULD CREATE THE C. TRICKING
WATER TRUST IN IT WOULD CREATE
IS THE TREE KING WATER FUN.
THAT THE REVENUE FROM THE TRUST
WOULD GO INTO AND THE STATE
WATER BOARD WOULD IMPLEMENT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING WITH
ALL OF YOU ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
AND WORKING IN GIVING TO A
SOLUTION THIS YEAR.
ON THE WE THINK THE TRUST IS A
MUCH BETTER APPROACH THAN A
STATEWIDE WATER TAX I WON'T GO
INTO ALL THOSE REASONS TODAY.
BUT WE URGE EVERYONE THAT'S HERE
TO FOCUS ON THE AFFORDABILITY
ISSUE THAT'S ONE OF THE
DOWNSIDES O A WATER TAX IT'S
NOT JUST THE COST OF THE TAX THE
ON THE ON LOCAL WATER BILL IT'S
THE COST OF IN OVER.
THREE THOUSAND LOCAL WATER
SYSTEMS TAKE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
STEPS TO IMPLEMENT WHEN YOU DO
THE MATH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS.
COKE THEY SKYROCKET IT'S HIGHLY
INEFFICIENT WE THINK THE TRUST
IS A MUCH BETTER WAY TO DO IT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I GAVE --
BLOCK FOR A LITTLE EXTRA TIME
BECAUSE THEY ARE PRETENDING
SOMETHING THAT I SUSPECT A LOT
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SAY YOU LIKE
VERY MUCH AND IF YOU CAN JUST
SAY I REALLY LIKE THE PLAN.
TRUST THAT WOULD BE GREAT --
PLEASE --
NEXT SPEAKER OKAY DANIELLE
BLASTED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
ALL TAKE LESS THAN A MINUTE I
PROMISE AND WE ARE DEFINITELY
COMMITTED TO A SOLUTION AS WELL
WE BELIEVE IT CAN BE DONE
WITHOUT A STATEWIDE WATER TAX.
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THE
GOVERNANCE SOLUTION WITH EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT AND THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER TRUST WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE DIALOGUE
TODAY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON GILBERT
FOR ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT --
FOR MANY OTHER REASONS MENTIONED
WE DO WE OPPOSE THE TAX WE
SUPPORT THE TRUST --
COUPLE REAL QUICK POINTS THE ONE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION.
MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T THINK IS A
REMOTELY RELIABLE NUMBERED THERE
THERE IS NO THE WORK HAS NOT
BEEN DONE AT ALL TO ARRIVE AT A
RELIABLE NUMBER I THINK IT'S
BEING DONE NOW I DON'T KNOW WHEN
THAT WILL.
WILL WILL REACH THAT CONCLUSION
AND LASTLY --
THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
THE THE PURPOSE THE OTHER
PROPOSAL THE TAX PROPOSAL BUT
THERE WASN'T TOO MUCH DISCUSSION.
ABOUT THE IMMUNITY IN THAT
PROPOSAL FOR THE POLLUTERS WHO
HELPED CREATE THIS PRO THIS
PROBLEM.
AND I THINK AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT'S IMMUNITY FOR THAT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT BE EQUALLY
AND FULLY VETTED AS WHETHER OR
NOT THAT'S A POLICY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE WANTS
TO PURSUE THANK YOU.
I'LL JUST MENTION THAT --
MISTER MONEY DO YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO THAT IN TERMS OF THE
CONTRIBUTION FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL INTERESTS YET JUST
REAL BRIEFLY BUT IT.
HAS BEEN A SUBJECT I THINK OF
SOME MISINFORMATION THERE IS NO --
UNITY FOR AGRICULTURE --
TO PRODUCE SIX SETON SAYS THE
REQUIREMENT IS THEY MUST COMPLY
WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
DISTRICTS --
BEST PRACTICES IN MOVING TOWARDS
REDUCING.
THE NITRATE RELIANCE IT IN ANY.
THEY ARE NOT IMMUNE FROM
PROSECUTION IF THEY'RE NOT
FOLLOWING THOSE BEST PRACTICES --
AND THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
MUNITY FROM CIVIL LIABILITY FOR
ANY INJURY OR DEATH CAUSED BY
CONTAMINANTS --
FROM FROM UNKNOWN APPROVAL
SOURCE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY -- WE
HAVE -- A
GUEST AT THE TABLE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WOULD YOU GO AHEAD YES
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH --
MEMBERS MORNING DAVID WILL FOR
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION YOU JUST WANT TO
MAKE A COUPLE POINTS HERE.
FIRST OF ALL WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED THIS MORNING IS NOT AT
THE MINISTRY WE DO BELIEVE THIS
IS A TAX WHICH SHOULD REQUIRE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
ESTABLISHING A TAX MEMBERS
BEYOND BEING AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT IS COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY WE'VE A SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS A NEW RECORD AMOUNT IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
WHAT'S BEEN PROPOSED IS USING A
SMALL PORTION OF THE SURPLUS TO
FIND A TRUST.
THIS HAS THE BENEFIT OF SOLVING
THE IMMEDIATE ONE TIME PROBLEM
ALSO ALLOWING FUNDS FOR FUTURE
YEARS TO SOLVE WHAT IS CARL A
CLEAN WATER PROBLEM IN THE STATE
WE THINK THIS.
IS IN FACT A PERMANENT SOLUTION --
THERE IS PREDICTABLE TO SENATOR
MUNNINGS PLANE IT ABSOLUTELY IS
PREDICTABLE OVER TIME ONE TIME
FUNDING.
SELL WITH THAT ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE TRUST.
THANK YOU FOR BEING BRIEF.
OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING --
MY NAME IS JUDY CORAL RONO I'M
ELECTED DIRECTOR BIGHORN DOES A
FEW WATER AGENCY WHICH IS.
A SERVICE FOUR THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN THE HIGH DESERT.
COMMUNITIES OF LANDERS JOHNSON
VALLEY FLAMINGO HEIGHTS NEAR
JOSHUA TREE.
WE REPRESENT A COMMUNITY THAT IS
A 100% DISADVANTAGED.
AND SEVENTY FIVE CID PERCENT
SENIORS ON JUST.
ON FIXED INCOME OF WHICH I'M FIT
IN BOTH CATEGORIES. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CONCERNS OUR AGENCY.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY TO B. OUT LOBBYING IS.
DID YOU MAKE ROOM FOR US.
AT YOUR DISCUSSION TABLE WE FIND
OUT THESE THINGS LIKE --
WELL THIS IS HERE.
PLEASE UNDERSTAND WE'RE IN THE
BUSINESS OF SERVING WATER.
WHICH IS ONE OF LIFE'S
NECESSITIES.
WEIRD WEAKENED LOBBYING AND I
SPEAK FOR MY WHOLE COMMUNITY WHO
QUESTIONED YOUR LOGIC.
AND EFFECT ON OUR LIVES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
SARS DIVERSE FOR THE MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
IN THE LOS VIRGINIS WATER
DISTRICT.
WHO DID A DE LOS PURCHASE IN A
DEEP DIVE ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS DURING THE INTERIM WHAT
THEY FOUND THOUGH THEY ARE A
MODERN SYSTEM?
THEY FOUND --
IMPLEMENTATION COST OF HAVE BEEN
ADDED P. Y. APPROACHING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
THEIR PROJECTED REVENUES FROM
THE TAX COLLECTED AS IT WAS
PROPOSED AT THE END WOULD BE
AROUND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO WE'RE LOOKING IN
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF AROUND
39% FOR DATABASE CREATION
DATABASE SECURITY ACCOUNTING.
AUDITING AND THEN TRANS MIDDLE
OF THESE TAXES DRIVE THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THROUGH THE
ROOF SO THOROUGHLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE INS BUT WE'RE GONNA WANT TO
COMMUNICATE WITH YOU ABOUT THE
BEANS.
OF DOING THIS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IS ALL THE ON AND BEHALF --
MAKES A WATER WE FILLETED ARE
COMMENTS WITH WITH OCWEN ON THE
TRUSTED SAKE HAVING THE TRUST AS
A GOOD CONCEPT.
AND THEN HOW WE FEEL THAT WITH
WOULD WHATEVER FEES OR OR
FUNDING SOURCES OF IS SOMETHING
THAT THAT WE CAN.
GET WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING I COULD CONTINUE TO
CONVERSE ABOUT.
THEIR THE LAST PANEL --
THE LAST SPEAKER ALSO TALKED AND
WAS VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT
CONSOLIDATION.
WE HAVE SEVERAL FOLKS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN BECAUSE ALL OR MY
AGRICULTURAL CLIENTS --
WITH THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE WE
THINK THAT THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE CONVERSATION ON THAT AND
LOOK AT SOME OTHER ALL TERMS
THAT WERE PRESENTED LAST YEAR.
OTHERS CABALLERO BILL IN THOSE
KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS THE NEED
TO CONTINUE AS WELL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND ARE ALMOST
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
MY NAME IS JOYCE STERLING I WEAR
MANY HATS.
I AM C. E. O. OF MY FAMILY'S
WINERY IN CINEMA COUNTY.
I SERVE ON THE STATE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL BOARD.
AND I AM HERE TODAY AS CHAIR OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RURAL
CAUCUS.
I AM VERY.
EXCUSE ME PLEASED AND PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE LANGUAGE THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PUT FORWARD IN HIS --
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND I WANT TO PLEDGE THE SUPPORT
OF THE WORLD CAUCUS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE FIND RELIABLE ON GOING.
FUNDING TO CLEAN THIS WATER
PROBLEM UP.
SO THAT WE GET A SOLUTION
ACHIEVED THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
STATEMENT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS --
CHAIRS SENATOR MINDING MY NAME
IS MARYANN WARMER DAMN I
REPRESENT THE REAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE A MEMBER DRIVEN
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING THIRTY
SIX OF THE STATE'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
AND HAVE THE OF LUSTER TION OF
BEING HOME TO MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES.
WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
TRYING TO FIND SOLUTIONS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP
OF SENATOR MINING HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN THAT CONVERSATION
OVER THE LAST YEAR.
WE'RE ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE WATER AGENCIES
FOR COMING FORWARD WITH A
DIFFERENT APPROACH THAT I THINK
IS WORTH AT LEAST CONSIDERING
AND TRYING TO SORT THROUGH.
WHICH THE REDS OF THE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE IN FRONT
OF US MIGHT BE THE MOST VIABLE
FOR THIS LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER --
WITH THAT WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN PUTTING FORWARD --
BUDGET TRAILER BILL WHICH
CAPTURES MANY OF THE CONCEPTS
THAT WE HAVE BECOME COMFORTABLE
WITH OVER THE LAST YEAR THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING BRIEF.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE JOINT
COMMITTEES.
MY NAME IS PAUL SETHI I'M A MESS
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT.
SERVING APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS.
IN SOUTHERN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
I AM HERE TO EXPRESS MY AGENCIES
SUPPORT OF FOR THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER TRUST IDEA APPROACH.
AND OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED STATEWIDE WATER TAX.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MY
CONSTITUENTS.
MORNING MY NAME'S ERIC MUSSELMAN
AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OUT
FRIENDS OF THE RIVER OR STATE
WIDE RIVER PROTECTION GROUP AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT FOR
OVER FORTY FIVE YEARS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE WE ARE FRIENDS THE
RIVER UNDERSTAND THAT INSURING
COMMUNITY HEALTH IS
FUNDAMENTALLY LINKED. TO
PROTECTING REVERSE AND ENTERING
THE HEALTH RIVERS THEY'RE
INEXTRICABLY LINKED AND I'M
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER BUT
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THAT. TO
SUPPORT ACTION AND THE FUNDING
THE DEDICATED ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCES THAT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS.
YEAH THIS YEAR AT AND BEFORE
THAT IMMEDIATELY.
THIS IS YOU CAN'T CAN'T WAIT ANY
LONGER ZANA CAN'T GO BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITY ANOTHER DAY AND SAY WE
HAVE TO WAIT LONGER.
AND A FEE SO A REPAIR FEE SINCE
ME AN APPROPRIATE --
METHODOLOGY FOR SOME OF THE
FUNDING --
SOURCE --
FOR OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE --
THIS IS ONE CALIFORNIA THERE'S
OVER A MILLION PEOPLE --
THAT ARE DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE
I DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
AND IT'S UP TO US A CALIFORNIANS
TO STAND UP TO AND RESOLVE IT.
IN A TRUST FUND APPROACH JUST
DOESN'T SEEM IT SEEMS OUT OF
BALANCE WITH INSURING A BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT LIKE DRINKING WATER --
SO SEEM TO FALL SHORT AS ALSO --
SUSCEPTIBLE AND OPEN TO TWO OF
THE THE RISKS IN THE MARKET.
SO -- THIS
IS ALSO PART OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT A NUMBER OF
OF ORGANIZATIONS LIKE ONLINE.
JUST.
CAN FINISH UP YOUR COMMISSURE WE
WE SUBMIT RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
GOVERNOR ON A WATER AGENDA AND
THIS IS ONE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT FRIENDS THE
RIVER MORE THAN FIFTY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FROM AROUND THE
STATE SUPPORTED SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION I URGE YOU
ACTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRS MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GREG
MORRISON I'M HERE REPRESENTING
ELSE OR VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT.
WE SERVE APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN
WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
IN APPROXIMATELY 35% OF THOSE
RESIDENTS ARE IN DISADVANTAGED
AND SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO YOU CAN IMAGINE
WHAT IT WOULD BE LIKE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO ABSORB.
OPPOSE WATER TAX WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT.
OF AUCKLAND CMU REYES PROPOSAL
AND I ECHO THE COMMENTS
SPECIFICALLY ON THE GOVERNMENT'S
PEACE OF THE THE ITEM OR THE
ISSUE THAT MISTER JONES
MENTIONED DURING HIS TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE A
CHAIRMAN QUIRK I CHECK WELCOME
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF FRESNO
LONG BEACH WATER DEPARTMENT AND
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
FELICE ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY AQUA IN
SIMI WAY AND LOOK FOR TO BEING
PART OF THE CONVERSATION AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THIS AND AGREE THAT
ACTION THIS YEAR'S APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RECALLS
ON THE GENERAL MANAGER OF TWENTY
NINE PALMS WATER DISTRICT WHERE
SPECIAL DISTRICT IN THE MOJAVE
DESERT AND SAM AND YOU DON'T
COUNTY --
OUR DISTRICT SERVES A POPULATION
OF 180001100% IS DISADVANTAGED
75% OF THAT IS TO REALLY
DISADVANTAGED ARE NOT
WITHSTANDING ALL THOSE FACTS
TWENTY NINE PALMS IS KNOWN FOR
INNOVATION AND FLUORIDE
TREATMENT ARSENIC TREATMENT.
AND I CAN ATTEST TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF MATHIS IS COMMENTS AT
ONE AM IS VERY EXPENSIVE FOR
THIS TREATMENT PLANTS.
DESPITE ALL THESE FACTS TWENTY
NINE PALMS WE HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING GRANTS WE'VE BEEN DONE
AYE GRANTS MANY TIMES.
THE LAST GRANT APPLICATION OVER
THREE YEARS WE WAITED FOR AN
ANSWER THREE YEARS --
WE CAN'T WAIT THREE YEARS.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS A SEAT
AT THE TABLE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
TO REPRESENT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE OURS?
THAT CAN SHARE OUR EXPERIENCES
WERE NOT IN FAVOR OF THE TAX --
TAKES AWAY OUR REVENUES AND ON A
LOCAL THE TRUST SO --
WE DO ASK FOR SEAT AT THE TABLE
AS ON GO IN.
DISCUSSIONS ARE HAD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SHORT.
MY NAME IS CAROL JEANNIE I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR TWENTY NINE PALMS
WATER DISTRICT I'M ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
TODAY -- OUR
GENERAL MANAGER JUST PRETTY MUCH
COVERED EVERYTHING THAT I WAS
GOING TO SAY SO I'M NOT GOING TO
TAKE UP THE TIME FOR REALLY
ASKING FOR IS A SEAT AT THE
TABLE -- TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE WATER WORLD.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING I'M DONE PARKS WITH
FEELING PAIN IN HILLS COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICT.
OF THE POPULATION OF 2400030% OF
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED IN 51% ARE SENIORS
ON A FIXED INCOME --
WE DON'T DISPUTE THE GRAVITY OF
THE PROBLEMS IN THE NEED FOR THE
TARGET TO SOLUTIONS.
COVER WE SERVE LOW AND FIXED
INCOME POPULATIONS HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES.
THE CONSERVATION MANDATES FOR
CHROMIUM SIX M. C. L. HAVE
ALREADY INCREASED RATES UP 220%
FOR SOME CUSTOMERS THAT DID GO
AWAY BUT WE'VE ALREADY MADE HUGE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT A SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT FOR DISTRICT WITH AN
ANNUAL BUDGET OF SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS THESE THESE ARE --
TAKING US TO THE TIPPING POINT
OF A I JUST WANT TO REFER BACK
TO THE STATE WATER BOARD ROAD ON
THE REPORT ABOUT IMPLEMENTING
FOR A ONE FIND THE SEARS I GET A
CORRECT --
THE WATER METER TAX WOULD BE
REGRESSIVE --
IF THAT IS THE CASE AND CREATING
A LOW INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IT WOULD BE REGRESSIVE
TO DO SO ON THE QUESTION OF
CHRONICALLY FEELING WATER
SYSTEMS WE DO BELIEVE THERE
NEEDS TO BE A SOLUTION.
BUT WE CANNOT ADD ADDITIONAL
FEES TO OUR CUSTOMERS THAT ARE
ALREADY PAYING FOR ADDITIONAL.
TAXES IN THE WATER SYSTEM THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRS MEMBERS I'M AARON
EVANS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES --
SO THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES BELIEVES IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF QUALITY DRINKING
WATER AND IN FACT IN THE PAST
WE'VE SUPPORTED.
MEASURES TO ADDRESS POLLUTION
CLEANUP FROM VARIOUS SOURCES AND
AFFORDABILITY MEASURES.
I'D ALSO PARTICULARLY LIKE TO
THINK CENTER MINING FOR COMING
TO OUR ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
POLICY COMMITTEE AND HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION WITH OUR MEMBERS.
IT WAS A VERY PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION BUT ULTIMATELY OUR
MEMBERS DID EXPRESS CONCERN FOR
THE FUNDING SOLUTION AS PART OF
MONTHLY WATER BILLS.
WE WOULD URGE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF SOME OF THE VARIOUS
ALTERNATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED INCLUDING.
TO THAT ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS
DISCUSS TODAY THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION --
THIS ISSUE IS NOT ONLY --
PROFESSIONALLY IMPORTANT OR
MEMBERS THE PERSONAL OUR MEMBERS
SERVE --
DISADVANTAGE --
COMMUNITY IS PREDOMINATELY AS A
CHILD CARE WORKERS BUT THEY ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY LIVE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES SO WE SUPPORT ANY
AND ALL EFFORTS THANK YOU.
BILL ALLEY --
ENVIRONMENT WORKING GROUP WE
SUPPORT THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
WE SIGNED ON TO THE LETTER THAT
MR WELL SOMEONE REFERRED TO THE
GOVERNOR.
IT INCLUDES THIS PLANK ABOUT
DRINKING WATER WEEK WERE NEUTRAL
ON THE SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR MONEY LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF OUR CONCERN WITH THE
SO CALLED SAFE HARBOR PROVISION
FOR AGRICULTURE.
I THINK THIS GAME IS MISS
SENATOR MINING --
LAID OUT JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO.
IS GOOD EXCEPT FOR A CONCERNED
ABOUT ACTUAL ENFORCEMENT BY THE
REGIONAL WATER PORTS ARE YOU CAN
SAY DO BMPS ETCETERA BUT IF
THEY'RE NOT ENFORCING IT
ACTUALLY OUT IN THE FIELD --
THAT'S OUR CONCERN BUT WE HOPE
TO WORK THIS OUT THIS YEAR AND
SUPPORT THIS CRITICAL NEED I
THINK THIS STORY BY TWENTY NINE
PALMS IS.
IS --
CHARACTERISTIC OF THE PROBLEM
OUT THERE WERE PEOPLE HAVE WATER
IN THIS EXPENSIVE TO FIX AND
THEY NEED URGENT FIXES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
POINT FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARC
IVERSON ON THE GENERAL MANAGER
OF WESTERN ART WATER COMPANY IN
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
WE ARE SERVE A CUSTOMER BASE
ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
75% ARE SENIORS ON FIXED INCOMES --
WILL KEEP IT SHORT --
WE UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM WE
SUPPORT THE TRUST FUND WE DON'T
SUPPORT THE TAX OPTION THEN WE'D
LIKE PLACES TABLE DISCUSS
ALTERNATIVE.
THANK YOU.
I GUESS IT'S STILL MORNING MY
NAME IS TIM GREEN A PRESIDENT.
OF WESTERN HEIGHTS WATER COMPANY
AS MARK RICHARD STATED WE SERVE
ABOUT TWENTY TO OUR CUSTOMERS WE
HAVE.
PLUMES WE HAVE T. C. P. WE HAVE
ISSUES AS WELL AS DOING THE GSA
COMPLIANT COUPLE ISSUES I WANT
TO ADDRESS NOT EVEN WHEN I CAME
HERE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE DO --
SUPPORT GALCO FUND US SENATE
MATHIS I BELIEVE YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT I THINK THEY
GAVE YOU ESTIMATE YOU COULD PLAY
MULTIPLIED BY THREE TO FOUR IF
NOT MORE KNOWING CALIFORNIA'S
TYPICAL AMOUNT FROM THESE TYPE
ISSUES.
BUT I'D ONE THING I DO HAVE TO
DO IS COMMANDTHIS --
THIS COMMITTEE FOR NOT KICKING
THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET ON THESE ISSUES AND MOVE
FORWARD.
BUT IN A LOT OF WAYS THE STATE
IS ITS BIGGEST PROBLEM FROM
REGULATORY ISSUES TO GETTING
RECYCLE PROGRAM THROUGH THE
GETTING --
RECYCLE BUT I MEAN GETTING BANDS
AND I MEAN --
JUST GETTING WATER INTO THE
GROUND TO HELP OUR OUR OUR
AQUIFER'S IS JUST SUCH A A DRAWN
OUT --
PROCESS AND I THINK GOAL LONG
WAY TO SOLVING A LOT OF THESE
LONG TERM ISSUES THAT YOU'VE
BROUGHT FORTH TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING I'M DOUG NATALIE ON
THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE NORTH
OF THE RIVER MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
START BAKERSFIELD --
SERVER COMMUNITY OF ABOUT.
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND OF PEOPLE
WE ARE TAKE PRIDE IN IN A WATER
SYSTEM.
THAT THE RATES ARE AFFORDABLE
AND WE PROVIDE CLEAN --
WATER SERVICE TO OUR CUSTOMERS
THIS TAX WOULD TEND --
TO HER OUR ABILITY IN THE FUTURE
TO MAINTAIN THAT WE HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS.
THAT NEED TO BE REPLACED --
ALONG WITH OTHER WATER QUALITY
ISSUES WE WANT TO STAY AHEAD OF
SO.
WE ARE NOT IN FAVOR THE TAX BUT
THE TRUST THAT I'VE HEARD HERE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD OPTION
I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE DETAIL.
AND I THINK THAT'S A GOOD OPTION.
THE OTHER THING I MIGHT --
THROW OUT HERE SUPPLY BRING
SALLY I KNOW KERN COUNTY WE HAVE
A ALLOCATION STATE WATER OF ONE
POINT ONE MILLION ACRE FEET.
THIS YEAR WE'VE GOT AN
ALLOCATION OF 10% SO HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE FEET TO MILLION
ACRE FEET.
THAT'S NOT BEING BROUGHT IN
ADDED TO THE BASIN.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S GOING TO HURT
WATER QUALITY WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON WATER SUPPLY. TO THE VALLEY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE FORWARD.
I'M OF THAT ORTEGA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES WE REALLY PRAISE YOUR
LEADERSHIP --
THE CHAIRS OF THESE COMMITTEES
FOR BRINGING CREATIVE IDEAS A
FEW YEARS AGO WE HAD ONE OF OUR
OWN WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED MUTUAL
WATER COMPANY MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE. THIRTY SIX OF THEM ONLY
THIRTY SIX OF THEM HAVE MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED CONNECTIONS THE
THIRTY SIX LARGER SYSTEMS HAVE
FUNDED A PROGRAM.
THAT NOW BRING ST CONTINUING
EDUCATION SAFETY TRAINING IN
ETHICS TRAINING TO SYSTEMS OF
ALL TYPES THAT HAVE MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED CONNECTIONS.
PART OF THE FUNDING IS MADE
POSSIBLE THROUGH A DRIVE POWERS
INSURANCE AT THE ALREADY.
THAT WAS MADE POSSIBLE THROUGH
AB SIX FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA THAT
HELPS US FUND THESE PROGRAMS WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN A POSITION YET ON
THE IDEA OF A TRUST --
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
THIS COMMITTEE REALLY SUPPORTS
CREATIVE APPROACHES AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE DOING
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MAXINE ISRAEL I'M A
DIRECTOR FOR CABS ON WATER
DISTRICT.
WHICH IS A SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
WE JUST UP OUR WATER RATES AND
HAVE TO TURN AROUND AND GIVE
THEM A TAX ON THEIR METER.
IS NOT FEASIBLE --
WE ALREADY PAY OUR COMMUNITY
VERY PAYS A TAX ON STATE WATER
WHICH WE DON'T EVEN SEE BECAUSE
THERE'S NO LYING TO CABS ON SO.
WHEN YOU'RE MAKING DECISION JUST
PLEASE LET US HAVE A FEW YOUR
TABLE THANK YOU?
HELLO I'M KRISTIN COMPTON WITH
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT WE
SERVE A POPULATION OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND FULL TIME
RESIDENTS AND DURING THE DAYTIME
THAT GOES UP TO OVER HALF
MILLION.
WE REALLY.
BUT YOU FOR TODAY'S AGREEMENT
WE'RE ALL WILLING TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND WORK ON THE
CHALLENGE WE URGE YOU TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE FUNDING ALTERNATIVES
TO PUT OUR HAVE BEEN PUT FORTH.
THERE REALLY CAN PROVIDE THAT
STABLE LONG TERM APPROACH BUT WE
ALSO REALLY URGE YOU TO LOOK AT
PROPOSALS THAT ADDRESS THE
TECHNICAL MANAGER OWN
GOVERNMENT'S ISSUES BECAUSE WE
DON'T ADDRESS THOSE WERE NOT
GONNA MOVE.
CALIFORNIA TO SUSTAINABILITY
THANK YOU.
TEARS MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY NO
AUTOMATIC WITH THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE AND I WILL JUST SIMPLY
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
I HAVE SEEN YOU A AKHLAQ AND
PAULA JONES FROM EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA DAVIS THAT I
WHAT THAT CITY OF OCEANSIDE --
AGAIN I DO ECHO WHAT THE REST TO
HAVE -- SAID
BEFORE ME --
THE CITY DOES THAT POSE THE TAX
AND IS SUPPORTIVE OF THAT TRUST.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING --
IMPROVE JONES I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE ORDER LINDA WATER DISTRICT --
IN -- WE IN
SHORT -- WE
AND WE OPPOSE THE WATER TAX --
PAUL JONES PRESENTATION --
SHOULD --
DESCRIBED VERY CLEARLY WHAT WHAT
MIGHT HAPPEN APPARENTLY A TWENTY
FIFTY AB.
TWENTY FIFTY PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE QUITE WELL BUT THE
GOVERNOR FOUNDED IT WOULD CREATE
BUREAUCRACY AND DID NOT HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING I THINK THE
FUNDING IS THE PROBLEM.
UP WE SEE MORE BUREAUCRACY IN
THE COLLECTION OF THE TAX WE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO COLLECT THE
TAX WITHOUT SPENDING.
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
AMOUNT COLLECTED TO COLLECT IT
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR US.
THANK YOU AGAIN --
I'VE JUST TURNED THEIR THIRTY
PEOPLE OUTSIDE WHO WANT TO SPEAK --
SO WHAT I WOULD ASK IS THAT YOU
TRYING TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS BECAUSE WE
WILL STOP AT TWELVE THIRTY GOOD
AFTERNOON BARBARIC IN PRE A WITH
RESTORE THE DELTA.
WE HAVE SIXTY THOUSAND FOLLOWERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE DO
SUPPORT THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING --
WATER FUND HAS PROPOSED WE DO
SUPPORT A SMALL TAX WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT SAFE HARBOR
ISSUES.
AROUND AGRICULTURAL DISCHARGE.
AND IN TERMS OF A TRUST FUND WE
WILL LOOK TO LEADERSHIP BY
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER.
IF THEY BEGIN TO SEE THAT IT'S
WILLFUL COMMUNITIES WE WILL
FOLLOW SUIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI AMOUNT DAVIS WHO COVERS ON
WATER JUST CHECK.
AND WE SUPPORT THE TROUGH BURNED
YOU KNOW PAUL JONES [inaudible]
AND I'D LIKE YOUR COMMENT MISTER
MATHIS ABOUT --
THE TRUSTED SAID OF TAXES.
AND MR GARCIA ALSO YOU IT --
AT STAGE COACH [inaudible]
COACHELLA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CALVIN LOUIS ON THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE CAT WAS
ON WATER DISTRICT.
WE SERVE ABOUT --
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED RESIDENTS
NOW WITH EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE ACTIVE CONNECTION.
AND 50% OF ARE SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED AND THE OTHER HALF
IS --
DISADVANTAGE --
AND OUR DISTRICT HAS BEEN.
COMPLYING WITH THE STATE WATER
CALLS WATER QUALITY --
REQUIREMENT YOU SCREWED UP JUST --
WRAP UP.
PLEASE.
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT.
THE SAME BETTER.
NO I JUST IF YOU COULD FINISH I
THINK WE GOT YOUR POINT IF YOU
COULD JUST MAKE YOUR FINAL
SENTENCE AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GO.
VERY QUICKLY HERE SO IF YOU
COULD JUST FINISH UP.
WITH THAT SAID --
BASICALLY.
I MY SENSE OF THE SAME AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A SEAT.
AT THE TABLE --
TO NEGOTIATE --
SOME RESOLUTE NEXT.
RAQUEL AYALA ON BEHALF OF
ELDORADO YOUR RECREATION
DISTRICT THIS ARE WATER AGENCIES
ROLLING WATER DISTRICT AND
WALNUT VALLEY WATER DISTRICT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE TRUST FUND
THAT HAS BEEN --
PROPOSED BY AQUA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE YOUNG THE DREAM
TIME HERE FOR YOU BUT WATER
AGENCY AND WE ALSO JUST WANT TO
SUPPORT THE INNOVATIVE AND
INTELLIGENT APPROACH OUTLINED BY
C. ANYWAY AND AQUA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELANIE CUEVAS
WITH CAN TANA WHAT'S IN HER MEN
ON THE HOUSE ON BEHALF OF EAST
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT WE ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF AQUA
AND SEE ANYWAY AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MICHAEL
HADLEY ON THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
OFFICER FOR WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT WHICH AROUND A
MILLION PEOPLE IN WEST RIVERSIDE
COUNTY ON A RETAIL AND WHOLESALE
WATER BASIS AND WHILE
HISTORICALLY BEEN IF OPPOSE THE
ATTACKS.
WERE VERY EXCITED AND IN FAVOR
OF SEEM AN ARC WAS SEEKING WATER
TRUST THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
MY NAME'S EDDY COME ON I AM THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST
GRASSROOTS FAITH BASED
ORGANIZING NETWORK IN THE STATE --
WE JUST WANT TO SUPPORT A
PERMANENT SOLUTION THAT HAPPENS
THIS YEAR IMMEDIATELY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WE'RE OPEN TO THE
CREATIVE IDEAS PRESENTED BY THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME IS
NATIONALLY KAPLAN DALY I WORK
WITH IMAGINE EACH TO A WE WORK
EXCLUSIVELY WITH WATER
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES.
AND EVERYONE HERE ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT INNOVATION TECH OUR PART OF
THE SOLUTION BUT TECH COMPANIES
FACE MANY CHALLENGES IN GETTING
OUT INTO THE FIELD SO THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SUPPORT DEPLOYMENT BETA
TESTING --
EASE THE CONTRACTING PROCESS AS
MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE SURE
THE TECH THAT EXIST CAN GET OUT
AND THAT THE TECH THAT NEEDS TO
BE DEVELOPED CAN BE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BRIEFLY
INTRODUCING A NEW TOPIC.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER CLEARING THE
WATER PROGRAM MANAGER FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION I LIKE TO THINK THE
THREE COMMITTEES FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING.
IN THE TWO YEARS TWO PLUS YEARS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
BILL I THINK WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
MOVEMENT I PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE.
THE WATER AGENCIES FOR
SUPPORTING CONSOLIDATION WHICH
THEY OPPOSE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS PROCESS AND FOR COMING UP
WITH ALTERNATIVE.
I IT WOULD BE GREAT IF THEY
COULD RAISE STICK WELLS AND I
THINK THAT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN
THE LAST RENDITION OF THEIR
TRUST FUND THEY ONLY LOOK TO
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS.
AND NOT THE ONE AND A HALF TO
TWO MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARTS ARE
BY A PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM SO
LET'S BE SURE THAT WE GET A
SOLUTION THAT COVERS EVERYBODY
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU CHAIR IS A MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS VERY MUCH WANT TO THANK
THE LEADERSHIP FROM THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS ISSUE REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE ADVOCATES ON GETTING
SOMETHING DONE AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THE SAFE INFORMAL DRINKING WATER
FIND.
IN PROVIDING A PERMANENT
SOLUTION FOR THESE FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WHO HAVE TO GO HOME
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND DRINK DIRTY
WATER LET'S GET SOMETHING DONE
THIS YEAR THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU.
AFTER HIS CHAIRMAN GREG'S Là
NICK WITH THE SAN JUAN WATER
DISTRICT WE SERVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOLKS IN
EASTERN SACRAMENTO IN SOUTHERN
PLASTER COUNTY.
AND TREAT WATER FOR ANOTHER
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE SUPPORT OCT
WAS EFFORTS AND ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH PAUL JONES AND
WAS COMMENTS.
AND AS YOU HEARD TODAY THERE ARE
A LOT OF NUMBERS BANDIED AROUND
ABOUT NEED.
I BEHOOVES THESE --
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT WHAT SORT
OF CAPITAL NEEDS THERE ARE THAT
CAN HELP FACILITATE
CONSOLIDATION AS WELL AS THE ON
GOING OWN M. NEEDS FOR THOSE
THAT CAN'T BE CONSOLIDATED OR
NEED THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THANK YOU FOR FINISHING --
IN THE APPROPRIATE TIME WHICH IS
THIRTY SECONDS OF THOSE OF
YOU'VE JUST COME IN IF YOU COULD
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO ABOUT
THIRTY SECONDS THANK YOU.
I HAVE TO DO IS FROM TULARE
COUNTY BY CITY AND I STAND HERE
AND SPEAK FOR ALL THOSE.
OF PEOPLE THAT CAN'T BE HERE AND
SPEAK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH MY NAME IS RICK MARTINEZ
AND I AM FROM THE A COMMUNITY DO
COR CALIFORNIA AND I AM A MEMBER
OF THE COMMUNITY.
DO COR COMMUNITY SERVICE
DISTRICT I'M HERE BECAUSE BEFORE
I STARTED WITHOUT WELL I WAS
ALWAYS --
WITH CESAR CHAVEZ AND THE U. F.
W. AND WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
CLEAN WATER EVER SINCE HE WAS
ALIVE SO I HOPE THAT THIS YEAR
WE CAN GET THIS DONE.
AND HAVE A PERMANENT.
SOLUTION TO OUR PROBLEMS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI ME NUMBERS ON THAT I SEE YEAH.
MY NAME IS SENDING A CO.
EVEN THE LOCAL MANY OTHER
POPULAR AND I COME FROM THE
POPULAR POPULAR COMMUNITY BUT
CURRENT I KNOW SET THE MODEL I
WORK ON THE THAT THOSE.
AND I'VE.
HAD WATER WITH CONNIE BRITTON.
WITH HIGH GREAT FOR FORTY YEARS.
ET LAKE IT I SEE YEAH MIGHT
THESE MIGHT THESE DOES GO MONEY
THAT IS THEN IS A SEAT THEN.
AND I WANNA ASK MATHIS MATHIS
YOUR COMMUNITIES NEED YOU SO I
DID WHAT OTHER LAWS POTUS THEM
YOU WENT THAT CALL ME WHAT THE
ONE THE ONE I YEAH.
I ASKED HIM WE WENT NO SPIN SOME
GIVEN UNTO CHAD OR MY THRILLED
THAT IT SHOWS ONE MYSELF GO
MONEY THAT IS SIMPLE THIS.
ITEM.
BEFORE BUT SO ARE VOTE COUNTS MY
VOTE COUNTS WHEN YOU GO AND
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITIES OVER
THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HIGH NUMBER MY KOREAN.
MY NAME IS MARK ACCORDION THAT
BOARD I KNOW THAT THE MODEL OUT
ONE MORE E. MY LOVE BUT I'M NOT
A LITTLE ONLY THE OTHER SYLVIA.
AND TO CONDUCT A LADY I COME
FROM THE SEVILLE COUNTY AND A
COMMUNITY IT'S THE BILL AND TO
LEARN COUNTY.
NEAR THE PRESENT UP TO ME AT A
PRESIDENTE NOT THAT THAT'S
CIVILE FROM FULLER.
MY REPRESENTATIVE THIS IS MY
THINK.
A KEY THEN GO UP WE GET A LOOK
IN THE PAST ENOUGH THAT YOU'RE
NOT BESIDE IF THE PHONE THOUGH
PUBLIC OKAY YES WE ONLY TOOK
THEM IN.
I'VE COME HERE TO SUPPORT THE
PASSING OF THIS FUND BECAUSE
I'VE SUFFERED A LOT IS A LITTLE
BIT THAT IT BOTH OPEN TO OTHER
EAT. TOO LITTLE FINANCING NOW
WHAT THEY OWN A PRIVATE WELL AND
I WAS WITHOUT WATER FOR TWO
YEARS.
ALSO THOUGHT IT'S ENOUGH BUT AND
PUT US ON A VEHICLE AND MY
HUSBAND HAD HAD A RECENT HEART
OPEN HEART SURGERY LIST OF WOULD
BE MORE CHOCOLATE KIT LEW
LISTING ON THE BUS OF I WANT.
ENOUGH TO REPEAT THAT AND
DUMBELLS WE SUFFERED A LOT
BECAUSE A NEIGHBOR WOULD BRING
WATER OVER IN THIS AREA DON'T
WHICH AND THEN TOOK A LOT OF THE
NEW ONE NIGHT AND THEY THEY I
WANT.
BUT NOT THAT OFTEN WE SUFFERED A
LOT IN THE HEAT BECAUSE WE HAD A
BARREL OF WATER THAT HE KNOWS
EVEN LESS THAN THAT OTHER WHO
NEVER BUT I SENT IN THE FOOT IS
COOL AND WE WOULD GO SIT UNDER A
TREE TO FEEL SOME RELIEF A LOT
THEY DON'T.
WANT TO ADMIT I WASN'T NOT THAT
INFAMOUS AND THOUGHT I DO WHAT I
TROUBLE A LOT OF TIMES THEY
DON'T.
AND THEY DON'T BELIEVE ME BUT I
WOULD SIT DOWN AND CRY LE LET
THESE DAYS OKAY I'M IS VANESSA
MICHELLE I WORK FOR A COMPANY
WATER CENTER AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO
REALLY NEEDS A SOLUTION TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LIBBY HADLEY AND A
COMPROMISE SO YOU CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS TULARE COUNTY AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE TO HAVE
CLEAN WATER.
THAT'S BEEN CONTAMINATED THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LESLIE
HERNANDEZ AND I'M FROM WEST
GOSHEN AD THAT SAYS CONEY ISLAND
LITTLE COMMUNITY TULARE COUNTY
MY REPRESENTATIVE IS MATHIS.
AND I'M HERE TO ASK FOR SUPPORT
FOR THESE FOR THESE THAT
HORRIBLE DRINKING WATER.
FINE FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE TULARE COUNTY IS ONE OF
THE COMING OF THE HAS MORE THE
MOST CONTAMINATED WATER.
IN IT IS TIME TO GIVE US A
LISTEN TO ALL THIS TIME IT IS I
NEEDED WE ARE THE ONES THAT PAY
THE MOST MONEY.
FOR TAXI WATER THAT WE CANNOT
DRINK IT WITH THE POOREST
FAMILIES AND LIKE IN THE VALLEY
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOE SEEN
YET THOUGH I COME FROM MY LITTLE
COMMUNITY OF SEVILLE.
TELERI CONNING MISTER MATHIS IS
ALSO ARE REPRESENT MY
REPRESENTATIVE.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR CRISIS
HELP ON GETTING A PERMANENT
SOLUTION FOR THIS WATER I HAVE
BEEN ON THIS MISSION FOR TEN
YEARS.
I HAVE GRANDKIDS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MY BRANCHES CHILDREN
BE ABLE TO DRINK GOOD WATER AND
NOT BE AFRAID OF IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EDDIE
GOT FED MENACE SAVE IN EXETER
CALIFORNIA I WORK FOR A
COMMUNITY WIDER CENTER AT THE
DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZING.
BUT I'M HERE ASKING ME BACK TO
RESIDENT WITH A DOMESTIC WELL
THAT IS CONTAMINATED WITH
NITRATES SO TODAY I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THAT SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FINE AND A
PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR NOT ONLY
ME.
BUT THAT RESIDENTS THAT ARE HERE
TO TELL YOU NOW.
HI MY NAME IS ED HERE AN AWFUL
TULARE NOW WHAT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO BRING THE MICROPHONE CLOSER.
HI MY NAME IS ADDED HERE I'M
FROM TO LARRY AND I WANT CLEAN
WATER.
THANK YOU.
OKAY GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
BROWN'S NUMBER TO LARRY NO ONE
CLEAN WATER GREAT.
HI MY NAME IN ONE SET IN A ONE
CLEAN WATER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET US ARE THEN THE NUMBER THAT
I CAN SIGN CHEST.
HELLO MY NAME IS RECORD FOR THIS
MAINLAND UP ONLY THAT TO LEARN
IT.
I COME FROM THE COMMUNITY OF
TULARE FOR FOLLOWER.
I DO LITTLE SECOND WAS THAT I
WAS TELLING HIM VIA BUT A TOTAL
SETTLEMENT.
PLEASE HELP US HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR ALL HUMAN
BEINGS IN THIS PRESENT ON ME SEE
HOSTESS ON A FULL TOTAL IN MY
NANA AND THOSE ARE MY CHILDREN
THAT WILL BE THE FUTURE OF
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN I ASK THAT
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE KEEP THEIR
COMMENTS TO THIRTY SECONDS OR
LESS OR NOT CAN BE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE THANK YOU.
CAN I GET YOUR PHONE FROM MY
SITES WHERE COUNTY AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT SAFE AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FINE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA QUAKER BASED LOBBY --
WE THINK THAT THIS IS A SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND ECONOMIC ISSUE --
SOLVING IT WILL REQUIRE A
RELIABLE AND I'M GOING FUNDING
STREAM --
WHAT WE THINK IT'S VERY
REASONABLE AND WE'RE VERY
WILLING TO TAX OURSELVES --
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THAT SO THAT
ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS CAN
HAVE SAY THANK YOU.
HELLO ON THE SALE TO RAMPANT.
WALL LIKE YOU SAY LET'S KEEP
CHORE IN THE RIGHT TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MISSION CONTROL
COMMUNITIES AND AND PLEASE AND
YOU HAVE THAT PUBLIC TO DO IT
THESEUNIQUE THE YEAR.
AND NOW EASING DECIDE TO MAKE A
DECISION.
NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I BROTHERS --
WHAT OF THE OTHER?
HELLO I DON'T.
KNOW IS THAT WHEN WITHIN A MONTH
WITH LOW BLOOD.
THE OKAY.
HI THIS IS ESTHER AND SHE IS
FROM I'LL POP FROM TAYLOR COUNTY.
OVERLOOKED IS THERE ISN'T GOING
THE NUMBER OF THOSE OF US ON FOR
HIS OWN TO START OF COUPLE SAID
THIS.
ISN'T AS WELL AS YOUR DOWN AT
THE SECOND OKAY COUNTY FEDERAL
OF HOMES THAT THERE IS A
PERMANENT SOLUTION BECAUSE YOU
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR OVER FOURTEEN
YEARS NOW THE LEADER BECAUSE HE
THEIR NATION.
WE NEED PROTECT US ALL THEY
WATER PLEASE STAND TO THE
FARMERS THAT USES LESS FIFTY
CENTS. TO THE LAND WE NEED
DRINKING WATER CLEAN PURE AND
CAN'T BE GOD BLESS YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PAUL H.
GARCIA MY COMMUNITY LEADER.
MERCED COUNTY AND DELL HI
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE THAT.
THAT I PRAY FOR ALL OF YOU THAT
YOU MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION AND
TO HAVE SAFE AND CLEAN WATER FOR
THE WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS.
NICHOLAS A. NETTLES AND I COME
FROM ON FROM WRESTLING MAKERS --
COMMUNITY AND BAKER SIR
CALIFORNIA KERN COUNTY.
AND I REPRESENT THAT AREA.
I TALKED TO MY MY COMMUNITY AND
THEY THEY SAID THAT I COULD BE A
GREAT IDEA TO IT TO PASS THIS
BILL THIS SAFE AND AFFORDABLE OF
DRINKING WATER.
SAW --
KICKED UP TRUST THAT THAT
COMMUNITY PUTTING YOU GUYS AND
AND HELP US A I HAVE A A
HEALTHIER COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU AND GOD BLESS.
GOOD NOON HOUR TO EVERYBODY IN
MY NAME IS BETTER ON AT ON THIS
I AM A POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WERE ALSO
WORKING IN DEVON MATHIS IS
DISTRICT --
I USED TO BE A TEACHER --
I'VE SPENT ABOUT TEN YEARS OF MY
LIFE FOR PAYING FOR EDUCATION.
TO WRAP UP YES AND I'M ABOUT TO
SIR -- I
JUST SWITCHED MY ENTIRE LIFE
CHOICES AND FIELD OF WORK TO
ADDRESS THE DRINKING WATER.
CRISIS AND I HOPE YOU ALL --
RECOGNIZE THE CRISIS AS WELL.
WHEN I THOUGHT THIS?
NUMBER OF I KNOW THAT MY MOM
GIVING BUT ELECT ONLY THAT THEY
MY BE IN THIS THAT.
IN THE LATTER.
RIGHT NOW.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AMANDA PLAYING THEN THE BOTTOM
LINE IN THE PROBLEM.
BEING VIOLATED.
CANNELLA GLADYS IT MIGHT BE MISS
THAT I'M COMING IN FROM THE COLD
TO ARTISTIC COUNTY YES CORRECT
YES.
IT IS THAT I HAVE A DRINK WILL
OF I BELIEVE THE PROBLEM AGAIN
OKAY YOU LADIES AND BEAT IT OUT
WOW REALLY COME OVER TO ASSIST
YOU WITHOUT.
WE ME AND WATER CLEAN.
CLEAN WHAT LEASE PLEASE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THAT THAT'S A FINI TRACK AND
TULARE -- MY
NUMBER IS A LITTLE KI?M MY
NAME IS TO LOOK TO HEAR FROM A
MAN WITH A LOT OF MONEY THAT
THEY MONTINI TRAXX AND POLITICAL
MEAN ALSO FOR THE COMMUNITY WHAT
TO WRITE CRITICAL COLORADO SICK
A LOT I BELIEVE.
AYE TO SAME RECYCLING BYTHE F..
IDEASCAN ABOUT A ONE DOLLAR
MILLIMETER GETTING ANY MONEY ONE
DOLLAR [inaudible]
HE I WANNA SEE.
AN EVEN THOUGH SINGLE MOTHER
SAYS A MUSKET GETTING GO
ADEQUATE HAVE WHOSE.
STORY.
YOU NEED TO RUN.
IN THE BATTLE BATTLE BUT IF YOU
DON'T NEED A CHECK BUT I WHAT I
NEED TO COME OVER I WANTED TO DO
MORE TO FIGHT FOR WATER
POLITICAL ILLEGAL EVERYTHING
WHAT I'M SAYING IS FOR OKAY IS
IT -- FOR
SUPPORT UNLESS THE VEHICLE --
USED THIS BILL BUT THIS WILL BE
A MOMENTOUS BILL FORECAST UP A
WELL WE NEED TO WRAP UP
SOMETHING OR NO ONE ELSE IS
GOING TO GET THE FINAL STADIUM.
IS THIS A LOT OF THE THAT TO
SAVE A LIFE NOISE NO MUST THAT
WHEN HE DOES NOT ONLY IF
SOMEBODY LEVY THIS EVENING OF
GIVING AN ANNOYING YEAH ONCE A
MONTH. TO SAVE IT ECOSYSTEM ME
WITH.
BUT INSTEAD.
IS TO SAY FOR THE LIFE OF THOSE
GET THEM TO COME OVER AND THE
LOWER KEYS THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE IMPORTED SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA AND I'M A
STUDENT AT STANFORD LAW SCHOOL --
WHEN I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA A FEW
YEARS AGO I WAS REALLY SHOCKED
TO FIND OUT ABOUT THE EXTREME
PROBLEMS WITH DRINKING WATER IN
THE STATE GIVING IT'S GIVEN
CALIFORNIA'S REPUTATION --
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND SO --
I SUPPORT THIS EVEN AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FIND AS A WAY TO
IMPLEMENT THE STATE'S RECOGNIZE
HIM IN RIGHT TO WATER THINK YEAH.
RIGHT TO GIVE EVERYONE TIME.
I'M GOING TO WARN YOU IT FIFTEEN
SECONDS TO WRAP UP THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S LAURA THE HEN AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATE WITH HELP
HURT THE PUBLIC INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP AND WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE CREATION
OF A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND.
WE'RE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE THREAT PRESENTED BY
LEAD CONTAMINATION WHICH WE'VE
LEARNED MORE ABOUT AS EQUALS A
TIME TO WRAP UP TESTING SO.
THANK YOU WE URGE AT ACTION THIS
YEAR IN Q. AND I AM A DIRECTOR
OF THE CARMICHAEL WATER DISTRICT.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU --
TAKE A VERY GOOD --
A LOOK AT THAT THE TRUST THAT
WAS PROPOSED OR IS OFFERED AS A
SUGGESTION BY OUR PAUL JONES.
AND ALSO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THE THE THE UNREST TIME TO WRAP
UP YES SIR AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANNA
VASQUEZ I'M HERE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ROOM TO JUST
SOMEONE'S AND JUST WANT TO ECHO
ALL THE COMMONSENSE DEMONS THAT
THE RESIDENTS FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
HAVE STATED AND WE SUPPORT A
PERMANENT FUND FOR C. BEFORE
DRINKING WATER.
THINKING.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSE IS THE CHAIR THAT
ARE SUPPORT THE UPPER --
THE FUN AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA'S BUT
THE PROPOSAL AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M STRUCK ROSECRANS I'M
REPRESENTING RESTORE HETCH
HETCHY I WORKED A WATER POLICY
FOR MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS WATER
IN CALIFORNIA IS A PUBLIC
RESOURCE.
OWNED BY THE STATE BUT IS
DISTRIBUTION IS OFTEN
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR WE BELIEVE
THAT UNFAIRNESS CAN BE.
LESSENED BY APPLYING --
THE FUNDS THROUGH WATER BILLS TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM THAT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO SOLVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MARTHA DAVIS I'M ON THE BOARDS
OF THE BOTTLE LIKE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMUNITY WATER CENTER THANK
YOU FOR THIS HEARING I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE WATER FUN.
BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO LOOK AT ALL THESE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS IN TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE SOLVE THE IMMEDIATE
PROBLEM BUT ULTIMATELY ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES FACE THESE
LEGACY PROBLEMS.
AND WE HAVE TO CUT RATES
SOMETHING THAT WILL ADDRESS THAT
AS WELL THANK YOU.
MATTHEW BAKER WITH PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE PCO FULLY
SUPPORTS A FINE FOR PROVIDING
SAFE IN FOR WOULD RING WATER FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND WE THANK
YOU FOR THIS DISCUSSION GIVE US
ABILITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM ROBIN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT MANY
ELEMENTS OF THE PROPOSED SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
ON FUNDING WE DO SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTIVE ALTERNATIVES THAT
ARE BEING PUT FORTH INCLUDING
THE TRUST ON GOVERNANCE WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
UP THOSE PUT FORTH BY THE
ASSOCIATION'S THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLINGIANS
ADVOCATE PEOPLE THE WATER AGENCY
IN LESSONS WATER DISTRICT --
WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH AQUA
AND THANK YOU FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. THREE SEPARATE MITCH ON
BEHALF OF SERIES SERIES THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WORKING
TO MOBILIZE INVESTORS AND
BUSINESS LEADERSHIP TO BUILD A
THRIVING SUSTAINABLE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
ARE BUSINESS PARTNERS DEPEND ON
RELIABLE GOOD QUALITY WATER
STORES IN CALIFORNIA FOR BOTH
THEIR OPERATIONS IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEM PLEASING
CUSTOMERS LIVE.
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR FINDING A SOLUTION TO THIS
CRIME CRITICAL ISSUE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEXANDER HER
NAME WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY --
FOR THE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
WE REPRESENT A LACK OF CLEAN
WATER THREATENS PHYSICAL HEALTH
ACADEMIC WELL --
PERFORMANCE ECONOMIC WELL BEING
AND HOUSING STABILITY AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FROM
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
RICHARD HARRIS ON BEHALF OF A
LIVE IN HAND MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN NORTHERN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND WE'LL JUST ASSOCIATED
REMARKS WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER.
SAYS ASIAN AQUA AND MISTER JONES
IS PRESENTATION ON THE TRUST
FUND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LUCAS FRERICHS ON BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY WE
APPRECIATED CENTER MUNNINGS
LEADERSHIP LAST YEAR AND SB SIX
TWENTY THREE SUPPORTED THEN WE
SUPPORT CREATION OF FUN NOW AND
CREATE YOU.
FOR HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY WE
COULD DISCUSS THESE ISSUES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GAIL THEY'LL HAND WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION DID --
TO THAT GENTLEMAN'S COMMENTS
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO THE THREE
RESPECTIVE CHAIRMAN LOUIS BROWN
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL AND CALIFORNIA FOR FOOD
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE CENTER
MONIES LEADERSHIP THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PICKING THIS
UP AND SEEING IT THROUGH WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TRACY PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
WE REMAIN IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF A SUSTAINABLE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND --
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF THOSE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED AND BELIEVE IT'S OUR
COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
SOLVE THIS AS A STATE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM VALDERRAMA
WITH THE VITAMIN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF NEXT GEN AMERICA I JUST WANT
TO ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS WITH --
AT BASICALLY EVERYTHING THAT'S
ON ARE MINING SAID TODAY HE WAS
SPOT ON I DO WANT TO SAY THAT IT
IT'S EASY TO RECOGNIZE A PROBLEM
IN IT TAKES REAL LEADERSHIP TO
TECH -- FOR
JUST SOLUTION AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT THIS
YEAR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRYST A GUARANTEE --
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND
THANKS TO CENTER MINING AND ALL
THE TEARS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
TOWARDS THAT GOAL THIS YEAR.
JASON BRIDE WESTERN UNITED DAIRY
MEN WANT TO THANK GOVERNOR
NEWSON HIS MINISTRATION CENTER
MONIES AND HIS STAFF THE CHAIRS
THIS COMMITTEE --
THIS ORGANIZATION SUPPORTED SB
SIX TWENTY THREE LAST YEAR AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO A
SOLUTION THAT MIRRORS THAT MODEL
AND THE ENGAGE IN THE PROCESS
THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
LEON TROUT NOT BE HALF OF THE
WATER FOUNDATION WITH ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE LEADERSHIP OF THESE
COMMITTEES AND OF COURSE SENATOR
MINING FOR HIS YEARS OF
LEADERSHIP AND FIGHTING TO
PROTECT THESE COMMUNITIES AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AT THAT.
DRINKING WATER FUND THANK YOU.
THANKS.
GOOD MORNING PUBLIC OURS WITH
ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FINE LAST
BUT NOT LEAST BUT WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR --
REALLY THINK WE NEED A DEDICATED
FUNDING SOLUTION FOR THIS
PROBLEM AND SINCE STRONG SUPPORT
AGAIN THIS YEAR AND THANKS FOR
THE LEADERSHIP OF EVERYONE ON
THE COMMITTEE. FOR HOLDING THIS
YEAR I WANT TO THANK
PARTICULARLY THE PEOPLE CAME
NEAR THE END AND KEPT THEIR
COMMENTS TO FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SECOND SO.
WE HAVE FINISHED --
I WILL SAY AS FAR AS THE TRUST
FUND GOES ACTUAL WILL AIR EARLY
IF YOU WANT TO PUT.
MONEY ASIDE FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME YOU SHOULD NOT EXPECT AND
YOU WANT TO MEET DEMANDS WITH
INFLATION YOU SHOULD NOT EXPECT
MORE THAN ABOUT A 3% RATE OF
RETURN ON AVERAGE.
THAT MEANS FOR THREE BILLION
DOLLAR TRUST FUND YOU WOULD GET
ABOUT NINETY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
THAT'S BELOW THE HUNDRED AND
FORTY WE'VE TALKED ABOUT --
YOU NEED ABOUT FIVE BILLION TO
GET UP TO THE HUNDRED AND FORTY
IN MISTER MATHIS AND OTHER SHE
SPOKE SAY WE REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE COST IS YET.
SO YOU'RE GONNA NEED A HELL OF A
TRUST FUND JUST SAYING --
WE ALSO HEARD CONCERNS ABOUT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE HEARD
THOSE --
THERE ANY FINAL COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS AND THEN FROM THE TWO
CHAIRS.
MR MATHIS IS ONE I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE FOLKS FROM MY DISTRICT
YOU MADE THE DRIVE UP HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY --
I THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY
SEVERAL CHALLENGES AS STATED
WITH THE FINANCIAL ASPECTS ON
HOW TO DO THIS I DO LIKE THE
TRUST FUND IDEA.
ON THERE'S ALSO THE IDEA THAT
I'M SHE'S A GUARANTEED 2% OF THE
GENERAL FUND TO GO TOWARDS --
NOT JUST CLEAN DRINKING WATER
BUT ALSO STORES CONVEYANCE
RECHARGING CETERA --
AND I WOULD LOVE TO TALK WITH
MORE OUT THERE ABOUT MAYBE
COMBINING THAT WITH A TRUST FUND
IDEA -- TO
LOOK AT HOW TO ACTUALLY GET THE
PROPER FUNDING NECESSARY TO
GUARANTEE IT FOR THE FUTURE
WITHOUT HAVING TO TAX.
OR PEOPLE TO ENSURE WE DO HAVE A
SAFE RELIABLE FUND.
AND GUARANTEED TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER FOR ALL.
THANK YOU AS CENTER MINING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE CO CHAIRS AND
THIS PARTICULAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO
APPEARED TODAY MANY WHO TRAVELED
LONG DISTANCES.
AYE SPECIAL WANTING KNOWLEDGE
THOSE WHO COME AT THEIR OWN
EXPENSE IN WHO OF MADE
PILGRIMAGES HERE. FOR YEARS. TO
TELL US ABOUT THE CRISIS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND I WOULD JUST KERR --
WHICH SHARE QUIRK.
THE TRUST FUND IDEA IS.
IS AN INTERESTING PROPOSAL WERE
OPEN TO ANY AND ALL OPTIONS.
BUT I WILL SAY.
AS CHAIR QUIRK INDICATED.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A FIVE OR
SIX BILLION DOLLAR.
CORPUS TO GENERATE THE LOW END
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
NECESSARY I WOULD ALSO REMIND US
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WHO EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT
PAYING A FEE OR A TAX?
OUR BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
EXEMPTS PEOPLE UP 22100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE THAT
DOESN'T GET EVERYBODY BUT IT
GETS A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR WHOM.
NINETY FIVE CENTS A MONTH WOULD
BE A HARDSHIP.
IN AGAIN I RETURNED TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN RIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR STATE.
I WOULD ASK EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM IF YOU HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PAY NINETY FIVE CENTS A MONTH.
WOULD YOU MEET THAT CHALLENGE.
I THINK MOST OF YOU IN YOUR
HEART WOULD FIND THE ABILITY. TO
PAY THAT THAT THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S.
LEADERSHIP IN HIS TEAM --
MY DOOR WILL REMAIN OPEN TO ANY
AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS --
WHO WANT TO WORK TOWARDS THIS
AGAIN THANK YOU CO CHAIRS THANK
YOU MEMBERS SOME PARTICULARLY TO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
TRAVELED AT THEIR OWN EXPENSE TO
BE HERE THANK THANK YOU SIR?
IS TO BLOOM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET ME BE
VERY BRIEF.
LET THIS BE THE YEAR THAT WE
FINALLY RESOLVE THIS ISSUE --
CHAIRS YOU.
THINK UP EVERYTHING HAS BEEN SET
WHAT THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED.
THOSE WHO REMAINED.
THAT'S A MISTAKE ABOUT BEING
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION YOU
ARE AT THE TABLE.
AND WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL REMAIN
ENGAGED --
THERE WILL BE OTHER HEARINGS AND
THEREFORE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN INPUT --
EST AND WILL HAVE A HEARING SUB
THREE WILL HAVE A HEARING AND
THE POSSIBILITY OF ANOTHER
HEARING.
ON THE MATTER --
IS BEING CONSIDERED SO A STAIN
GAUGE WITH THAT.
LOT OF GOOD IDEAS MAYBE MY BAD
IDEA.
BUT BUT NEVER THE LESS WE THINK
THAT THIS HAS BEEN FRUITFUL AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PUTTING OUT
SOME LANGUAGE THAT'S REFLECTIVE
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WE'VE HEARD --
FOR ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK AND LET
THIS BE THE YEAR THAT WE GET
THIS DONE THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION